hello everyone
welcome to this full course video on
machine learning with python
in this video we will cover everything
you need to know to become an expert in
machine learning
our experienced instructors with good
industry experience will take you
through this course
first you will understand the basics of
machine learning from a short animated
video
you will then know the essential
applications of machine learning
you will understand machine learning
concepts and learn why mathematics
statistics and linear algebra are
crucial
then we will focus on some vital machine
learning algorithms such as linear
regression
logistic regression decision trees
random forest and k nearest neighbors
you will also learn about regularization
dimensionality reduction
and principal component analysis we will
perform a prediction analysis on the
recently held u.s elections as well
finally you will study the machine
learning roadmap for 2021
so let's begin we know humans learn from
their past experiences
and machines follow instructions given
by humans
but what if humans can train the
machines to learn from the past data and
do what humans can do
and much faster well that's called
machine learning but it's a lot more
than just
learning it's also about understanding
and reasoning so today
we will learn about the basics of
machine learning
so that's paul he loves listening to new
songs
he either likes them or dislikes them
paul decides this
on the basis of the song's tempo genre
intensity and the gender of voice for
simplicity
let's just use tempo and intensity for
now so here
tempo is on the x-axis ranging from
relaxed to fast
whereas intensity is on the y-axis
ranging
from light to soaring we see that paul
likes the song with fast tempo and
soaring intensity
while he dislikes the song with relaxed
tempo
and light intensity so now we know
paul's choices
let's say paul listens to a new song
let's name it as song a
song a has fast tempo and a soaring
intensity so it lies
somewhere here looking at the data can
you guess whether paul will like the
song or not
correct so paul likes this song by
looking at paul's past choices
we were able to classify the unknown
song very easily
right let's say now paul listens to a
new song
let's label it as song b so song b
lies somewhere here with medium tempo
and medium intensity neither relaxed nor
fast
neither light nor soaring now can you
guess whether ball likes it or not
not able to guess whether paul will like
it or dislike it
are the choices unclear correct we could
easily classify song a
but when the choice became complicated
as in the case of song b
yes and that's where machine learning
comes in let's see how
in the same example for song b if we
draw a circle around the song b
we see that there are four words for
like whereas
one would for dislike if we go for the
majority votes
we can say that paul will definitely
like the song that's all this was a
basic machine learning algorithm also
it's called k-nearest neighbors so this
is just a small example
in one of the many machine learning
algorithms quite easy
right believe me it is but what happens
when the choices become complicated as
in the case of song b
that's when machine learning comes in it
learns the data builds the prediction
model
and when the new data point comes in it
can easily predict for it
more the data better the model higher
will be the accuracy
there are many ways in which the machine
learns
it could be either supervised learning
unsupervised learning
or reinforcement learning let's first
quickly understand supervised
learning suppose your friend gives you
one million coins of
three different currencies say one rupee
one euro and one dirham
each coin has different weights for
example a coin of one rupee weighs three
grams
one euro weighs seven grams and one
dirham weighs four grams
your model will predict the currency of
the coin here
your weight becomes the feature of coins
while currency
becomes the label when you feed this
data to the machine learning model
it learns which feature is associated
with which sleep
for example it will learn that if a coin
is of three grams it will be a one rupee
coin let's give a new coin to the
machine on the basis of the weight
of the new coin your model will predict
the currency hence
supervised learning uses labeled data to
train the model here the machine
knew the features of the object and also
the labels associated with those
features
on this note let's move to unsupervised
learning and see the difference
suppose you have cricket data set of
various players with their respective
scores
and wickets taken when you feed this
data set to the machine
the machine identifies the pattern of
player performance
so it plots this data with the
respective wickets on the x-axis
while runs on the y-axis while looking
at the data you will clearly
see that there are two clusters the one
cluster
are the players who scored high runs and
took less wickets
while the other cluster is of the
players who scored less runs but took
many wickets
so here we interpret these two clusters
as batsmen
and bowlers the important point to note
here is that there were no labels of
batsmen
and bowlers hence the learning with
unlabeled data
is unsupervised learning so we saw
supervised learning where the data was
labeled
and the unsupervised learning where the
data was unlabeled
and then there is reinforcement learning
which is a reward based learning or we
can say that it works on the principle
of feedback
here let's say you provide the system
with an image of a dog and ask it to
identify it the
system identifies it as a cat so you
give a negative feedback to the machine
saying that it's a dog's image the
machine will learn from the feedback and
finally if it comes across
any other image of a dog it will be able
to classify it correctly
that is reinforcement learning to
generalize machine learning model
let's see a flowchart input is given to
a machine learning model which then
gives the output according to the
algorithm applied
if it's right we take the output as a
final result
else we provide feedback to the training
model and ask it
to predict until it learns i hope you've
understood supervised and unsupervised
learning
so let's have a quick quiz you have to
determine whether the given scenarios
uses supervised or unsupervised learning
simple right
scenario one facebook recognizes your
friend in a picture from an
album of tagged photographs
scenario two netflix recommends new
movies based on someone's past movie
choices
scenario 3 analyzing bank data for
suspicious transactions
and flagging the fraud transactions
think wisely and comment below your
answers
moving on don't you sometimes wonder how
is machine learning possible in today's
era well that's because today we have
humongous
data available everybody is online
either making a transaction
or just surfing the internet and that's
generating a huge amount of data
every minute and that data my friend is
the key to analysis also the memory
handling capabilities of computers have
largely increased which helps them to
process such huge amount of data at hand
without any delay and yes computers now
have great computational powers so there
are a lot of
applications of machine learning out
there to name a few
machine learning is used in healthcare
where diagnostics are predicted for
doctor's review the sentiment analysis
that the tech giants are doing on social
media is another interesting application
of machine learning
fraud detection in the finance sector
and also to predict customer churn in
the e-commerce sector
while booking a gap you must have
encountered search pricing
often where it says the fair of your
trip has been updated
continue booking yes please i'm getting
late for office
well that's an interesting machine
learning model
which is used by global taxi giant uber
and others
where they have differential pricing in
real time based on demand
the number of cars available bad weather
rush r
etc so they use the surge pricing model
to ensure that those who need a cab can
get one
also it uses predictive modeling to
predict
where the demand will be high with the
goal that drivers can take care of the
demand
and search pricing can be minimized
great hey siri can you remind me to book
a cab at 6 00 pm today
okay i'll remind you thanks no problem
comment below some interesting everyday
examples around you
where machines are learning and doing
amazing jobs
so that's all for machine learning
basics today from my site
machine learning has improved our lives
in a number of wonderful ways today
let's talk about some of these i'm rahul
from simply learn and these are the top
10 applications of machine learning
first let's talk about virtual personal
assistants google assistant
alexa cortana and siri now we've all
used one of these at least at some point
in our lives now these help improve our
lives in a great number of ways
for example you could tell them to call
someone you could tell them to play some
music you could tell them to even
schedule an appointment
so how do these things actually work
first they record whatever you're saying
send it over to a server which is
usually in a cloud decode it with the
help of machine learning in neural
networks
and then provide you with an output so
if you ever notice that these systems
don't work very well without the
internet
that's because the server couldn't be
contacted next let's talk about traffic
predictions
now say i wanted to travel from
buckingham palace to large cricket
ground the first thing i would probably
do
is to get on google maps so search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground
now here the map is a combination of red
yellow and blue but the blue regions
signify a clear road that is you won't
encounter traffic there
the yellow indicate that they are
slightly congested and red means they're
heavily congested
so let's look at the map a different
version of the same map and here
as i told you before red means heavily
congested yellow means slow moving
and blue means clear so how exactly is
google able to tell you that the traffic
is clear slow moving or heavily
congested so this is the help of machine
learning
and with the help of two important
measures first is the average time
that's taken on specific days at
specific times on that route the second
one is the real time location data
of vehicles from google maps and with
the help of sensors some of the other
popular map services are bing maps
maps dot me and here we go next up we
have social media personalization
so say i want to buy a drone and i'm on
amazon
and i want to buy a dji mavic pro the
thing is it's close to one lap so i
don't want to buy it right now but the
next time i'm on facebook i'll see an
advertisement for the product
next time i'm on youtube i'll see an
advertisement even on instagram
i'll see an advertisement so here with
the help of machine learning google has
understood that i'm interested
in this particular product hence it's
targeting me with these advertisements
this is also with the help of machine
learning let's talk about email spam
filtering
now this is a spam that's in my inbox
now how does gmail know what spam
and what's not spam so gmail has an
entire collection of emails which have
already been labeled as spam or not spam
so after analyzing this data gmail is
able to find some characteristics
like the word lottery or winner from
then on any new email that comes to your
inbox
goes through a few spam filters to
decide whether it's spam or not
now some of the popular spam filters
that gmail uses is
content filters header filters general
blacklist filters and so on
next we have online fraud detection now
there are several ways that online fraud
can take place for example there's
identity theft where they steal your
identity fake accounts where these
accounts only last for how long the
transaction takes place
and stop existing after that and man in
the middle attacks where they steal your
money while the transaction is taking
place
the feed forward neural network helps
determine whether a transaction is
genuine or fraudulent so what happens
with feed forward neural networks are
that the outputs are converted into hash
values and these values
become the inputs for the next round so
for every real transaction that takes
place there's a specific pattern a
fraudulent transaction would stand out
because of the significant changes that
it would cause with the hash values
stock market trading machine learning is
used extensively when it comes to stock
market trading
now you have stock market indices like
nikai they use long short short-term
memory neural networks now
these are used to classify process and
predict datum when there are time lags
of unknown size and duration
now this is used to predict stock market
trends assisted medical technology
now medical technology has been
innovated with the help of machine
learning diagnosing diseases has been
easier from which we can create 3d
models
that can predict where exactly there are
lesions in the brain it works just as
well for brain tumors and ischemic
stroke lesions they can also be used in
fetal imaging and cardiac analysis
now some of the medical fields that
machine learning will help assist in
is disease identification personalized
treatment drug discovery clinical
research and radiology
and finally we have automatic
translation now say you're in a foreign
country and you see billboards and signs
that you don't understand that's where
automatic translation comes of help now
how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chat
bots here the image recognition happens
using convolutional neural networks and
the text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequence to sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other
hello and welcome to machine learning
tutorial part one
this is part one of a machine learning
series put on by
learn my name is richard kirschner i'm
with the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead what's in it for
you today
well we'll start off with a brief
explanation of why machine learning and
what is machine learning
and then we'll get into a few of the
types of machine learning machine
learning algorithms
linear regression decision trees support
vector machine
and finally we'll do a use case where
we're going to classify whether recipe
is of a cupcake or a muffin
using the svm or the support vector
machine sounds like a delicious way to
explore
machine learning so why machine learning
why do we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us
well because machines can now drive your
car for you
it's still very in the infant stage but
it's just exploding as we see
with google's waymo and then uber head
their program which unfortunately
crashed
they know that this is huge this is
going to be the huge industry to change
our whole
transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now used to detect over 50
eye diseases
do you know how amazing that is to have
a computer that double checks for the
doctor for things they might miss
that's just huge in the health industry
pretty soon they actually do already
have that within some areas where maybe
not for eyes but for other diseases
where they're using the camera on your
phone to help
pre-diagnose before you go and see the
doctor and because the machine
can now unlock your phone with your face
i mean that's just cool having it being
able to identify your face
or your voice and be able to turn stuff
on and off for you depending on where
you're at and what you need
talking about an ultimate automation or
world we live in
and as we dig in deeper we have a nice
example of
facebook as you can see here they have
the facebook post with halloween
comment yes if you want it order here
nobody likes spam post on facebook that
annoy them into
interacting with likes shares comments
and other actions
i remember the original ones were all if
you don't click on here
you will have bad luck or some kind of
fear factor
well this is a huge thing in social
media when people are getting spammed
and so
this tactic known as engagement bait
takes advantage of facebook's news feed
algorithm by choosing engagement in
order to get the greater reach
to eliminate engagement bait the company
reviewed and categorized hundreds of
thousands of posts to train a machine
learning model that detects different
types of engagement bait
so in this case we have we're using
facebook but this is of course across
all the different social media
they have different tools are building
and the facebook scroll gif
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there
and notices that there's a certain set
up with facebook and it's able to
replace it
and they have like vote baiting react
baiting
share baiting they have all these
different these are kind of general
titles but there certainly are a lot of
way of baiting you to go in there and
click on something
so they fed all this this data was fed
into the machine and then they have the
new post the new post comes up
that takes over part of the facebook
setup and that's what you're looking at
you're looking at this new post that's
replaced like a virus has replaced that
so what facebook do to eliminate this is
they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this
and checks the click-through rate so it
starts looking for people who are
clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it and it's not something that
normally would be clicked through
once facebook has scanned for these
keywords and phrases
it is now able to identify the spam
coming in
and this makes your life easier so
you're not getting spammed it's not like
walking through an airport and
a lot of countries you have like
hundreds of people trying to sell you
timeshare
come join us sign up for this eliminates
that annoyingness so now you can just
enjoy your facebook
and your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures
mine is family certainly people like
their cat pictures too
another good example is google's
deepmind project
alphago a computer program that plays a
board game go has defeated the world's
number one go player and i hope i say
his name right
kg the ultimate go challenge game of
three of three
was on may 27 2017. so it's just last
year that this happened
and what makes this so important is that
you know go is just is a game so it's
not like you're driving a car or
something in our real world
but they are using games to learn
how to get the machine learning program
to learn they want it to learn how to
learn
and that is a huge step a lot of this is
still in its infant stage as far as
development
as we saw what happened with the as i
referred to earlier the
uber cars they lost their whole division
because they jumped ahead too fast
so it's still an infant stage but boy is
this like the beginning
of just an amazing world that is
automated in ways we can't even imagine
what tomorrow's going to look like we've
looked at a lot of examples of machine
learning
so let's see if we can give a little bit
more of a concrete definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is the science of making
computers learn and act like
humans by feeding data and information
without being explicitly programmed
we see here we have a nice little
diagram where we have our ordinary
system
uh your computer nowadays you can even
run a lot of stuff on
a cell phone because cell phones are
advanced so much and then with
artificial intelligence
and machine learning it now takes the
data and it learns from what happened
before
and then it predicts what's going to
come next and then
really the biggest part right now in
machine learning that's going on is it
improves
on that how do we find a new solution so
we go from
descriptive where it's learning about
stuff and understanding how it fits
together
to predicting what it's going to do to
post scripting coming up with a
new solution and when we're working on
machine learning
there's a number of different diagrams
that people have posted for what steps
to go through
a lot of it might be very domain
specific so if you're working on
photo identification versus language
versus medical or physics
some of these are switched around a
little bit or new things are put in
they're very specific to the domain
this is kind of a very general diagram
first you want to define your objective
very important to know what it is you're
wanting to predict then you're going to
be collecting the data so once you've
defined an
objective you need to collect the data
that matches you spend a lot of time
in data science collecting data and the
next step preparing the data you've got
to make sure that your data is clean
going in
there's the old saying bad data in bad
answer out
or bad data out and then once you've
gone through and we've cleaned all this
stuff coming in
then you're going to select the
algorithm which algorithm are you going
to use you're going to train that
algorithm in this case
i think we're going to be working with
svm the support vector machine
then you have to test the model does
this model work is this a valid model
for what we're doing
and then once you've tested it you want
to run your prediction you want to run
your prediction
or your choice or whatever output it's
going to come up with
and then once everything is set and
you've done lots of testing
then you want to go ahead and deploy the
model remember i said domain specific
this is very general
as far as the scope of doing something a
lot of models you get halfway through
and you realize that your
data is missing something and you have
to go collect new data
because you've run a test in here some
place along the line you're saying hey
i'm not really getting the answers i
need
so there's a lot of things that are
domain specific that become part of this
model this is a very
general model but it's a very good model
to start with and we do have some basic
divisions
of what machine learning does that's
important to know
for instance do you want to predict a
category well if you're categorizing
thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease
so in other words i'm looking for a yes
no answer is it going up or is it going
down
and in that case we'd actually say is it
going up true
if it's not going up it's false meaning
it's going down this way it's a yes no
zero one do you want to predict a
quantity that's
regression so remember we just did
classification now we're looking at
regression these are the two
major divisions and what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height
weight health and other factors so based
on these different factors you might
guess how old a person is
and then there are a lot of domain
specific things like do you want to
detect an anomaly
that's anomaly detection this is
actually very popular right now
for instance you want to detect money
withdrawal anomalies you want to know
when someone's
making a withdrawal that might not be
their own account we've actually brought
this up because this is really big right
now
if you're predicting the stock whether
to buy stock or not
you want to be able to know if what's
going on in the stock market is an
anomaly
use a different prediction model because
something else is going on you got to
pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm i'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested
so being able to detect anomalies is
very big in data science these days
another question that comes up which is
on what we call
untrained data is do you want to
discover structure in
unexplored data and that's called
clustering for instance
finding groups of customers with similar
behavior given a large database of
customer data containing their
demographics and past
buying records and in this case we might
notice that
anybody who's wearing a certain set of
shoes go shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information
it helps us to market or group people
together so that we can now explore that
group
and find out what it is we want to
market to them if you're in the
marketing world
and that might also work in just about
any arena you might want to group people
together
whether they're based on their different
areas
and investments and financial background
whether you're going to give them a loan
or not before you even start looking at
whether they're a valid customer for the
bank you might want to look at all these
different areas and group them together
based on
unknown data so you're not you don't
know what the data is going to tell you
but you want to cluster people together
that come together
let's take a quick detour for quiz time
oh my favorite so we're going to have a
couple questions here
under quiz time and we'll be posting the
answers
in this part two of this tutorial
so let's go ahead and take a look at
these quiz times questions and hopefully
you'll get them all right
it'll get you thinking about how to
process data and what's going on
can you tell what's happening in the
following cases
of course you're sitting there with your
cup of coffee and you have your checkbox
and your pen
trying to figure out what's your next
step in your data science analysis
so the first one is grouping documents
into different categories
based on the topic and content of each
document
very big these days you know you have
legal documents you have
maybe it's the sports group documents
maybe you're analyzing newspaper
postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world
b identifying handwritten digits in
images
correctly so we want to know whether
they're writing an a or capital a
b c what are they writing out in their
hand digit their handwriting
c behavior of a website indicating that
the site
is not working as designed d
predicting salary of an individual based
on his or her
years of experience hr hiring
uh set up there so stay tuned for part
two we'll go ahead and answer these
questions when we get to the part two of
this tutorial
or you can just simply write at the
bottom and send a note to simply learn
and they'll follow up with you on it
back to our regular content
now these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another
way of dividing our types of machine
learning and that is with
supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning supervised
learning
is a method used to enable machines to
classify predict objects problems or
situations based on labeled data
fed to the machine and in here you see
we have a jungle of data
with circles triangles and squares and
then we label them we have what's a
circle what's a triangle what's a square
we have our model training and it trains
it so we know the answer
very important when you're doing
supervised learning you already know the
answer
to a lot of your information coming in
so you have a huge group of
data coming in and then you have a new
data coming in so we've trained our
model
the model now knows the difference
between a circle a square a triangle
and now that we've trained it we can
send in in this case a square and a
circle goes in
and it predicts that the top one's a
square and the next one's a circle
and you can see that this is uh being
able to predict whether someone's going
to default on a loan because i was
talking about banks earlier
supervised learning on stock market
whether you're going to make money or
not
that's always important and if you are
looking to make a fortune in the stock
market keep in mind
it is very difficult to get all the data
correct on the stock market
it is very it fluctuates in ways you
really hard to predict
so it's quite a roller coaster ride if
you're running machine learning on the
stock market you start realizing you
really have to dig for new data
so we have supervised learning and if
you have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning
machine learning model finds the hidden
pattern in an unlabeled
data so in this case instead of telling
it what the circle is and what a
triangle is and what a square is
it goes in there looks at them and says
for whatever reason it groups them
together maybe they'll group it by the
number of corners
and it notices that a number of them all
have three corners a number of them all
have four corners
and a number of them all have no corners
and it's able to filter those through
and group them together
we talked about that earlier with
looking at a group of people who are out
shopping we want to group them together
to find out
what they have in common and of course
once you understand
what people have in common maybe you
have one of them is a customer at your
store
or you have five of them or customer
your store and they have a lot in common
with five others who are not customers
at your store
how do you market to those five who
aren't customers at your store yet they
fit the demographs of who's going to
shop there and you'd like them to shop
at your store not the one next door
of course this is a simplified version
you can see very easily the difference
between a triangle and a circle which
might not be so easy in marketing
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is an important type of machine
learning where an agent learns how to
behave in an environment by performing
actions and seeing the result
we have here where the in this case a
baby it's actually great that they used
an
infant for this slide because the
reinforcement learning
is very much in its infant stages but
it's also probably the
biggest machine learning demand out
there right now
or in the future it's going to be coming
up over the next few years is
reinforcement learning and how to
make that work for us and you can see
here where we have our action
in the action on this one it goes into
the fire hopefully the baby didn't
it's just a little candle not a giant
fire pit like it looks like here
when the baby comes out and the new
state is the baby is
sad and crying because they got burned
on the fire and then maybe they take
another action
the baby's called the agent because it's
the one taking the actions
and in this case they didn't go into the
fire they went a different direction and
now the baby's happy
and laughing and playing reinforcement
learning is very easy to understand
because that's how
as humans that's one of the ways we
learn we learn whether
it is you bring yourself on the stove
don't do that anymore don't touch the
stove
in the big picture being able to have
machine learning programming or an ai
be able to do this is huge because now
we're starting to
learn how to learn that's a big jump
in the world of computer and machine
learning and we're going to go back and
just kind of go back over
supervised versus unsupervised learning
understanding this is huge
because this is going to come up in any
project you're working on
we have in supervised learning we have
labeled data
we have direct feedback so someone's
already gone in there and said
yes that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be
and then with unsupervised training it's
not labeled so we really don't know
what it is there's no feedback so we're
not telling it whether it's right or
wrong we're not telling it whether it's
a triangle or a square
we're not telling it to go left or right
all we do is we're finding
hidden structure in the data grouping
the data together to find out
what connects to each other and then you
can use these together
so imagine you have an image and you're
not sure what you're looking for
so you go in and you have the
unstructured data find all these things
that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data
and program something to predict what's
in the picture so you can see how they
go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture
there are many interesting machine
learning algorithms let's have a look at
a few of them
hopefully this gives you a little flavor
what's out there and these are some of
the most important ones that are
currently being used
we'll take a look at linear regression
decision tree
and the support vector machine let's
start with a closer look at linear
regression
linear regression is perhaps one of the
most well-known and well-understood
algorithms in statistics and machine
learning
linear regression is a linear model for
example a model that assumes a linear
relationship between
the input variables x and the single
output variable
y and you'll see this if you remember
from your algebra classes
y equals mx plus c imagine we are
predicting distance traveled y
from speed x our linear regression model
representation for this problem
would be y equals m times x plus c or
distance equals m times speed plus c
where m is the coefficient and c is the
y-intercept
and we're going to look at two different
variations of this first we're going to
start with
time is constant and you can see we have
a bicyclist
he's got a safety gear on thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second
and so over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers
we have a second bicyclist who's going
twice the speed or
20 meters per second and you can guess
if he's going twice the speed and time
is a constant
then he's going to go twice the distance
and that's easy to compute 36
times 2 you get 72 kilometers
and so if you had the question of how
fast would somebody is going
three times at speed or 30 meters per
second is you can easily compute the
distance
in our head we can do that without
needing a computer but we want to do
this for more complicated data so it's
kind of nice to compare the two but
let's just take a look at that and what
that looks like in a graph
so in a linear regression model we have
our distance to the speed
and we have our m equals the ve slope of
the line
and we'll notice that the line has a
plus slope and as the speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive
relationship and so your speed of the
person which equals y equals mx plus c
distance traveled in a fixed interval of
time and we could very easily compute
either following the line or just
knowing it's 3 times 10 meters per
second that this is roughly 102
kilometers distance that this third
bicep
has traveled one of the key definitions
on here is
positive relationship so the slope of
the line is positive
as distance increase so does speed
increase let's take a look at our second
example where we put
distance is a constant so we have speed
equals 10 meters per second
they have a certain distance to go and
it takes him 100 seconds to travel that
distance
and we have our second bicyclist who's
still doing 20 meters per second
since he's going twice the speed we can
guess that he'll cover the distance in
about half the time
50 seconds and of course you could
probably guess on the third one
100 divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed
you can easily guess that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or
graph if the distance is assumed to be
constant let's see the relationship
between speed and time
and as time goes up the amount of speed
to go that same distance
goes down so now your m equals a minus
ve slope of the line
as the speed increases time decreases
hence the variable
has a negative relationship again
there's our definition
positive relationship and negative
relationship depended on the slope of
the line
and with a simple formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's uh see with the mathematical
implementation of linear regression and
we'll take this data so suppose we have
this data set
where we have x y x equals 1 2 3
4 5 standard series and the y value is 3
2 2 4 3. when we take that and we go
ahead and
plot these points on a graph you can see
there's kind of a nice scattering
and you could probably eyeball a line
through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression
and the first thing we do is we come up
here we have the mean
of x i and remember mean is basically
the average
so we added five plus four plus three
plus two plus one and divide by five
and that simply comes out as three and
then we'll do the same for y
we'll go ahead and add up all those
numbers and divide by five
and we end up with the mean value of y
of i equals
2.8 where the x i references it's an
average or means value and the y i also
equals a means value of y
and when we plot that you'll see that we
can put in the y equals 2.8
and the x equals 3 in there on our graph
we kind of give it a little different
color so you can
sort it out with the dashed lines on it
and it's important to note that when we
do the linear regression
the linear regression model should go
through that dot
now let's find our regression equation
to find the best fit line
remember we go ahead and take our y
equals mx plus c so we're looking for
m and c so to find this equation for our
data
we need to find our slope of m and our
coefficient of
c and we have y equals mx
plus c where m equals the sum of
x minus x average times y minus y
average or y means and x means over the
sum of
x minus x means squared that's how we
get the slope of the value of the line
and we can easily do that by creating
some columns here we have
x y computers are really good about
iterating through data
and so we can easily compute this and
fill in a graph of data
and in our graph you can easily see that
if we have our x value of 1
and if you remember the x i or the means
value is 3
1 minus 3 equals a negative 2 and 2
minus 3
equals a negative 1 so on and so forth
and we can easily fill in the column of
x minus x i
y minus y i and then from those we can
compute
x minus x i squared and x minus x i
times y minus y i and you can guess it
that the next step is to go ahead and
sum the different columns for the
answers we need
so we get a total of 10 for our x minus
x i squared
and a total of 2 for x minus x i times y
minus y
i and we plug those in we get 2 10
which equals 0.2 so now we know the
slope of our line equals 0.2
so we can calculate the value of c
that'd be the next step is we need to
know where it crosses the y
axis and if you remember i mentioned
earlier
that the linear regression line has to
pass through
the means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just flip back up there
to that graph
and you can see right here there's our
means value which is 3
x equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value
we can simply plug that into our formula
y equals 0.2 x plus c so we plug that in
we get 2.8
equals 0.2 times 3 plus c and you can
just solve for c
so now we know that our coefficient
equals 2.2
and once we have all that we can go
ahead and plot our regression line
y equals 0.2 times x plus 2.2
and then from this equation we can
compute
new values so let's predict the values
of y using
x equals 1 2 3 4 5 and plot the points
remember the one two three four five was
our original x values
so now we're going to see what y thinks
they are not what they actually are
and we plug those in we get y of
designated with y of p
you can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals
2.6 and so on and so on so we have our y
predicted values of what we think is
going to be when we plug those numbers
in
and when we plot the predicted values
along with the actual values
we can see the difference and this is
one of the things that's very important
with linear aggression in any of these
models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted
x and y and y predict and we draw a
little line so you can sort of see what
the error looks like there between the
different points
so our goal is to reduce this error we
want to minimize that error value
on our linear regression model
minimizing the distance
there are lots of ways to minimize the
distance between the line and the data
points like
sum of squared errors sum of absolute
errors
root mean square error etc we keep
moving this line through the data points
to make sure the best fit line
has the least square distance between
the data points and the regression line
so to recap with a very simple linear
regression model
we first figure out the formula of our
line through the middle
and then we slowly adjust the line to
minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math
is very much the same it gets much more
complex as we add in
different dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals
mx plus c but you can take that out to x
z i j q all the different features in
there and they can plot a linear
regression model on all of those
using the different formulas to minimize
the error
let's go ahead and take a look at
decision trees a very different way to
solve problems in the linear regression
model
decision tree is a tree-shaped algorithm
used to determine a course of action
each branch of a tree represents a
possible decision occurrence or reaction
we have data which tells us if it is a
good day to play golf
and if we were to open this data up in a
general spreadsheet
you can see we have the outlook whether
it's a rainy overcast sunny
temperature hot mild cool humidity
windy and did i like to play golf that
day yes or no
so we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not
but you could imagine if you got up in
the night before you're trying to plan
your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you
in the morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like
that this becomes very beneficial and we
see this in a lot of applications coming
out now where it gives you suggestions
and lets you know what would be fit the
match for you for the next day or the
next purchase
or the next whatever you know next meal
out in this case
is tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in
and so we come up and let's uh determine
if you should play golf
when the day is sunny and windy so we
found out the forecast tomorrow is going
to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity
and then we have our normal which is if
it's if you have a normal humidity
you're going to go play golf
and if the humidity is really high then
we look at the outlook and if the
outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do
so if you know that it's a very high
humidity
and it's sunny you're probably not going
to play golf because you're going to be
out there miserable
fighting off the mosquitoes that are out
joining you to play golf with you maybe
if it's raining you probably don't want
to play in the rain but if it's slightly
overcast
you get just the right shadow that's a
good day to play golf and be outside out
on the green
now in this example you can probably
make your own tree
pretty easily because it's a very simple
set of data going in
but the question is how do you know what
to split where do you split your data
what if this is much more complicated
data
where it's not something that you would
particularly
understand like studying cancer they
take about 36 measurements of the
cancerous
cells and then each one of those
measurements represents
how bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are
something that as a human we would have
no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but
so it's a question is going to come up
is this the right decision tree
for that we should calculate entropy and
information
gain two important vocabulary words
there are the entropy
and the information gain entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or impurity
in the data set
entropy should be low so we want the
chaos to be as low as possible
we don't want to look at it and be
confused by the images or what's going
on
there with mixed data and the
information gain it is a measure
of decrease in entropy after the data
set is split
also known as entropy reduction
information gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side
in this case we're going to denote
entropy as
i of p of n n where p
is the probability that you're going to
play a game of golf and
n is the probability where you're not
going to play the game of golf
now you don't really have to memorize
these formulas there's a few of them out
there depending on what you're working
with but it's important to note that
this is where this formula is coming
from so when you see it you're not lost
when you're running your programming
unless you're building your own decision
tree code in the back
and we simply have a log squared of p
over p plus n minus n over p plus n
times the log squared of
n of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what
actually looks like when we're computing
that from the computer script side
entropy of a target class of the data
set is the whole entropy
so we have entropy play golf and we look
at this
if we go back to the data you can simply
count how many yeses and no
in our complete data set for playing
golf days
in our complete set we find we have five
days we did play golf
and nine days we did not play golf and
so our i
equals if you add those together 9 plus
5 is 14.
and so our i equals 5 over 14 and 9 over
14. that's our p and n values that we
plug into that formula
and you can go to 5 over 14 equals 0.36
9 over 14 equals 0.64 and when you do
the whole
equation you get the minus 0.36
log root squared of 0.36 minus 0.64
log squared root of 0.64 and we get a
set value we get
0.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with
and we want to make that entropy go down
and just like we calculated the entropy
out for the whole set
we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf and the outlook
is it going to be overcast or rainy or
sunny
and so we look at the entropy we have p
of sunny times e
of 3 of 2 and that just comes out how
many sunny days
yes and how many sunny days no over the
total which is five don't forget to put
the we'll divide that five out later on
equals p overcast equals four comma zero
plus rainy equals two comma three and
then when you do the whole
setup we have 5 over 14
remember i said there was a total of 5.
5 over 14 times the i
of 3 of 2 plus 4 over 14 times the
4 comma 0 and 514 over i of 2
3. and so we can now compute the entropy
of just the part it has to do with the
forecast and we get 0.693
similarly we can calculate the entropy
of other predictors like temperature
humidity and wind and so we look at the
gain outlook how much are we going to
gain from this
entropy play golf minus entropy play
golf outlook
and we can take the original 0.94 for
the whole set
minus the entropy of just the rainy day
and temperature
and we end up with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy
and we define an information gain the
higher the information gain
the lower the entropy the better the
information gain of the other three
attributes can be calculated in the same
way
so we have our gain for temperature
equals 0.029
we have our gain for humidity equals
0.152
and our gain for a windy day equals
0.048
and if you do a quick comparison you'll
see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain
and we can continue to go down the tree
using the different information gains
with the largest information we can
continue down the nodes of the tree
where we choose the attribute with the
largest information gain as the root
node
and then continue to split each sub node
with the largest information gain that
we can compute
and although it's a little bit of a
tongue twister to say all that you can
see that's a very easy to view
visual model we have our outlook we
split it three different directions
if the outlook is overcast we're going
to play and then we can split those
further down if we want so if the
outlook is sunny but then it's also
windy
if it's windy we're not going to play if
it's not windy we'll play
so we can easily build a nice decision
tree to guess
what we would like to do tomorrow and
give us a nice recommendation for the
day
so we want to know if it's a good day to
play golf when it's sunny and windy
remember the original question that came
out tomorrow's weather report is sunny
and windy
you can see by going down the tree we go
outlook sunny outlook windy
we're not going to play golf tomorrow so
our little smart watch pops up and says
i'm sorry tomorrow is not a good day for
golf it's going to be
sunny and windy and if you're a huge
golf fan
you might go uh-oh it's not a good day
to play golf
we can go in and watch a golf game at
home so we'll sit in front of the tv
instead of being out playing golf in the
wind
now that we've looked at our decision
tree let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating
support vector machine support vector
machine is a widely used classification
algorithm
the idea of support vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner
for example dog or cat disease or no
disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height
and weight of males and females a new
data point arrives and we want to know
whether it's going to be a male
or a female so we start by drawing a
line we draw decision lines but if we
consider decision line one
then we will classify the individual as
a male and if we consider decision line
two then it will be a female so you can
see this person kind of lies in the
middle of the two groups it's a little
confusing trying to figure out which
line they should be under
we need to know which line divides the
classes correctly
but how the goal is to choose a
hyperplane and that is one of the key
words they use when we talk about
support vector machines
choose a hyperplane with the greatest
possible margin between the decision
line
and the nearest point within the
training set so you can see here we have
our support vector we have the two
nearest points to it and we draw a line
between those two points
and the distance margin is the distance
between the hyperplane and the nearest
data point from either set so we
actually have a value
and it should be equal the distance
between the two
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line
one has a maximum distance so we observe
that line one has a maximum distance
margin so we'll classify the new data
point correctly
and our result on this one is going to
be that the new data point is mel
one of the reasons we call it a
hyperplane versus a line
is that a lot of times we're not looking
at just
weight and height we might be looking at
36
different features or dimensions and so
when we cut it with a hyperplane
it's more of a three-dimensional cut in
the data multi-dimensional
it cuts the data a certain way and each
plane continues to cut it down
until we get the best fit or match let's
understand this with the help of an
example
problem statement i always start with a
problem statement when you're going to
put some code together we're going to do
some coding now
classifying muffin and cupcake recipes
using support
vector machines so the cupcake versus
the muffin
let's have a look at our data set and we
have the different recipes here we have
a muffin recipe
that has so much flour i'm not sure what
measurement 55 is in but it has 55
maybe it's ounces but has a certain
amount of flour
certain amount of milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt
and so based on these measurements we
want to guess whether we're making a
muffin or a cupcake
and you can see in this one we don't
have just two features we don't just
have
height and weight as we did before
between the male and female in here we
have a number of features
in fact in this we're looking at eight
different features
to guess whether it's a muffin or a
cupcake what's the difference between a
muffin and a cupcake
turns out muffins have more flour while
cupcakes have more butter and sugar
so basically the cupcake's a little bit
more of a dessert where the muffins a
little bit more of a fancy bread
but how do we do that in python how do
we code that to go through recipes and
figure out what the recipe is
and i really just want to say cupcakes
versus
muffins like some big professional
wrestling thing
before we start in our cupcakes versus
muffins we are going to be working
in python there's many versions of
python many different editors
that is one of the strengths and
weaknesses of python
is it just has so much stuff attached to
it is one of the more
popular data science programming
packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda
and jupiter nopa the anaconda navigator
has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the anaconda
navigator you can change environments
i actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python36
environment
so this is in python version 36 although
it doesn't matter too much which version
you use
i usually try to stay with the 3x
because they're current unless you have
a project that's very specifically in
version 2x
27 i think is usually what most people
use in the version 2.
and then once we're in our jupiter
notebook
editor i can go up and create a new file
and we'll just jump in here
in this case we're doing svm muffin
versus cupcake
and then let's start with our packages
for
data analysis and we almost always use
a couple there's a few very standard
packages we use
we use import import import
numpy that's for number python
they usually denote it as np that's very
comma
that's very common and then we're going
to import
pandas as pd and numpy
deals with number arrays there's a lot
of cool things you can do with the numpy
setup as far as multiplying all the
values
in an array in a numpy array data array
pandas
i can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set i think we do
as an import
it makes a nice data frame and the
difference between a data frame
and a numpy array is that a data frame
is more like your excel spreadsheet
you have columns you have indexes you
have different ways of referencing it
easily viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame
and pandas kind of sits on numpy so they
you need them both in there
and then finally we're working with the
support vector machine
so from sk learn we're going to use the
sk learn model
import svm support vector machine
and then as a data scientist you should
always try to
visualize your data some data obviously
is too complicated or doesn't make any
sense to the human
but if it's possible it's good to take a
second look at it so you can actually
see what you're doing
now for that we're going to use two
packages we're going to import
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt
again very common and we're going to
import
seaborn as sns and we'll go ahead and
set the font scale
in the sns right in our import line
that's what this
semicolon followed by a line of data
we're going to set the sns
and these are great because the the
seaborn sits on top of matplot library
just like pandas hits on numpy
so it adds a lot more features and uses
and control
we're obviously not going to get into
matplot library and seabourn it'd be its
own tutorial
we're really just focusing on the svm
the support vector machine from
sk learn and since we're in jupiter
notebook
we have to add a special line in here
for our
matplot library and that's your
percentage sign or
ambersign matplot library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code project
a lot of times i use like notepad plus
plus and i'll run it from there
you don't have to have that line in
there because it'll just pop up as its
own window on your computer depending on
how your computer is set up
because we're running this in the
jupyter notebook
as a browser setup this tells it to
display
all of our graphics right below on the
page
so that's what that line is for i
remember the first time i ran this i
didn't know that i had to go look that
up
years ago it's quite a headache so
matplot library inline is just because
we're running this on the web setup and
we can go ahead and run this make sure
all our modules are in
they're all imported which is great if
you don't have an import you'll need to
go ahead and pip
use the pip or however you do it there's
a lot of other
install packages out there although pip
is the most common
and you have to make sure these are all
installed on your python setup
the next step of course is we got to
look at the data you can't run
a model for predicting data if you don't
have actual data
so to do that let me go ahead and open
this up and take a look
and we have our cupcakes versus muffins
and it's a csv file or dot csv meaning
that it's comma separated variable
and it's going to open it up in a nice
spreadsheet for me
and you can see up here we have the type
we have muffin muffin muffin cupcake
cupcake
cupcake and then it's broken up into
flour milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt so we can
do is we can go ahead and look at this
data
also in our python
let us create a variable recipes equals
we're going to use our pandas module dot
read
csv remember is a comma separated
variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus
muffins oops i got double brackets there
do it this way
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program i loaded or the the
place i saved this particular python
program is in the same folder
we get by with just the file name but
remember if you're storing it in a
different location you have to also put
down the full path on there
and then because we're in pandas we're
going to go ahead
and you can actually inline you can do
this but let me do the full print
you can just type in recipes dot head
in the jupiter notebook but if you're
running in code in a different script
you need to go ahead and type out the
whole print recipes dot head
and panda's nose is that's gonna do the
first five
lines of data and if we flip back on
over to the spreadsheet where we opened
up our csv
file you can see where it starts on line
two this one calls it zero and then
two three four five six is going to
match go and close that out because we
don't need that anymore
and it always starts at zero and these
are it automatically indexes it since we
didn't
tell it to use an index in here so
that's the index number for the left
hand side
and it automatically took the top row as
labels so pandas using it to read a csv
is just really slick and fast one of the
reasons we love our pandas
not just because they're cute and cuddly
teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot our data
and i'm not going to plot all of it i'm
just going to plot the
sugar and flour now obviously
you can see where they get really
complicated if we have tons of different
features
and so you'll break them up and maybe
look at just two of them at a time to
see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use seaborne
so that's our sns and the command for
that is sns.lm
plot and then the two different
variables i'm going to
plot is flower and sugar
data equals recipes the hue
equals type and this is a lot of fun
because it
knows that this is pandas coming in so
this is one of the
powerful things about pandas mixed with
seaborne in doing
graphing and then we're going to use a
pallet set one
there's a lot of different sets in there
you can go look them up for seabourn
or do a regular fit regular equals false
so we're not really trying to fit
anything
and it's a scatter kws
a lot of these settings you can look up
in seabourn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings
for doing a seaborn plot let's go ahead
and run that
and because it does it in line it just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on
sugar and flour alone there's a definite
split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at and say hey if i drew a
line
right between the middle of the blue
dots and the red dots
we'd be able to do an svm and a hyper
plane right there in the middle
then the next step is to format
or pre-process
our data we're going to break that up
into two parts
we need a type label and remember
we're going to decide whether it's a
muffin or cupcake well a computer
doesn't know muffin or cupcake it knows
zero and one
so what we're going to do is we're going
to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
and p
where and this is where we can do some
logic
we take our recipes from our panda and
whatever
type equals muffin it's going to be zero
and then if it doesn't equal muffin
which is cupcakes is going to be one
so we create our type label this is the
answer
so when we're doing our training model
remember we have to have a training data
this is what we're going to train it
with is that it's zero or one it's a
muffin
or it's not then we're going to create
our recipe
features and if you remember correctly
from right up here
the first column is type so we really
don't need the type columns that's our
muffin or cupcake
and in pandas we can easily sort that
out
we take our value recipes
dot columns that's a pandas
function built into pandas
got values converting them to values so
it's just the column titles going across
the top
and we don't want the first one so what
we do is since it always starts at
zero we want one
colon till the end and then
we want to go ahead and make this a list
and this converts it to
a list of strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features
make sure it looks right let me go ahead
and run that
and i forgot the s on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s
in there and then run that and we can
see we have flour milk sugar butter
egg baking powder vanilla and salt
and that matches what we have up here
right where we printed out
everything but the type so we have our
features and we have our label
now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns and we actually
need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients
and when you're doing this usually you
do but for our example we want to limit
it so you can easily see what's going on
because if we did all the ingredients
we have you know that's what uh
seven eight different hyperplanes that
would be built into it we only want to
look at one so you can see what the svm
is doing
and so we'll take our recipes and we'll
do just flour
and sugar again you can replace that
with your recipe features and do all of
them but we're going to do just flour
and sugar
and we're going to convert that to
values we don't need to make a list out
of it because it's not string values
these are actual
values on there and we can go ahead and
just print
ingredients and you can see what that
looks like
and so we have just the amount of flour
and sugar just the two sets of plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here
and take our recipe features
and so if we decided to use all the
recipe features
you'll see that it makes a nice column
of different data so it just strips out
all the labels and everything we just
have just the values
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a
plot later on we'll go ahead and take
that and just do flour and
sugar and we'll run that you'll see it's
just the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model we'll go ahead and just call
it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called
svc
in this case we're going to go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific
set up on there and if we go to the
reference on their website
for the svm you'll see that there's
about there's eight of them here
three of them are for regression three
are for classification
the svc support vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and there's also one for detecting
outliers
and another one that has to do with
something a little bit more specific on
the model
but svc and sbr are the two most
commonly used
standing for support vector classifier
and support vector regression
remember regression is an actual value a
float value or
whatever you're trying to work on and
sbc is a classifier so it's a yes no
true false but for this we want to know
zero one
muffin cupcake if we go ahead and create
our model
and once we have our model created we're
gonna do model dot fit
and this is very common especially in
the sk learn all their models
are followed with the fit command and
what we put into the fit what we're
training with it is we're putting in the
ingredients
which in this case we limited to just
flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series
you'd want to split into we won't get
into that today we split it into
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
whether you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things
go into that it gets very complicated
when you get to the higher end
not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set
of data and let's go ahead and run this
and now we have our model fit and i got
an
error here so let me fix that real quick
capital sbc
it turns out i did it lowercase
support vector classifier
there we go let's go ahead and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically
these are the defaults of the model you
notice that we change the kernel to
linear
and there's our kernel linear on the
printout and there's other different
settings you can mess with we're going
to just leave that
alone for right now for this we don't
really need to mess with any of those
so next we're going to dig a little bit
into our
newly trained model and we're going to
do this so we can show you on a graph
let's go ahead and get the separating
and we're going to say we're going to
use a w for our variable on here
we're going to do model dot coefficient
underscore
0. so what the heck is that again we're
digging
into the model so we've already got a
prediction and a train
this is a math behind it that we're
looking at right now
and so the w is going to represent
two different coefficients and if you
remember we had y
equals mx plus c so these coefficients
are connected to that
but in two-dimensional it's a plane
we don't spend too much time on this
because you can get lost in the
confusion of the math
so if you're a math whiz this is great
you can go through here
and you'll see that we have a equals
minus w0
over w of one remember there's two
different values there
and that's basically the slope that
we're generating
and then we're going to build an xx what
is xx
we're going to set it up to a numpy
array there's our np
dot line space so we're creating a line
of values between 30 and 60. so it just
creates a set of numbers for x
and then if you remember correctly we
have our formula
y equals the slope times x
plus the intercept well to make this
work we can do this as
y y equals the slope
times each value in that array that's a
neat thing about numpy so when i do a
times
x x which is a whole numpy array of
values it multiplies a across
all of them and then it takes those same
values and we subtract
the model intercept that's your uh
where we had mx plus c so that'd be the
c from the formula
y equals mx plus c and that's where all
these numbers come from
a little bit confusing because it's
digging out of these different arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it
so plot the parallels to separating
hyperplane
that pass through the support vectors
and so we're going to create
b equals a model support vectors
pulling our support vectors out there
here's our y y
which we now know is a set of data we
have we're going to create y y
down equals a times x x plus
b 1 minus a times b 0
and then model support vector b is going
to be set that to a new value the minus
1 set up
and y y up equals a times x x plus b 1
minus
a times b 0. and we can go ahead and
just run this to load these variables up
if you wanted to know understand a
little bit more of what's going on
you can see if we print
y y let me just run that you can see
it's an array this is a line it's going
to have
in this case between 30 and 60 so it's
going to be 30 variables in here
and the same thing with yy up yy
down and we'll we'll plot those in just
a minute on the graph so you can see
what those look like
just go ahead and delete that out of
here and run that so it loads up the
variables
nice clean slate i'm just going to copy
this from before
remember this our sns our seaborn plot
lm plot flower sugar
and i'll just go ahead and run that real
quick so you can see remember what that
looks like it's just a straight graph on
there
and then one of the neat things is
because seaborn sits on top of
pie plot we can do the pie plot for the
line going through
and that is simply plt.plot
and that's our x x and y y
are two corresponding values x y and
then somebody played with this to figure
out that the line width equals two
in the color black would look nice so
let's go ahead and run this whole thing
with the pie plot on there
and you can see when we do this it's
just doing flour and sugar on here
corresponding line between the sugar and
the flour and the
muffin versus cupcake
um and then we generated the support
vectors the yy
down and yy out so let's take a look and
see what that looks like
so we'll do our pl plot and again this
is all against
x x our x value but this time we have y
y down
and let's do something a little fun with
this we can put in a
k dash dash that just tells it to
make it a dotted line and if we're going
to do
the down one we also want to do the up
one so here's our yy
up and when we run that it adds
both sets of line and so here's our
support and this is what you expect
you expect these two lines to go through
the nearest data point so the dashed
lines go through the nearest muffin
and the nearest cupcake when it's
plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data
and you can see how easy it is to see
based just on sugar and flour
which one's a muffin or a cupcake
let's go ahead and create a function
to predict
muffin or cupcake
i've got my recipes i pulled off the
internet and i want to see the
difference between a
muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through
and create a function with depth and
let's call it muffin or cupcake
remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today we're not doing all the
ingredients
and that actually is a pretty good split
you really don't need all the
ingredients to know it's flour and sugar
and let's go ahead and do an if else
statement so if
model predict
is a flower and sugar equals zero
so we take our model and we do it run a
predict it's very common in sk learn we
have a dot predict
you put the data in and it's going to
return a value
in this case if it equals zero then
print you're looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe
that's pretty straightforward for
function
or def for definition def is how you do
that in python
and of course we're going to create a
function you should run something in it
and so let's run a
cupcake and we're going to send it
values 50 and 20 a muffin or cupcake i
don't know what it is
and let's run this and just see what it
gives us and it says oh it's a muffin
you're looking at a muffin recipe so it
very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake
recipe let's plot this
there we go plot this on the graph so we
can see what that actually looks like
and i'm just going to copy and paste it
from below where we're plotting all the
points in there
so this is nothing different than we did
before if i run it
you'll see it has all the points and the
lines on there
and what we want to do is we want to add
another point
and we'll do plt plot
and if you remember correctly we did for
our test we did 50
and 20. and then somebody went in here
and decided we'll do
a y-o for yellow or it's kind of a
oranges yellow color it's going to come
out
marker size nine those are settings you
can play with somebody else played with
them to
come up with the right setup so it looks
good and you can see there it is graphed
clearly a muffin in this case
in cupcakes versus muffins the muffin
has
won and if you'd like to do your own
muffin cupcake
contender series you certainly can send
a note down below
and the team at simply learn will send
you over the data they use for the
muffin and cupcake
and that's true of any of the data we
didn't actually run a plot on it earlier
we had men versus women
you can also request that information to
run it on your data setup so you can
test that out
so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support vector machine
code
we did a predict 40 parts flower 20
parts sugar
i think was different than the one we
did whether it's a muffin or a cupcake
hence we have built a classifier using
svm
which is able to classify if a recipe is
of a cupcake
or a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin
today in our second tutorial we're going
to cover k-means
and linear regression along with going
over the quiz questions we had
during our first tutorial what's in it
for you
we're going to cover clustering what is
clustering
k means clustering which is one of the
most common use clustering tools out
there
including a flow chart to understand
k-means clustering and how it functions
and then we'll do an actual python live
demo on clustering of cars based on
brands
then we're going to cover logistic
regression what is logistic regression
logistic regression curve and sigmoid
function
and then we'll do another python code
demo to classify a tumor as malignant or
benign based on features
and let's start with clustering suppose
we have a pile of books
of different genres now we divide them
into different groups like
fiction horror education and as we can
see from this young lady she definitely
is into heavy horror you can just
tell by those eyes and the maple
canadian leaf on her shirt
but we have fiction horror and education
and we want to go ahead and divide our
books up
well organizing objects into groups
based on similarity is
clustering and in this case as we're
looking at the books we're talking about
clustering things with known
categories but you can also use it to
explore data so you might not know the
categories
you just know that you need to divide it
up in some way to conquer the data and
to organize it better
but in this case we're going to be
looking at clustering in specific
categories
and let's just take a deeper look at
that we're going to use k
means clustering k means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library
k-means clustering is an example of
unsupervised learning
if you remember from our previous thing
it is used when you have
unlabeled data so we don't know the
answer yet we have a bunch of data that
we want to cluster to different groups
define clusters in the data based on
feature similarity
so we've introduced a couple terms here
we've already talked about
unsupervised learning and unlabeled data
so we don't know the answer yet we're
just going to group stuff together and
see if we can find
an answer of how things connect we've
also
introduced feature similarity features
being different features of the data
now with books we can easily see fiction
and
horror and history books but a lot of
times with data
some of that information isn't so easy
to see right when we first look at it
and so k-means is one of those tools
where we can start finding things that
connect
that match with each other suppose we
have these data points and want to
assign them into a cluster
now when i look at these data points i
would probably group them into two
clusters just by looking at them i'd say
two of these group of data kind of come
together
but in k-means we pick k clusters and
assign random
centroids two clusters where the k
clusters represents two different
clusters
we pick k clusters and cyrano centroids
to the clusters
then we compute distance from objects to
the centroids
now we form new clusters based on
minimum distances
and calculate the centroids so we figure
out what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stop
changing their positions and become
static repeat previous two steps
iteratively till the cluster centroid
stop changing and the positions become
static
once the clusters become static then
k-means clustering algorithm is said to
be
converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever
math we're using to figure out the
answer has come to a solution or it's
converged on an answer
so we see the flow chart to understand
make a little bit more sense by putting
it into a nice easy step
by step so we start we choose k we'll
look at the elbow method in just a
moment
we assign random centroids to clusters
and sometimes you pick the centroids
because you might look at the data in a
graph and say ah these are probably the
central points
then we compute the distance from the
objects to the centroids
we take that and we form new clusters
based on minimum distance and calculate
their centroids
then we compute the distance from
objects to the new centroids
and then we go back and repeat those
last two steps we calculate the
distances
so as we're doing it brings into the new
centroid
and then we move the centroid around and
we figure out what the best
which objects are closest to each
centroid so the objects can switch from
one centroid to the other the centroids
are moved around
and we continue that until it is
converged
let's see an example of this suppose we
have this data set of seven individuals
and their score on two topics
a and b so here's our subject
in this case referring to the person
taking the
test and then we have subject a where we
see what they've scored on their
first subject and we have subject b and
we can see what they score on the second
subject
now let's take two farthest apart points
as initial
cluster centroids remember we talked
about selecting them randomly
or we can also just put them in
different points and pick the furthest
one apart so they move together
either one works okay depending on what
kind of data you're working on and what
you know about it
so we took the two furthest points one
and one
and five and seven and now let's take
the two farthest apart
points as initial cluster centroids each
point is then assigned to the closest
cluster with respect to the distance
from the centroids
so we take each one of these points in
there we measure that distance and you
can see that
if we measure each of those distances
and you use the
pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you
know the x and the y and you can figure
out the
diagonal line from that or you just take
a ruler and put it on your monitor
that'd be kind of silly but it would
work if you're just eyeballing it
you can see how they naturally come
together in certain areas
now we again calculate the centroids of
each cluster
so cluster one and then cluster two and
we look at
each individual dot there's one two
three we're in one cluster
the centroid then moves over it becomes
1.8 comma 2.3 so remember was that one
and one
well the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly 2 2 but 1.8 and 2.3
and the second one if we wanted to make
the overall
mean vector the average vector of all
the different distances to that centroid
we come up with four comma one and five
four so we've now moved the centroids
we compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean
and to that of the opposite cluster and
we find we can build a nice chart on
here
that the as we move that centroid around
we now have a new different kind of
clustering of groups
and using euclidean distance between the
points and the mean
we get the same formula you see these
new formulas coming up so we have our
individual dots
distance to the mean centroid of the
cluster and distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster
only individual three is nearer to the
mean of the opposite cluster
cluster two then its own cluster one and
you can see here in the diagram where
we've kind of
circled that one in the middle so when
we've moved the cluster
the centroids of the clusters over one
of the points shifted to the other
cluster
because it's closer to that group of
individuals thus
individual three is relocated to cluster
two resulting in a new partition and we
regenerate all those numbers
of how close they are to the different
clusters for the new clusters we will
find the actual cluster centroids so now
we move the
centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here
on comparing the distance of each
individual's distance to its own cluster
mean
and to that of the opposite cluster we
find that the data points are stable
hence we have our final clusters now if
you remember i brought up a concept
earlier k-mean on the k-means algorithm
choosing the right value of k
will help in less number of iterations
and to find the appropriate number of
clusters in a data set
we use the elbow method and within
sum of squares wss is defined as the sum
of the squared
distance between each member of the
cluster in its centroid
and so you see we've done here is we
have the number of clusters
and as you do the same k-means algorithm
over the different clusters
and you calculate what that centroid
looks like and you find the optimal you
can actually find the optimal number of
clusters using the elbow the graph
is called as the elbow method and on
this we guessed it two just by looking
at the data
but as you can see the slope you
actually just look for right there where
the elbow is in the slope and you have a
clear answer that we want two different
to start with k-means equals two a lot
of times people end up computing
k-means equals two three four five until
they find
the value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain remember domain i
mentioned that last time
you'll know that where to pick those
numbers or where to start guessing at
what that k value is
so let's take this when we're going to
use a use case
using k-means clustering to cluster cars
into brands
using parameters such as horsepower
cubic inches
make year etc so we're going to use the
data set
cars data having information about three
brands of cars
toyota honda and nissan we'll go back to
my
favorite tool the anaconda navigator
with the
jupiter notebook and let's go ahead and
flip over to our jupiter notebook
and in our jupiter notebook i'm going to
go ahead and just paste the
basic code that we usually started a lot
of these off with
we're not going to go too much into this
code because we've already discussed
numpy we've already discussed matplot
library and pandas
they'll be being the number array pandas
being the panda's dataframe
and matplot for the graphing and don't
forget uh since if you're using the
jupiter notebook you do need the matplot
library inline
so that it plots everything on the
screen if you're using a different
python editor then you probably don't
need that because it'll have a pop-up
window on your computer
and we'll go ahead and run this just to
load our libraries and our setup into
here
the next step is of course to look at
our data which i've already opened up in
a spreadsheet and you can see here we
have the miles per gallon
cylinders cubic inches horsepower weight
pounds
how you know how heavy it is time it
takes to get to 60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90.
what year it is so this is you can
actually see this is kind of older cars
and then the brand toyota
honda nissan so the different cars are
coming from
all the way from 1971 if we scroll down
to uh the 80s we have between the 70s
and 80s the number of cars that they've
put out
and let's uh when we come back here
we're going to importing the data so
we'll go ahead and do
data set equals and we'll use pandas to
read this
in and it's a from a csv file remember
you can always post this
in the comments and request the data
files for these
either in the comments here on the
youtube video or go to simplylearn.com
and request that
the car csv i put it in the same folder
as
the code that i've stored so my python
code is stored in the same folder so i
don't have to put the full path
if you store them in different folders
you do have to change this and double
check your name variables
and we'll go ahead and run this and
we've chosen data set
arbitrarily because you know it's a data
set we're importing and we've now
imported our car csv into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the x data this is
the
one that we're going to try to figure
out what's going on with
and then there's a number of ways to do
this but we'll do it in a simple loop so
you can actually see what's going on so
we'll do
four i and x dot columns
so we're going to go through each of the
columns and
a lot of times it's important i'll make
lists of the columns
and do this because i might remove
certain columns or there might be
columns that
i want to be processed differently but
for this
we can go ahead and take x of i and we
want to go
fill in a and that's a pandas command
but the question is what we're going to
fill the missing data with
we definitely don't want to just put in
a number that doesn't actually mean
something
and so one of the tricks you can do with
this is we can take
x of i and in addition to that we want
to go ahead and turn this into
an integer because a lot of these are
integers so we'll go ahead and keep it
integers
and let me add the bracket here and a
lot of editors will do this they'll
think that you're closing one bracket
make sure you get that second bracket in
there if it's a double bracket
that's always something that happens
regularly so once we have our integer of
x of y this is going to fill in any
missing data with the average and i was
so busy closing one set of brackets i
forgot that the mean is also has
brackets in there for the pandas
so we can see here we're going to fill
in all the data with the average value
for that column so there's missing data
it's in
the average of the data it does have
then once we've done that
we'll go ahead and loop through it again
and
just check and see to make sure
everything is filled in correctly
and we'll print and then we take x is
null and this returns a set of the null
value or the how many lines are null
and we'll just sum that up to see what
that looks like and so when i run this
and so with the x what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because that had the models that's what
we're
trying to see if we can cluster these
things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the x out
for one we could take the x and we could
go
data set our variable we're using and
use the i
location one of the features that's in
pandas
and we could take that and then take all
the rows
and all but the last column of the data
set
and at this time we could do values we
just convert it to values
so that's one way to do this and if i
let me just put this down here and print
x it's a capital x we chose and i run
this you can see it's just the values
we could also take out the values and
it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it
what i like to do with this is instead
of doing the i
location which does integers more common
is to come in here
and we have our data set and we're going
to do data
set dot or data set dot
columns and remember that lists all the
columns so
if i come in here let me just
mark that as red and i print
data set dot columns
you can see that i have my index here i
have my mpg cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand
would be to do data columns of
everything but the last
one minus one so now if i print this
you'll see the brand disappears
and so i can actually just take data set
columns
minus one and i'll put it right in here
for the columns we're going to look at
and let's un mark this and
unmark this and now if i do
an x dot head i have a new data frame
and you can see right here we have all
the different columns except for the
brand at the end of the year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set
you're going to get an error later on
and it'll say cannot convert string
to float value and that's because if for
some reason these things the way they
recorded them must been recorded as
strings
so we have a neat feature in here on
pandas to convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert
underscore numeric
equals true and yes i did have to go
look that up i don't have it memorized
the convert numeric in there
if i'm working with a lot of these
things i remember them but um
depending on where i'm at what i'm doing
i usually have to look it up
and we run that oops i must have missed
something in here let me double check my
spelling
and when i double check my spelling
you'll see i missed the first underscore
in the convert objects
when i run this it now has everything
converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data
and eliminate null values most people
when they're doing small amounts
working with small data pools discover
afterwards that they have a null value
and they have to go back and do this
so you know be aware whenever we're
formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it
and that's fine that's just part of
exploring the data and understanding
what you have
and i should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go easier to see
so we'll do 4i in working with x
dot columns we'll page through all the
columns
and we want to take x of i and we're
going to change that we're going to
alter it
and so with this we want to go ahead and
fill in
x of i pandas has the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data then we'll put my brackets
up and there's a lot of different ways
to fill this data if you have a really
large data set some people just void out
that data because
and then look at it later in a separate
exploration of data
one of the tricks we can do is we can
take our
column and we can find the means
and the means is in other are quotation
marks
so we take the columns we're going to
fill in the non-existing one with the
means
the problem is that returns a decimal
float so
some of these aren't decimals certainly
let me be a little careful of doing this
but for this example we're just going to
fill it in
with the integer version of this it
keeps it on par with the other data that
isn't a decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check then you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right
so we're going to go through and test
for
missing data and one of the ways you can
do that
is simply go in here and take our x of
i column so it's going to go through the
x of i column it says is null
so it's going to return any any place
there's a null value it actually goes
through
all the rows of each column is null
and then we want to go ahead and sum
that so we take that and we add the sum
value and these are all pandas so is
null is a panda
command and so is sum and if we go
through that we go ahead and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns
have zero null values so we've now
tested and double checked and our data
is nice and clean we have no
null values everything is now a number
value
we turned it into numeric and we've
removed the last column in our data
and at this point we're actually going
to start using the elbow method to find
the optimal number of clusters
so we're now actually getting into the
sk learn part
uh the k means clustering on here
i guess we'll go ahead and zoom it up
one more not so you can see what i'm
typing in here
and then from sk learn we're going to
or sk learn cluster
i'm going to import k
means i always forget to capitalize the
k
and the m when i do this so it's capital
k capital m
k means and we'll go and create a
um array wcss equals let me get an empty
array
if you remember from the elbow method
from our slide
within the sums of squares wss is
defined as the sum of
square distance between each member of
the cluster and its centroid
so we're looking at that change in
differences as far as a square distance
and we're going to run this over a
number of k-mean values
in fact let's go for i in range we'll do
11 of them
range zero eleven and the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
create the
actual we'll do it all lowercase
and so we're going to create this object
from the k-means that we just
imported and
the variable that we want to put into
this is
in clusters we're going to set that
equals to
i that's the most important one because
we're looking at how
increasing the number of clusters
changes our answer
there are a lot of settings to the
k-means
our guys in the back did a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones that you see in a
lot of stuff
is how you would knit your k-means so we
have k-means plus
plus this is just a tool to let the
model itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial
incentroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a max
iteration we put in there
we have the infinite the random state
equals zero
you really don't need to worry too much
about these when you're first learning
this
as you start digging in deeper you start
finding that these are shortcuts that
will speed up the process
as far as the setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in
clusters equals i so we're going to
literally
train our k means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times
and if you're working with big data you
know the first thing you do is you
run a small sample of the data so you
can test all your stuff on it
and you can already see the problem that
if i'm going to iterate through a
terabyte of data
11 times and then the k-means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times
that's a heck of a process so you got to
be a little careful with this a lot of
times though you can
find your elbow using the elbow method
find your optimal number on a sample of
data especially if you're working with
larger data sources so we want to go
ahead and take our k means and we're
just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the sklearn
very common
you fit your model and if you remember
correctly our variable we're using is
the capital
x and once we fit this value
we go back to the array we made and we
want to go and just depend that value on
the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it
generates it it generates the value
you're looking for is
inertia so k means dot inertia will pull
that specific value out that we need
and let's get a visual on this we'll do
our plt
plot and what we're plotting here
is first the x axis which is range 0
11 so that will generate a nice little
plot there
and the wcss for our y axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title
and let's get some labels so let's go
ahead and do plt
x label and we'll do we'll do a number
of clusters for that
and plt y label
and for that we can do oops there we go
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there
and finally we want to go ahead and
display our graph which is simply
plt dot oops dot show there we go and
because we have it set to inline
it'll appear in line hopefully i didn't
make a type error on there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there
at uh two and again right around three
and four and then after that there's not
very much
now as a data scientist if i was looking
at this
i would do either three or four and i'd
actually try both of them to see what
the
output look like and they've already
tried this in the back so we're just
going to use three as a setup on here
and let's go ahead and see what that
looks like when we actually use this to
show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the cars
data set and basically we're going to
copy the code that we loop through up
above
where k means equals k means number of
clusters and we're just going to set the
number of clusters to three
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do three and four
on this and graph them just to see how
they come up differently be kind of
curious to look at that
but for this we're just going to set it
to 3. go ahead and create our own
variable
y k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there
to k means but we're not going to do a
fit
we're going to do a fit predict is the
setup you want to use
and when you're using untrained models
you'll see
a slightly different because usually you
see fit and then you see just the
predict
but we want to both fit and predict the
k-means on this
and let's fit underscore predict and
then our capital x is the data we're
working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick
we're going to take our x value and
we're going to set x as
matrix so we're converting this into a
nice
rows and columns kind of set up but we
want the we're going to have columns
equals none so it's just going to be a
matrix of data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see these
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated
so there's like minor changes in the
versions and future versions
instead of matrix now that it's more
common to set it dot
values instead of doing as matrix but
maths matrix works just fine
for right now and you'll want to update
that later on but let's go ahead and
dive in and plot this and see what that
looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data i always like to take a look and
see
what i am plotting so let's take a look
at y
k means i'm just going to print that out
down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0
2 1 2. so it's clustering these
different
rows of data based on the three
different
spaces it thinks it's going to be and
then let's go ahead and print
x and see what we have for x and we'll
see that x
is an array it's a matrix so we have our
different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array
so we're only going to be looking at the
first two
or positions zero and one and if you
were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting
you might actually do a little different
than and dig a little deeper into the
different
aspects because this is all the
different columns we looked at but we
look at columns one and two for this to
make it easy
so let's go ahead and clear this data
out of here and let's bring up our plot
and we're going to do a scatter plot
here so plt scatter
and this looks a little complicated so
let's explain what's going on with this
we're going to take the x values
and we're only interested in y of k
means
equals 0 the first cluster okay
and then we're going to take value 0 for
the x axis
and then we're gonna do the same thing
here we're only interested in
k means equals zero but we're going to
take this second column so we're looking
at the first two columns
in our answer or in the data and then
the guys in the back played with this a
little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
with as the size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots
we're going to use red for this one and
when they were looking at the data
and what came out it was definitely the
toyota on this we're just going to go
ahead and label it toyota
again that's something you really have
to explore in here
as far as playing with those numbers and
see what looks good
we'll go ahead and hit enter in there
and i'm just going to paste in the next
two lines
which is the next two cars and this is
our nissa and honda
and you'll see with our scatter plot
we're now looking at where
y underscore k means equals one and we
want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns zero and one
and each of these rows then corresponds
to nissan and honda
and i'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and uh finally let's take a look and put
the centroids on there
again we're going to do a scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our k-means
the model we created dot cluster centers
and we're going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with 0 and 1.
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow
and we'll label them it's always good to
have some good labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title plt
title and pop up there
plt titles you always want to make your
graphs look pretty and we'll call it
clusters of
car make and one of the features of the
plot library is you can add a
legend it'll automatically bring in it
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
toyota nissan and honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's inline
so if you're using a different editor
that's not the jupiter notebook
you'll get a pop-up of this and you
should have a nice set of clusters here
so we can look at this we have a
clusters of
honda and green toyota and red
nissan and purple and you can see where
they put the centroids to separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other
different data on here as far because we
only looked at the first two columns
this is just column one and two
or zero one as you label them in
computer scripting
but you can see here we have nice
clusters of car make and we were able to
pull out the data
and you can see how just these two
columns form very distinct clusters of
data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different
almost going in reverse you start
looking at the data and pulling apart
the columns to find out
why is the first group set up the way it
is
maybe you're doing loans and you want to
go well why is this group not defaulting
on their loans and why is the last group
defaulting on their loans
and why is the middle group 50
defaulting on their
bank loans and you start finding ways to
manipulate the data and pull out the
answers you want
so now that you've seen how to use
k-mean
for clustering let's move on to the next
topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm
is the simplest classification algorithm
used for binary or multi-classification
problems and we can see we have our
little girl from canada who's into
horror books is back
that's actually really scary when you
think about that with those big eyes
in the previous tutorial we learned
about linear regression
dependent and independent variables so
to brush up y equals mx plus c
very basic algebraic function of
y and x the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict
the independent variables x1
all the way up to xn are the features or
attributes we are going to use to
predict the target class
we know what a linear regression looks
like but using the graph we cannot
divide
the outcome into categories it's really
hard to categorize 1.5
3.6 9.8 for example
a linear regression graph can tell us
that with increase in number of hours
studied the marks of a student will
increase
but it will not tell us whether the
student will pass or not
in such cases where we need the output
as categorical value
we will use logistic regression and for
that we're going to use the sigmoid
function
so you can see here we have our marks 0
to 100
number of hours studied that's going to
be what they're comparing it to
in this example and we usually form a
line that says y equals mx plus c
and when we use the sigmoid function we
have p
equals 1 over 1 plus e to the minus y
it generates a sigmoid curve and so you
can see right here when you take the
ln which is the natural logarithm i
always thought it should be
nl not ln that's just the inverse of
e your e to the minus y and so we do
this we get
ln of p over one minus p equals m times
x
plus c that's the sigmoid curve function
we're looking for
and we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function as it
derives goes to 1
or to 0 depending on what your x value
is
and the probability if it's greater than
0.5
the value is automatically rounded off
to one indicating that the student will
pass
so if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass
then you have a threshold value at the
0.5 it automatically puts that right in
the middle usually
and your probability if it's less than
0.5 the value rendered off to zero
indicating the student will fail
so if they're not studying very hard
they're probably going to fail
this of course is ignoring the outliers
of that one student is just a natural
genius
and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately
i have to study hard to learn new stuff
problem statement
to classify whether a tumor is malignant
or
benign and this is actually one of my
favorite
data sets to play with because it has so
many features
and when you look at them you really are
hard to understand
you can't just look at them and know the
answer so it gives you a chance to kind
of dive into what data looks like when
you
aren't able to understand the specific
domain of the data but i also want you
to remind you that
in the domain of medicine if i told you
that my probability was really good it
classified things that say
90 or 95 percent and i'm classifying
whether
you're going to have a malignant or a b9
tumor i'm guessing that you're going to
go get it tested anyways so you got to
remember the domain we're working with
so why would you want to do that if you
know you're just going to go get a
biopsy because
you know it's that serious this is like
an all or nothing
just referencing the domain it's
important it might help the doctor
know where to look just by understanding
what kind
of tumor it is so it might help them or
aid them and something they missed from
before
so let's go ahead and dive into the code
and i'll come back to the domain part of
it in just a minute
so use case and we're going to do our
normal imports here we're importing
numpy
pandas seaborn the matplot library and
we're going to do matplot library in
line since i'm going to switch over to
anaconda
so let's go ahead and flip over there
and get this started so i've opened up a
new window
in my anaconda jupiter notebook
and by the way jupiter notebook you
don't have to use anaconda for the
jupyter notebook
i just love the interface and all the
tools and anaconda brings
so we got our import numpy as in p for
our
numpy number array we have our pandas pd
we're going to bring in seaborn to help
us with our graphs
as sns so many really nice tools in both
seaborn and matplot library
and we'll do our matplotlibrary.piplot
as plt
and then of course we want to let it
know to do it in line and let's go and
just run that so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data not creative today
equals pd and this happens to be in a
csv file so we'll use a pd.read
underscore
csv and i happen to name the file i
renamed it
data4p2.csv you can of course
write in the comments below the youtube
and request for the data set itself or
go to the simply learn website and we'll
be happy to supply that for you
and let's just um open up the data
before we go any further and let's just
see what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when i pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just a csv
file comma separated variables we have
an id
so i guess the categorizes for reference
or what id which
test was done the diagnosis m for
malignant
b for b9 so there's two different
options on there
and that's what we're going to try to
predict is the m and b and test it
and then we have like the radius mean or
average
the texture average perimeter mean area
mean
smoothness i don't know about you but
unless you're
a doctor in the field most of stuff i
mean you can guess what concave
means just by the term concave but i
really wouldn't know what that means in
the measurements they're taking
so they have all kinds of stuff like how
smooth it is uh the symmetry
and these are all float values let me
just page through them real quick
and you'll see there's i believe 36 if i
remember correctly in this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at
the different growth the tumorous growth
so
back in our data and i put this in the
same folder as a code
so i saved this code in that folder
obviously if you have it in a different
location you want to put the full path
in there and we'll just do
pandas first five lines of data with the
data dot head
when we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an id
we have a diagnosis if we go all the way
across
you'll see all the different columns
coming across displayed nicely
for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
seaborn
which we referenced as sns makes it very
easy to go in here and do a
joint plot you'll notice that very
similar to
because it is sitting on top of the plot
library
so the joint plot does a lot of work for
us and we're just going to look at the
first
two columns that we're interested in the
radius mean and the texture mean
we'll just look at those two columns and
data
equals data so that tells it which two
columns we're plotting
and that we're going to use the data
that we pulled in let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here and there's all kinds of cool
things on this graph to look at i mean
we have the texture mean and the radius
mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram
they show that for the radius mean
whereas the most commons radius mean
come up and where the most common
texture is
so we're looking at the tech the on each
growth its average
texture and on each radius its average
uh
radius on there it's a little confusing
because we're talking about the
individual objects
average and then we can also look over
here and see the
histogram showing us the median or
how common each measurement is and
that's only two columns so let's dig a
little deeper into
seaborn they also have a heat map and if
you're not familiar with heat maps a
heat map
just means it's in color that's all that
means heat map
i guess the original ones were plotting
heat density on something and so
ever since then it's just called a heat
map and we're going to take our data
and get our corresponding numbers to put
that into the heat map
and that's simply data dot c-o-r-r
for that that's a pandas expression
let's remember we're working in a pandas
data frame so that's one of the cool
tools in pandas
for our data and this is pull that
information into a heat map and see what
that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features
we have our id we have our texture we
have our area
our compactness concave points and if
you look down the middle
of this chart diagonal going from the
upper left to bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare
texture to texture they're identical so
they're 100 percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence
and you'll see that when you look at say
area or right below it it has almost a
black on there when you compare it to
texture
so these have almost no corresponding
data they don't really form a linear
graph or something that you can look at
and say how connected they are they're
very scattered data
this is really just a really nice graph
to get a quick look at your data
doesn't so much change what you do but
it changes
verifying so when you get an answer or
something like that or you start looking
at some of these individual
pieces you might go hey that doesn't
match according to
showing our heat map this should not
correlate with each other and if it is
you're going to have to start asking
well why what's going on what else is
coming in there but it does show some
really cool information on here
and we can see from the id there's no
real
one feature that just says if you go
across the top line
that lights up there's no one feature
that says hey if the area is a certain
size then
it's going to be b9 or malignant it says
there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big hint in the data that
we're trying to id this
whether it's malignant or b9 that's a
big hint to us as data scientists to go
okay
we can't solve this with any one feature
it's going to be something that includes
all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it
and while we're exploring the data let's
explore one more area
and let's look at data dot is null we
want to check
for null values in our data if you
remember from earlier
in this tutorial we did it a little
differently where we added stuff up and
sum them up
you can actually with pandas do it
really quickly data dot is null and
summit and it's going to go across all
the columns
so when i run this
you're going to see all the columns come
up with no null data
so we've just just to re-hash these last
few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seen how they plot with the seaborn
with a joint plot which shows both the
histogram
and the data plotted on the x y
coordinates
and obviously you can do that more in
detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the seaborn
heat map the sns
dot heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other
and forms a very nice combination or
points of scattering points
and you can also see areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says no values
okay so not a big deal if you miss it
but
it's no fun having to go back when
you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step
and now you're 10 steps later and you
got to go remember where you were
pulling the data in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
x and our y
let me just put that down here and we'll
set the x equal to
and there's a lot of different options
here certainly we could do
x equals all the columns except for the
first two because if you remember the
first two is the id and the diagnosis
so that certainly would be an option but
we're going to do is we're actually
going to
focus on the worst the worst radius the
worst texture
parameter area smoothness compactness
and so on one of the reasons to start
dividing your data up
when you're looking at this information
is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if i have two measurements
coming in
to my model it might overweigh them it
might
overpower the other measurements because
it's measuring it's basically taking
that information in twice
that's a little bit past the scope of
this tutorial i want you to take away
from this though is that we are dividing
the data up into pieces
and our team in the back went ahead and
said hey let's just look at the worst
so i'm going to create a an array and
you'll see this array
radius worst texture worse perimeter
worst we've just taken the worst of the
worst and i'm just going to put that
in my x so this x is still a pandas data
frame
but it's just those columns and our y if
you remember correctly
is going to be oops hold on one second
it's not x it's data there we go
so x equals data and then it's a list of
the different columns the worst of the
worst
and if we're going to take that then we
have to have our answer for our y
for the stuff we know and if you
remember correctly we're just going to
be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it
b9 or malignant and since it's a single
column we can just do diagnosis
oh i forgot to put the brackets or there
we go okay
so it's just diagnosis on there and we
can also
real quickly do like x dot head if you
want to see what that looks like
and y dot head and run this
and you'll see it only does the last one
i forgot about that if you don't do
print
you can see that the the y dot head is
just mmm because the first ones are all
malignant
and if i run this the x dot head is just
the first five values of radius worst
texture worse parameter worst area worst
and so on
i'll go ahead and take that out so
moving down
to the next step we've built our two
data sets our answer and then the
features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test
your model so we do that by splitting
the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import
train test split so we're going to split
it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this i
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups
so you have all kinds and there's
reasons for that which is past the scope
of this
and for this particular example isn't
necessary for this we're just going to
split it into two groups
one to train our data and one to test
our data
and the sklearn dot model selection
we have train test split you could write
your own quick code to do this we just
randomly divide the data up into two
groups but they do it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this
where we're going to generate four
variables capital x
train capital x test so we have our
training data we're going to
use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test
so this is the stuff we want to see how
good it did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just
imported and we're going to do x and our
y are two different data that's going in
for our split
and then the guys in the back came up
and wanted us to go ahead and use a test
size
equals 0.3 that's test underscore size
random state it's always nice to kind of
switch a random state around but not
that important
what this means is that the test size is
we're going to take 30
of the data and we're going to put that
into our test variables our y
test and our x test and we're going to
do 70
into the x train and the y train so
we're going to use 70
of the data to train our model and 30 to
test it
let's go ahead and run that and load
those up so
now we have all our stuff split up and
all our data ready to go
and now we get to the actual logistics
part we're actually going to do
our create our model so let's go ahead
and bring that in
from sklearn we're going to bring in our
linear model and we're going to
import logistic regression that's the
actual model we're using
and this we'll call it log model
stereo model and let's just set this
equal to
our logistic regression that we just
imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the models in
the sk learn we just need to go ahead
and fix it
fit do a fit on there and we use our x
train that we separated out with our y
train and let's go ahead and run this so
once we've run this we'll have a model
that fits this data
that 70 of our training data
and of course it prints this out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different
choices you can make but for word though
we're just going to let all the defaults
sit
we don't really need to mess with those
on this particular example and there's
nothing in here that really
stands out as super important until you
start
fine tuning it but for what we're doing
the basics will work just fine
and then let's we need to go ahead and
test out our model
is it working so let's create a variable
y predict
and this is going to be equal to our log
model and we want to do a predict again
very
standard format for the sk learn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it
and we're going to test why predict
against the y test
so we want to know what the model thinks
it's going to be that's what our y
predict is
and with that we want the capital x x
test so we have our train set and our
test set
and now we're going to do our y predict
and let's go ahead and run that
and if we print
y predict let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it presents
and i prints a nice array of
b and m for b9 and malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so that's pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and is functional
was very easy to create you'll always
discover with our data science
that as you explore this you spend a
significant amount of time prepping your
data and making sure your data coming in
is good
there's a saying good data in good
answers out
bad data in bad answers out that's only
half the thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predict here
log model.predict x test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrics we're going to import
classification report and that just
reports how good our model
is doing and then we're going to feed it
the model data let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual data so this is what
we actually know is true
and our prediction what our model
predicted for that data on the test side
and let's run that and see what that
does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have
a precision for b9 and malignant b and m
and we have a precision of 93 at 91.
a total of 92 so it's kind of the
average between these two 92 there's all
kinds of different information on here
your f1 score your recall your support
coming through on this and for this i'll
go ahead and just flip back to our
slides that they put together for
describing it
and so here we're going to look at the
precision using the classification
report
and you see this is the same printout i
had up above some of the numbers might
be different because it does randomly
pick out
which data we're using so this model is
able to predict the type of tumor with
91 percent accuracy so we look back here
let's
you'll see where we have uh b9 and it
actually is 92 coming up here
but we're looking about a 92 91
precision
and remember i reminded you about
domains and we're talking about the
domain of a medical domain
with a very catastrophic outcome you
know at 91 or 92 percent precision
you're still going to go in there and
have somebody do a biopsy on it
very different than if you're investing
money and there's a 92 percent chance
you're going to earn 10 percent
and 8 chance you're going to lose 8
you're probably going to bet the money
because at that odds it's pretty good
that you'll make some money and in the
long run you do that enough
you definitely will make money and also
with this domain
i've actually seen them use this to
identify different forms
of cancer that's one of the things that
they're starting to use these models for
because then it helps the doctor know
what to investigate
so that wraps up this section we're
finally we're going to go in there and
let's discuss the answer to the quiz
asked in machine learning tutorial part
1.
can you tell what's happening in the
following cases
grouping documents into different
categories based on the topic
and content of each document this is an
example of clustering where k-means
clustering can be used to group the
documents by topics using
bag of words approach so if you've
gotten in there that you're looking for
clustering
and hopefully you had at least one or
two examples like k-means that are used
for clustering different things
then give yourself a two thumbs up b
identifying handwritten digits in images
correctly
this is an example of classification the
traditional approach to solving this
would be to extract digit dependent
features like curvature of different
digits etc
and then use a classifier like svm to
distinguish between images
again if you got the fact that it's a
classification example
give yourself a thumb up and if you're
able to go hey let's use svm or another
model for this
give yourself those two thumbs up on it
c
behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as
designed this is an example of anomaly
detection
in this case the algorithm learns what
is normal and what is
not normal usually by observing the logs
of the website
give yourself a thumbs up if you got
that one and just for a bonus can you
think of another example of anomaly
detection
one of the ones i use it for my own
business is detecting anomalies in stock
markets
stock markets are very fickled and they
behave very radical
so finding those erratic areas and then
finding ways to track down
why they're erratic was something
released in social media was something
released
you can see where knowing where that
anomaly is
can help you to figure out what the
answer is to it in another area
d predicting salary of an individual
based
on his or her years of experience this
is an example of regression
this problem can be mathematically
defined as a function between
independent years of experience and
dependent variables
salary of an individual and if you guess
that this was a regression model
give yourself a thumbs up and if you
were able to remember that it
was between independent and dependent
variables
and that terms give yourself two thumbs
up choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get
access to 1 000 plus hours of video
content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more we're going to cover
mathematics for machine learning
so today's agenda is going to cover data
and its types
and we're going to dive into linear
algebra and its concepts
calculus statistics for machine learning
probability for machine learning
hands-on demos and of course thrown in
there in the middle is going to be your
matrixes and a few other things to go
along with all this
data and its types data denotes the
individual pieces of factual information
collected from various sources
it is stored processed and later used
for analysis
and so we see here just a huge grouping
of information
a lot of tech stuff money dollar signs
numbers and then you have your
performing analytics to drive insights
and hopefully you
have a nice sure your shareholders
gather it at the meeting and you're able
to explain it in something they can
understand
so we talk about data types of data we
have in our types of data we have a
qualitative
categorical you think nominal or ordinal
and then you have your quantitative or
numerical which is discrete or
continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary
always people's favorite is the
vocabulary words
okay not mine uh but let's dive into
this what we mean by nominal
nominal they are used to label various
label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc
it's something that you either mark true
or false this is a label
it's on or off either they have a red
hat on or they do not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data labels
uh think of it as a true false kind of
setup
and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one movie ratings etc
you can see here the salary rains if you
have 10 000 to 20 000
number of employees earning that rate is
150 20 000 to 30
100 and so forth some of the terms
you'll hear is bucket
uh this is where you have 10 different
buckets and you want to separate it into
something that makes sense into those 10
buckets
and so when we start talking about
ordinal
a lot of times when you get down to the
brass bones again we're talking true
false
so if you're a member of the 10 to 20k
reigns
so forth those would each be either part
of that group or you're not
but now we're talking about buckets and
we want to count how many people are in
that bucket
quantitative numerical data falls into
two classes
discrete or continuous and so data with
a final set of values which can be
categorized
class strength questions answered
correctly
and runs hit and cricket a lot of times
when you see this you can think
integer and a very restricted integer
i.e you can only have 100 questions on a
test
so you can it's very discreet i only
have 100 different values that it can
attain
so think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open in
or anything like that so discrete is
very solid
simple to count set number continuous on
the other hand
continuous data can take any numerical
value within a range
so water pressure weight of a person etc
usually we start thinking about float
values where they can get phenomenally
small in their in what they're worth
and there's a whole series of values
that falls right between discrete and
continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still
discrete but it starts to get
complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from 525.33
to 580.60
there's a lot of point values in there
it'd still be called discrete
but you start looking at it as almost
continuous because it does have such a
variance in it
now uh we talked about no we did we went
over nominal and ordinal
almost true false charts and we looked
at quantitative and numerical data
which were starting to get into numbers
discrete you can usually
a lot of times discrete will be put into
it could be put into true false but
usually it's not
so we want to address this stuff and the
first thing you want to look at is the
very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at
linear algebra you can remember back
when your
euclidean geometry we have a line well
let's go through this we have a linear
algebra is the domain of mathematics
concerning
linear equations and the representations
in vector spaces and through matrixes
i told you we're going to talk about
matrix is so
a linear equation is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10.
very linear 10x plus 12.4y
equals z and now you can actually solve
these two equations by combining them
and this we're talking about a linear
equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction and these values usually think
of an x
y z plot so each one is a direction
and the actual distance of like a
triangle a b
is c and then your matrix can describe
all kinds of things
i find matrixes confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because
of the magnitude and the different
things they're used for
and a matrix is a chart or a
you know think of a spreadsheet but you
have your rows and your columns and
you'll see here we have
a times b equals c very important to
know
your counts so depending on how the math
is being done
what you're using it for making sure you
have the same rows and number of columns
or a single number
there's all kinds of things that play in
that that can make matrixes confusing
but really has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in
are you adding in multiple polynomials
where you have like
a x squared plus b y plus you know you
start to see that can be very confusing
versus a very straightforward matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such
primary this is what we're here to talk
about is these different math
mathematical computations that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of 1 is
called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have uh
ax plus b equals c which is a one
variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c
a x plus b y plus z c z equals d
and so forth but all of these are to the
power of one you don't see x squared you
don't see x cubed
so we're talking about linear equations
that's what we're talking about
in their addition if you have already
dived into say
neural networks you should recognize
this a x plus b y plus c
z setup plus the intercept
which is basically your your neural
network each node adding up
all the different inputs and we can
drill down into that
most common formula is your y equals mx
plus c
so you have your y equals the
m which is your slope your x value
plus c which is your
y-intercept you kind of label it wrong
here uh
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you set
x equal to zero y equals c and that's
that's your y-intercept right there
uh and that's they just had a reverse
value of y when x equals zero
equals the y-intercept which is c and
your slow gradient line which is your
m so you get your y equals two x plus
three
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems
and then of course the one of the most
important takeaways is the slope
gradient of the line so the slope is
very important that
m value in this case we went ahead and
solved this
if you have y equals 2x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice
line graph here on the right so
matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in
columns and rows so we're talking
m rows by n columns here a11 is
denotes the element of the first row in
the first column
similarly a12 and it's really pronounced
a11 in this particular setup
so it's a row one column one a 12 is
a row one column two uh first row and
second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as
like a capital letter a smaller case a
for the top row
or i mean you can see where they can go
all kinds of different directions as far
as the value
you just take a moment to realize
there's need to be some designation as
far as what row it's in
and what column it's in and we have our
basic operations we have addition so
when you think about addition you have
two matrixes of two by two and you just
add each individual
number in that matrix and then when you
get to the bottom you have
in this case the solution is 12 10 plus
2 is 12
5 plus 3 is 8 and so on and the same
thing with subtraction
now again you're counting is you want to
check your
dimensions of the matrix the shape
you'll see
shape come up a lot in programming so
we're talking about dimensions
we're talking about the shape if the two
shapes are
equal this is what happens when you add
them together
or subtract them and we have
multiplication
when you look at the multiplication you
end up with a very a slightly different
setup going
now if we look at our last one where
we're like why this always gets to me
when we get to matrixes
they don't really say why you multiply
matrixes
my first thought is 1 times 2 4 times 3
but if you look at this we get 1 times 2
plus 4 times three one times three plus
four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times
five if you're looking at these matrixes
uh
think of this more as an equation and so
we have
if you remember we went back up here for
our multiple line equations let's just
go back up a couple slides where we were
looking at
a two variable so this is a two variable
equation
ax plus b y equals c
and this is a way to make it very quick
to solve these variables and that's why
you have the matrix and that's why you
do
the multiplication the way they do and
this is the
dot product of 1 times 2
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times five
and it gives us a nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough
inputs and then in matrix operations
when you're dealing with
a lot of matrixes now keep in mind
multiplying matrixes is different than
finding the product of two matrixes
okay so we're talking about
multiplication we're talking about
solving for equations when you're
finding the product
you are just finding 1 times 2. keep
that in mind because that does come up
i've had that come up a number of times
where i'm
altering data and i get confused as to
what i'm doing with it
transpose flipping the matrix over is
diagonal
comes up all the time where you have you
still have 12 but instead of it being a
12 8 it's now 12 14 8 21
you're just flipping the columns and the
rows and then of course you can do an
inverse changing the signs of the values
across this main diagonal
and you can see here we have the inverse
a to the minus 1 and
ends up with instead of 12 8 14 12 is
now minus 22 minus 12.
vectors vector just means we have
a value and a direction and
we have down four numbers here on our
vector
in mathematics a one dimensional matrix
is called a vector
so if you have your x plot and you have
a single value
that values along the x axis and it's a
single
dimension if you have two dimensions you
can think about putting them on a graph
you might have x and you might have y
and each value denotes a direction and
then of course the actual distance
is going to be the hypothesis of that
triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means uh for categorizing and how close
data is together
they will compute that based on the
pythagorean theorem so you would take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance
as far as where that point is where that
vector exists or an actual
point value and then you can compare
that point value
to another one it makes a very easy
comparison versus
comparing 50 or 60 different numbers
and that brings us up to i gene vectors
and i gene values
i gene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span
wall transformation and i gene values
the scalar values that are associated to
the vectors
conceptually you can think of the vector
as your picture you have a picture it's
two dimensions x and y and so when you
do those two dimensions and those two
values
or whatever that value is
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it
and so if we take and we have a vector
a and that's a set value uh
b is um your is your you have a and b
which is your hygiene vector
two is the i gene value so we're
altering
all the values by two that means we're
uh maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall
if you're doing picture editing that's
one of the places this comes in
but you can see when you're transforming
your different information
how you transform it is then your igene
value and you can see here
vector after line transit transition
we have 3a a is the hygiene vector 3 is
the iogene value
so a doesn't change that's whatever we
started with that's your original
picture
and three is skewing it one direction
and maybe a b is being skewed another
direction
and so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those
by the aging values so let's go ahead
and pull up a demo
on linear algebra and to do this i'm
going to go through my trusted anaconda
into my jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new notebook called
linear algebra
since we are working in python we're
going to use our numpy i always import
that as
np or numpy array probably the most
popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy
we are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10
15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15
29 and i went in and added a space there
in between
so it's easier to read and since it's
the
last line we don't have to put the print
statement on it unless you want we can
simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
we have 10 15 29 and we get
30 24 which is what you expect 10 plus
20
15 plus 9. you could almost look at this
addition
as being
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do
a dot t plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that we now get them
we now have 30 24 going the other way
we could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b i can also do a plus
b dot
t and you're going to see that that will
come out the same
the 30 24 whether i transpose a and b or
transpose them both at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a
minus b and we run that
and we get minus 10 6. now remember this
is the last line in this particular
section that's why not to put the print
around it
and just like we did before we can
transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main setup and
then we get a minus 10
6 going the other way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do
a scalar multiplication and just put
down
scalar so you can remember that what
we're talking about here is i have
this array here u and if i go a
times u we'll take the value 2 we'll
multiply it by every value in here
so 2 times 30 is 60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way so
in numpy we have what they call dot
product
and uh with this this is in a two
dimensional vectors it is the equivalent
of
two matrix multiplication remember we
were talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the well let's walk
through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
um
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6
or our u and our v uh and then we're
going to go ahead and do
if we take the values
and if you remember correctly an array
like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6. we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go and then we'll go ahead and
do
the np dot dot of u
comma
v and we'll find when we do this
we go and run this uh we're going to get
370 370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve linear
algebra when you have multiple numbers
going across
and so this could be very complicated we
could have a whole string of different
variables going in here
but for this we get a nice value for our
dot multiplication
and we did addition earlier which is
just your basic addition
and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do let's
create two
complex matrixes this one
is a matrix of um you know 12 10
4 6 4 31. we'll just print out a so you
can see what that looks like here's
print a we print a
out you can see that we have a
two by three layer matrix for a
and we can also put together always kind
of fun when you're playing with print
values
we could do something like this we could
go in here
there we go we could print a we have it
end with
uh equals a run and this kind of gives
it a nice look
here's your matrix that's all this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all
all that is doing on there and then we
can simply add in
what is a plus b and you should already
guess because this is the same as what
we did before there's no difference
we do a simple vector addition we have
12 plus 2 is 14
10 plus 8 is 18 and so on and just like
we did the
matrix addition we can also do a
minus b and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2
is 10 10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go 8 minus
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10
10 minus 8 is 2 4 minus 46 is minus 42
and so forth
so same as the subtraction as before we
just call it matrix subtraction is
identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just
one number to a matrix you can also do
scalar multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have
b which is your array we can also do a
times
b when we run that you can see here we
have 2 times 4
is 8. 5 times 4 is 20 and so forth
you're just multiplying the 4 across
each one of these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up a little bit of a brain teaser
is matrix and vector multiplication
and so we're looking at this uh
we are just doing regular arrays it
doesn't necessarily have to be a numpy
array
we have a which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array and so we can from
here do the dot
a b and this is going to return two
values
and the first value is that it's you
could say it's like
we're doing the this array b array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it
splits it up so you have a matrix of
vector multiplication and you can mix
and match
when you get into really complicated uh
backend stuff this becomes
more common because you're now you've
got layers upon layers of data
and so you you'll end up with a matrix
and a set of bolt
vector matrices do you want to multiply
now keep in mind that if you're doing
data science a lot of times you're not
looking at this this is what's going on
behind the scenes
so if you're in the scikit looking at sk
learn where you're doing linear
regression models this is some of the
math that's hidden behind the scenes is
going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and
manipulate the data around so it fits
right and then you go back in
and you run it through the psi kit and
if we can do
up here where we did a matrix and vector
multiplication we can also do matrix two
matrix multiplication
and if we run this where we have the two
matrixes uh you can see a very
complicated array that of course comes
out on there for our dot
and just to reiterate it we have our
transpose matrix which is your dot
t and so if we create a matrix a and we
do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from 5
10 15 20 25 30 to 5 15
25 10 20 30 rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot
it also comes up a lot with xy plotting
when you put in the pi plot you have one
format
where they're looking at pairs and
numbers and then they want all of x's
and all y's
so you know the transpose is an
important tool both for your math and
for plotting and all kinds of things
another tool that we didn't discuss uh
is your
identity matrix uh and this one is more
definition uh the
identity matrix we have here one where
we just did
two so it comes down as 1 0 0 1
1 0 0 0 1 0 it creates a diagonal of one
and what that is is when you're doing
your identities you could be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate
and of course when you have feature one
compared to feature one to itself
it is always one where
usually it's between zero one depending
on how well correlates
so when we're talking about identity
matrix that's what we're talking about
right here
is that you create this preset matrix
and then you might adjust these numbers
depending on
what you're working with and what the
domain is and then another thing we can
do
to kind of wrap this up will hit you
with the most complicated
piece of this puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix and let's just go ahead and put
the
um it's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the uh
the website for numpy
so given a square matrix a here's our
square matrix a which is two one zero
zero one zero one two one
keep in mind 3 by 3 is square it's got
to be equal
it's going to return the matrix a
inverse
satisfying dot a a inverse so here's our
matrix multiplication
and then of course it equals the dot uh
yeah a
inverse of a with an identity shape of
a dot shaped zero this is just reshaping
the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
uh we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see what we end up with
is we end up with uh an array 0.5 minus
0.5
and so forth with our 2 1 one going down
two one zero zero one zero one two one
uh getting into a little deep on the
math
understanding when you need this is
probably really is
is what's really important when you're
doing data science
versus handwriting this out and looking
up the math and handwriting all the
pieces out
you do need to know about the linear
algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up
we took a look at the algebra side of it
let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side
of what's going on here with the machine
learning so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all
part of the bag of tricks especially
when you're doing large neural networks
but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end
so when it comes up you really do need
to understand from the data science not
data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation uh so we talk
about calculus
uh we're going to go ahead and
understand it by
talking about cars versus time and speed
uh so it helps to calculate the
spontaneous
rate of change so suppose we plot a
graph of the speed of a car with respect
to time
so as you can see here going down the
highway probably merged into the highway
from an on-ramp
so i had to accelerate so my speed went
way up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and i accelerate again
up to the speed limit
and maybe peter's off up there so you
can look at this as
as the speed versus time i'm getting
faster and faster because i'm
continually
accelerating and if i hit the brakes you
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect of time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the endpoint of
delta x so we can calculate
a simple if you had x and delta x we
could put a line there
and that slope of the line is our
acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points i want to know what across
the whole of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
so the idea is instead of i mean if you
ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period
up into maybe 10 sections and you use
that and you can calculate the
acceleration between each one of those
10 sections kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller
until delta x is almost infinitesimally
small and so we get a function of a
equals a limit as h goes to 0 of
a function of a plus h minus a function
of a over
h and that is you're computing the
slope of the line we're just computing
that slope under smaller and smaller and
smaller samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral
you can see down here we have our nice
integral sign
looks like a giant s and that's what
that means is that we've taken this down
to
as small as we can for that sampling
so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process
in the integration similar small
intervals are made of the smallest
possible length of x
plus delta x where delta x approaches
almost an infinitesimally small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up
all the links together so we're summing
up all the accelerations from the
beginning to the end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d of x
equals a plus c that is
our basic calculus here so when we talk
about multivariate
calculus multivariate calculus deals
with functions that have multiple
variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
change in w over change of time equals
change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt
it gets pretty complicated and it really
translates into
the multivariate integration using
double integrals
and so you have the the sum of the sum
of f x of y of d of a
equals the sum from c to d and a to b of
f of x
y d x d y equals the sum of a to b
sum of c to d of f x y d y
d x understanding the very specifics
of everything going on in here and
actually doing the math
is usually calculus 1 calculus 2 and
differential equations
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into
and solve these math equations what we
want to take from here is we're talking
about calculus
we're talking about summing of all these
different slopes
and so we're still solving a linear
expression we're still solving
y equals m x plus b but we're doing this
for infinitely small x's and then we
want to sum them up that's what this
integral sign means the sum of a of x d
of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
multivariate differentiation using the
chain rule
uh when we come in here and we have the
change of w to the change of t
equals the change of w dz uh and
so forth that's what's going on here
that's what these means
we're basically looking for the area
under the curve which really comes
to how is the change changing
speeds going up how is that changing and
then you end up with a multiple layer
so if i have three layers of neural
networks how is the third
layer changing based on the second layer
changing which is based on the first
layer changing
and you get the picture here that now we
have a very complicated
multivariate integration with integrals
the good news is we can solve this
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation
so the nice thing is that you don't have
to solve this on paper unless you're a
data analysis and you're working on the
back end
of integrating these formulas and
building the script to actually build
them
so we talk about applications of
calculus it provides us the tools to
build an accurate predictive model
so it's really behind the scenes we want
to guess at what the change of the
change of the change is
a little goofy i i know i just threw
that out there it's kind of a meta term
but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables so there's our multiple
variables going in there
if one variable is changing how does it
affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find
the local and global maxima
and this is really big we're going to
actually going to have a whole section
here on gradient
descent because it is really i mean i
talked about neural networks and how
you can see how the different layers go
in there but gradient descent is one of
the
most key things for trying to guess the
best answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent and before we open up
the code let's just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go there ah hard to read
there
and i want to make the error as low as
possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line
here which is the minimum
value so we're looking for the minimum
and it does that by sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace
here and it goes hey this is still going
down it goes here
and then goes back over here and then
goes a little bit closer
and it's just playing a high low until
it gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error and
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best
output of it that's simply minus the
value
so if you're looking for where the peak
is this is the same as
a negative for where the valley is i'm
looking for that valley
that's all that is this is a way of
finding it so
the cool thing is all the heavy lifting
done um i actually
ended up putting together one of these a
while back as
uh when i didn't know about sidekick and
i was just starting
boy it's a long while back and uh
is playing high low how do you play low
not get stuck in the valleys
figure out these curves and things like
that well you do that
and the back end is all the calculus and
differential equations to calculate this
out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
so instead we're going to put together
the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so uh guys in the back put together a
nice little piece of code here which is
kind of fun
uh some things we're going to note and
this is this is really
important stuff because when you start
doing your data science and digging into
your machine learning models
you're going to find these things are
stumbling blocks
the first one is current x where do we
start at
keep in mind your model that you're
working with
is very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it
the first question is where do we start
and we started at this because the
algorithm starts at x equals three
so we our arbitrarily picked five
learning rate is
uh how many bars to skip going one where
the other
i'm in fact i'm going to separate that a
little bit because these two are really
important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about
well here's our here's the function
we're going to use our
gradient of our function 2 times x plus
5
keep it simple so that's a function
we're gonna work with
so if i'm dealing with increments of a
thousand point one is going to be a
very long time and if i'm dealing with
increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so i
won't get a very good answer
and then we look at precision this tells
us when to stop the algorithm
so again very specific to what you're
working on
if you're working with money and
you don't convert it into a float value
you might be dealing with 0.01 which is
a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations
we want something to cut out at a
certain point usually that's built into
a lot of
minimization functions and then here's
our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go
while previous step size is greater than
precision and it errors is less than max
and
max iters say that
10 times fast
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
and then we also don't want to go past a
thou or whatever this is a million or
ten thousand
uh running that's actually pretty high i
almost never do max
iterations more than like a hundred or
two hundred
rare occasions you might go up to four
or five hundred if it's depending on the
problem you're working with
uh so we have our previous equals our
current that way we can track
time wise uh the current now equals the
current minus the rate
times the formula of our previous x
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous
step size equals the absolute current
previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get
too far and then we're just going to
print the local minimum occurs at
x on here and if we go ahead and run
this
you can see right here it gets down to
this point and it says hey
um local minimum is minus 3.3222 for
this particular series we created
this is created off of our formula here
lambda x2 times x plus 5.
now when i'm running this stuff uh
you'll see this come up a lot
in uh with the sk learn kit and
one of the nice reasons of breaking this
down the way we did
is i could go over those top pieces
those top pieces are everything when you
start looking at these minimization
toolkits in built-in code and so
from we'll just do it's actually
docs dot scipy.org
and we're looking at the scikit
there we go optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value you have
the function that's going in this
function can be very
complicated so we used a very simple
function up here
it could be there's all kinds of things
that could be on there
and there's a number of methods to solve
this as far as how they shrink down
and your x naught there's your there's
your start value so your function
your start value um there's all kinds of
things that come in here that you can
look at which we're not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints
bounds some of this it does
automatically but you really
the big thing i want to point out here
is you need to have a starting point
you want to start with something that
you already know is mostly the answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out
a lot of vocabulary and statistics ah
so statistics well i guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an edel
class
so a bunch of stuff going on statistics
statistics concerns with the collection
organization analysis interpretation and
presentation of data that is
a mouthful um so we have from
end to end where does it come from is it
valid what does it mean
how do we organize it um how do we
analyze it
then you gotta take those analysis and
interpret it into something that uh
people can use kind of reduce it to
understandable
um and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is gonna understand what the
heck you did
so we look at the terminologies there is
a lot of terminologies depending on what
domain you're working in
so clearly if you're working in
a domain that deals with viruses
and t cells and and
how does you know where does that come
from you're studying the different
people then you can have a population
if you are working with
mechanical gear you know a little bit
different if you're looking for the
wobbling
statistics uh to know when to replace a
rotor on a machine or something like
that
that can be a big deal you know we have
these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up
at one point do you replace them instead
of waiting for it to break in which case
it costs a lot of money instead of
replacing a bushing you're replacing the
whole fan
unit an interesting project that came up
for our city a while back so population
all objects are measurements whose
properties are being observed
so that's your population all the
objects it's easy to see it with people
because we have our population enlarged
but in the case of the sewer fans we're
talking about how
the fan units that's the population of
fans that we're working with
you have a parameter a matrix that is
used to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied
you don't want to do them all because
then you don't have a if you come up
with a conclusion for everyone
you don't have a way of testing it so
you take a sample sometimes you don't
have a choice you can only take a sample
of what's going on
you can't study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object
in a population types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method
based on the theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
a non-probabilistic approach
selecting samples based on the
subjective judgment of the researcher
rather than
random selection it has to do with
convenience
trying to reach a quota or snowball
and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp on
that says biased
so you gotta be very careful on that so
probabilistic
sampling when we talk about a random
sampling we select
random size samples from each group or
category
so we it's as random as you can get we
talk about
systematic sampling we're selecting
random size samples from each group or
category with a fixed
periodic interval so we kind of split it
up this would be like a time set up or
our different categories
and you might ask your question what is
a category or a group
if you look at i'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
and when i say separated i don't mean
separated from their
place where they live i mean as far as
the analysis we want to look at the
different groups
and make sure they're all represented so
if we had like an
eighty percent uh of a group that is uh
say hispanic and or indian and
also in that same area we have 20 20
percent who are
let's call our expatriates they left
america and they're nice and
your caucasian group we might want to
sample
a group that is representative of both
so we're talking about stratified
sampling
and we're talking about groups those are
the groups we're talking about and that
brings us to stratified sampling
selecting approximately equal size
samples from
each group or category this way we can
actually
separate the categories and give us an
insight
into the different cultures and how that
might affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of
depends on what you're working with as
far as your data and what you're
studying
and so we can see here just a little bit
more we'd have selecting 25 employees
from a company of 250 employees randomly
don't care anything about them what
groups
are in which office they're in nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique employees in a
company of 250 employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or categories by the
branch and
the category could depend on what you're
studying so it has a lot of
variation on there you see this kind of
grouping and categorizing is also
used to generate a lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you've got to be
very careful of that and it's very
unethical thing to kind of do
so types of statistics uh we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential
statistics there are so many different
terms and statistics to break it up
uh so we so we're talking about a
particular
setup so we're talking about descriptive
of inferential
statistics the base of the word describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like
with inferential statistics we're going
to take that from the small population
to a large population
so if you're working with a drug company
you might look at the data and say
these people were helped by this drug
they did
80 percent better as far as their health
or 80 percent better survival rate than
the people
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people
so that's where you get your inferential
so we are
predicting how it's going to affect the
greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative
analysis of data so we have a measure of
central tendencies we have your mean
median and mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile
range your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second
but one of them you can think of is um
how the data difference differences you
know
what's the max min range all that stuff
is your spread
and anything that's just a single number
is usually your central
tendencies measure central tendencies so
we talk about the mean
it is the average of the set of values
considered what is the average outcome
of whatever is going on
and then your median separates the
higher half and the lower half
of data so where's the center point of
all your different
data points so your mean might have some
a couple really big numbers that skew it
so that the average is much higher than
if you took those
outliers out where the median would
by separating the high from the low
might give you a much
lower number you might look at and say
oh that's that's odd why is the average
so much higher than the median
well it's because you have some outliers
or why is it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value
this is really interesting if you're
studying economics and how people are
doing you might find that the
most common income like in the u.s was
uh 1.24
000 a year where the average was
closer to 80 thousand and it's like wow
what a difference
well there's some people have a lot of
money and so that skews that
way up so the average person is not
making that kind of money
and then you look at the median income
and you're like well the median income
is
a little bit closer to the average so it
does create a very interesting
way of looking at the data again these
are all
central tendencies single numbers you
can look at for the whole spread of the
data
and we look at the measure of central
tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a students in a classroom so here we
have the mean
sum of the marks of the students total
number of students and as we talked
about the median
if we have 0 through 10 and we take half
the numbers and put them on one side of
the line
half the numbers on the other side of
the line we end up with 5 in the middle
and then the mode what mark was scored
by most of the students
in a test in a simple case where most
people scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out uh
not so easy when you have different
areas where like you have like the um
oh let's go back to economy a little bit
more difficult to calculate if you have
a large group that scores that makes 30
000
and a slightly bigger group that makes
26 000 so what do you put down for the
mode
uh certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh
range what's the difference between the
highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's uh we had everybody in the test
score between 60
and 100 somebody got 100 or maybe 60 to
90 percent it was so hard that a lot of
people could not get a hundred percent
um you have your inter-quartile range
quartiles divide a rank ordered data set
into
four equal parts very common thing to do
as part of all the basic packages
whether you're working
in data frames with pandas
whether you're working in scala whether
you're working in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your max
and then it'll have your interquartile
range how does it look like in each
quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set
is from the mean and therefore from
every other number in the set
so you have like how much turbulence is
going on in this data
and then the standard deviation it is to
measure the variance or the dispersion
of a set of values from the mean
and you'll usually see if i'm doing a
graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
graph
graph the standard deviation in the
error on the graph as a background so
you can see how far off it is
so standard deviations used a lot so
measurement of spread
marks of a student out of a hundred we
have here from 50 to 63 or 50 to
90. so the range maximum marks minimum
marks we have 90 to 45 and the spread of
that is 45
90 minus 45. and then we have the
interquartile range
using the same marks over there you can
see here where the median is
and then there's the first quarter the
second quarter
and the third quarter based on splitting
it apart by those values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean
uh so here's our our you know
calculating the average there
we end up at approximately 66 for the
average
and then we look at that the variance
once we know the means we can do
equals the marks minus the mean squared
why is it squared uh because one you
want to make sure
it's you don't have like if you if
you're putting all this stuff together
you end up with an
error as far as one's negative one's
positive one's a little higher one's a
little lower
uh so you always see the squared value
and over the total observations and so
the standard deviation
equals the square root of the variance
which is approximately 16.
and if you were looking at a predictable
model you would be looking at the
deviation based on the error how much
error does it have
that's again really important to know if
your if your prediction is predicting
something
what's a chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the tools as
far as some of the basics for doing your
statistics and what we're talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
python code
so you can get some little hands-on here
for that let's go in back into our
jupiter notebook in python
now almost all of this you can do in
numpy
last time we worked in numpy this time
we're going to go ahead and use pandas
and if you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns
let's just go ahead and do a print
df.head
and run that and you can see we have
the name jane michael william rosie
hanna sat on their salaries on here
and of course instead of having to do
all those hand calculations and add
everything together and divide by the
total
we can do something very simple on this
like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
i go and do this print
df pick our column salary because we
want to find the means of that
calorie we want to find the means of
that column
and we go and print this out and you can
see that the
average income on here is 71 000
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
there can be in some computation slight
differences but for the most part
the means is the average uh and then the
median
oops let's put a
median here do you have salary that way
it displays a little better
we can see the median is 54 000. so the
halfway mark
is significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here makes
189 000.
darn you rosie for throwing off our
numbers but that's something you'd want
to notice
this is this is the difference between
these is huge
and so is what is the meaning behind
that when you're studying a populace and
looking at
uh the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most uh
common income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at 50
000. so this is this is very telling
that most people are making fifty
thousand
the middle point is at fifty four
thousand so half the people are making
more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common
income is below the median then
there's a few there's a scale there's a
lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low
salaries in there and so this trend
which is very common
in statistics when you're analyzing the
economy in different people's
income is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also
very important when we're studying
statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was
you might start asking questions at that
point why aren't you talking about the
median income why aren't you talking
about the mode the most common income
what are you hiding uh and if you're
doing these analysis you should be
looking at these saying hey
why are these discrepancies why are
these so different and of course with
any
analysis it's important to find out the
minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply uh
dot min it'll pull up your minimum and
then
dot max pulls up the maximum pretty
straightforward on
as far as translating it and
knowing which you know what the lowest
value what your highest value is here
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode uh note that it puts mode zero like
i said there's a couple different ways
you can compute the mode
um although the standard one is pretty
good we can of course do the range
which is your max minus your min so now
we have a range of 149
000 between the upper end and the lower
end
and you might want to be looking at the
individual values on all of these
but it turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas and so in pandas we
can actually do df salary describe
and if we do this you can see we have
that there's seven
uh setups here's our mean our standard
deviation which we didn't compute yet
which would just be a dot std
and you gotta be a little careful
because when it computes it it looks for
axes and things like that
we have our minimum value and here's our
quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary
so these are the these are the basic
statistics you can pull them up and like
just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like
um in here i could actually go uh
count and run and now it just prints the
count
so because this is a dictionary you can
pull any one of these values out of here
it's kind of a quick and dirty way to
pull all the different information
and then split it up and depending on
what you need now if i just walked in
and gave you this information
in a meeting at some point you would
just kind of
fall asleep that's what i would do
anyway
so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here and we'll go ahead and
put it into a histogram
and plot that graph on it of the
salaries and let's just go ahead and put
that in here
so we do our matplot inline remember
that's a jupiter's notebook thing
a lot of the new version of the matplot
library does it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there import matplot library pipelot is
plt that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame i don't
i guess i really don't need to respell
the data frame
maybe we could just remind ourself
what's in it so we'll go ahead and just
print df that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title
salary distribution color gray
plot ax v line salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet line style dash this is
just all
making it pretty what color dash line
line width of 2 that kind of thing and
the median
and let's go ahead and run this just so
you can see what we're talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame print it out so you can see it
with the salaries
we'll look at the salary distribution
and just look at this
the way the salary is distributed
you have our in this case we did let's
see we had red for
the median we have violet
for our average or mean and you can just
see how it
really i mean here's our outlier here's
our person who makes a lot of money
here's the average and here's the median
and so as you look at this you can say
wow based on the average it really
doesn't tell you much about what people
are really taking home
all it does is tell you how much money
is in this you know
with the average salary is so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is
that it's very easy to plot um
an ax v line these are these up and down
lines for your markers
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated
keeping it simple is pretty
straightforward i look at this and i can
see we have a major outlier out here
we can definitely do a histogram and
stuff like that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words what you really want to make sure
you take away
is that we can do a basic describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe
because this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
mean so if you're doing a lot of
statistics
being able to doesn't have the print on
there so it's only going to print
the last one which happens to be the
mean you can very easily reference any
one of these
and then you can also if you're doing
something a little bit more complicated
and you don't need just the basics
you can come through and pull any one of
the individual
references from the from the pandas on
here
so now we've had a chance to describe
our data
let's get into inferential statistics
inferential statistics allows you to
make predictions or
inferences from data and you can see
here we have a nice little picture movie
ratings
and if we took this group of people and
said hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say
and then you ask just a random person
who comes out of the movie who hasn't
been in this study
you can infer that 55 chance of saying
liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 percent chance of can't say
so that's real basics of what we're
talking about is you're going to infer
that the next person is going to follow
these statistics
uh so let's look at point estimation uh
it is a process of finding an
approximate value for a population's
parameter
like mean or average from random samples
of the population
let's take an example of testing
vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out and make sure they're going to
work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population
so here's a protected there's our small
group up here where we've selected them
we run medical trials on them and then
the results work for the population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth and the very scary
coveted virus in the middle of one and
let's take a look at the applications of
inferential statistics
very central is what they call
hypotheses testing
and the confidence interval which go
with that
and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution
in central limit theorem hypothesis
testing hypothesis testing is used to
measure the plausibility of a hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now when we talk about theorems
theory hypothesis
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory is the same as hypothesis
where theorem is a scientific uh
statement that is something that has
been
proven although it is always up for
debate because in science we always want
to make sure things are up to debate
so hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven
gravity is a theory so if you want to
debate the theory of gravity
try jumping up and down if you want to
have a theory about
why the economy is collapsing in your
area
that is a philosophical debate very
important i've heard people mix those up
and it is a pet peeve of mine
when we talk about hypotheses testing
the steps involved in hypotheses testing
is first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test
and we make a decision and so when
you're talking about hypothesis you're
usually trying to disprove it
if you can't disprove it and it works
for all the facts
then you might call that a theorem at
some point
so in a use case let's consider an
example we have four students who are
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves
they did so by making four chits which
has their names on it and the name that
gets picked
up has to do the cleaning for that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on it
so here's our four people nick rob
emilia emilia
and summer now rick emilia and summer
are asking us to decide whether rob has
done some
mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day
third day and so on till 12 days the
probability of rob getting the job
decreases every day
ie his turn never comes up then
definitely he has done some mischief
while making the chits so the
probability of rob not doing work on day
one
is a three out of four there's a 0.75
chance that he didn't do work
2 days 3 4 times 3 4 equals 0.56
3 days you have 3 4 3 4 3 4 which equals
0.42
when you get to day 12 it's 0.032 which
is less than 0.05
remember this .05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he wasn't chosen for
12 consecutive days that's a very high
probability when
on day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies
we have null hypothesis a general
statement that states that there is no
relationship between
two measured phenomena or no association
among the groups
alternative hypothesis contrary to the
null hypothesis it states
whenever something is happening a new
theory is preferred instead of an old
one
and so the two hypotheses go hand in
hand uh
so your null this is always interesting
in when talking about data science and
the math behind it
it's about proving that the things have
no correlation
null hypothesis says these two have zero
relation to each other
where the alternative hypothesis says
hey we found a relation this is what it
is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypothesis of a study
question is true and the t-value
it is simply the calculated difference
represented in units of standard error
the greater the magnitude of t the
greater the evidence against the null
hypothesis
and you can look at the t values being
specific to the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value
and you're looking for what they call
the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper
let's assume that a new drug is
developed with the goal of lowering the
blood pressure
more than the existing drug and this is
a good one because
the null value here isn't that you don't
have any drug the null value here is
that it's better than the existing drug
the new drug doesn't lower the blood
pressure more than the existing drug
now if we get that that says our null
hypothesis is correct there is no
correlation
and the new drug is not doing its job
the alternative hypothesis
the new drug does significantly lower
the blood pressure more than the
existing
drug yay we got a new drug out there
and that's our alternative hypothesis or
the h1 or ha
and we look at the p value results from
the evidence like medical trial showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for a 0.05 or
5 percent
and the t value comparing all the
positive test results and finding means
of different samples in order to test
hypothesis
so this is specific to the test how what
percentage of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure our true values of
observations lie
in let's say you asked a dog owner
around you and asked them
how many cans of food do you buy for
your
per year for your dog through
calculations you got to know that the
on an average around 95 percent of the
people bought around 200 to 300 cans of
food
hence we can say that we have a
confidence interval of 2
300 where 95 percent of our values lie
in that spring data spread and this the
graph
really helps a lot so you can start
seeing what you're looking at here where
you have the 95 percent
you have your peak in this case it's a
normal distribution so you have a nice
bell curve equal on both sides it's not
asymmetrical
and 95 of all the values lie within a
very small range
and then you have your outliers the 2.5
percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis uh we're
going to move into
probability so you have your hypothesis
once you've generated your hypothesis we
want to know the probability of
something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur
any event can be predicted with total
certainty
and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
so any event cannot be predicted with
total certainty can only be predicted as
a likelihood of its occurrence
score prediction how good you're going
to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics and chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh i think we calculated as under
one in trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability
that we don't see them so we talk about
random variable
a random variable is a variable whose
possible values are numerical outcomes
of a random phenomena
so we have the coin tossed how many
heads will occur in the series of 20
coin flips
probably you know the on average they're
10 but you really
can't know because it's very random how
many times a red ball is picked from a
bag of balls if there's equal number of
red balls and blue balls and green balls
in there how many times the sum of
digits on two dice
results are five each um
so you know there's how often you're
going to roll two fives on your pair of
dice
so in a use case let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y
you can take values two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice for roll five let's go ahead
and look at
total sum of five and you have in as far
as your random variables you can have a
one four equals five four one two three
three two so four of those rolls
can be four if you look at all the
different options you have four of those
random rolls can be
a five and if we look at the total
number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh
you can see that we have four out of 36
chance every time you roll the dice
that you're gonna roll a total of five
you can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means
but you could think of that at what
point if someone never rolls a five or
they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating we'll look a little closer at
the math behind that
but let's just consider this is one of
the cases is rolling two dice and
gambling
there's also binomial distribution is
the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial
so passing or failing an exam winning or
losing a game
and getting either head or tails so if
you ever see binomial distribution it's
based on
a true false kind of setup you win or
lose
let's consider a use case and let's
consider the game of football between
two clubs barcelona and dortmund
the teams will have to play a total of
four matches and we have to find out
the chances of barcelona winning the
series so
we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75 percent or 0.75
that means that each game they have a 75
chance that they're going to win that
game
and losing chances are 25 or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals 1. so that
accounts for 100
of the game probability for getting k
wins in
in matches is calculated and we
we're talking like so if you have five
games and you want to know if i play
um how many wins in those five games
should i get what's a percentage on
those
and the probability for getting k wins
and
in matches is calculated by p x equals k
equals n c k p to the k q to the
n minus k here p is the probability of
success
and q is the probability of failure and
so we can do total games of
n equals five where k equals zero one
two three four five
p which is the chance of winning is
point seven five
q the chance of losing equals one minus
p
which equals 1 minus 0.075 which equals
0.25
the probability that barcelona will lose
all of the matches can then
just plug in the numbers and we end up
with a .00097
so very small chance they're going to
lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches
probability that barcelona will win at
least two matches
is .0878 and of course we can go on to
the probability that barcelona will win
three matches
the 0.26 and of course four matches
and so on and it's always nice to take
this information
um and let's find the accumulated
discrete probabilities for each of the
outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches
x equals three x equals four x equals
five
and we end up with the p equals 0.264
plus 0.395
plus 237 which equals 0.89
in reality the probability of barcelona
winning the series is much higher than
0.75
and it's always nice to put out a nice
graph so you can actually see the number
of wins to the probability
and how that pans out with our binomial
case
continuing in our important terminology
location
the location of the center of the graph
depends on the mean
value and this is some very important
things
so much of the data we look at and when
you start looking at probabilities
almost always has a normalized look
like the graph in the middle but you do
have
left skewed where the data is skewed off
to the left and you have more stuff
happening off to the left and you have
right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed
it's really important to take a closer
look at that mostly you end up with a
normalized set of data but you got to
also be aware that sometimes it's a
skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out
and if the standard deviation is small
then most of your data is going to hit
right there in the middle you can have a
nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that
fits certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so
if you have a really high standard
deviation
if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target and set to
become a millionaire
which leads us to the z-score z-score
tells you how far from
the mean a data point is it is measured
in terms of standard deviations from the
mean
around 68 percent of the results are
found between one standard deviation
around 95 percent of the results are
found between two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there
we have a mu minus two sigma
mu is just a quick way it's a kind of
funky u
it just means the mean uh and then the
sigma is the standard deviation and
that's the
o with the little arrow off to the right
or the little
wagy tail going up the o with it with
the line on it
so mu minus 2 sigma is your
95 percent of the results are found
between two standard deviations
central limit theorem this goes back to
the skew if you remember we were looking
at the skew values on this previous
slide have left skewed normalized and
right skewed
when we're talking about it being skewed
or not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed
if you take large random samples from
the population with the mean
mu and the standard deviation sigma
with replacement and you can see here
of course we have our mu minus two sigma
and the spread down here
the mean the median and the mode and so
when you're talking about very large
populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value
if you do that's a flag that something's
wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from and
the math behind it
and if you're going to do all this we
got to jump into conditional
probability the conditional probability
of an event a
is the probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event b has
already occurred
and you'll see this as bayes theorem
b-a-y-e-s
base and this is red
i mean you have these funky looking
little p brackets a b
this is the probability of a being true
while
b is already true and you have the
probability of b
being true when a is already true so p b
of a
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of b
being true and we talk about bayes
theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important
formula and it's really it's not if you
actually do the math you could just kind
of do
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math
but it works with probabilities which
makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine
different studies going on in different
areas
different people have done the studies
they brought them together
if we look at today's covet virus the
virus spread
certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the u.s
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is
very powerful and it really has to do
with the data collection part of the
math and data science
and understanding where your data is
coming from and how you're going to
combine
different studies in different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease
due to smoking and this is kind of
interesting the way they word this
let's say that according to medical
report provided by the hospital
states that around 10 percent of all
patients
they treated suffered lung disease
so we have kind of a generic medical
report
they further found out by a survey that
15
of the patients that visit them smoke
so we have 10 percent that are lung
disease and
15 of the patients smoke and finally
5 of the people continued smoke even
when they had
lung disease not the brightest choice
but you know it is an addiction so it
can be really difficult to kick and so
we can look at the
probability of a uh prior probability of
10
people having lung disease and then
probability b
probability that a patient smokes is 15
percent
uh and the probability of b
if b then a the probability of a patient
smokes even though they have
lung disease is five percent and
probability of a is b
probability that the patient will have
lung disease if they smoke
and then when you put the formulas
together you get a nice solution here
you get
the probability of a of b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a
3.33 percent chance hence there is a
3.33
chance that a person who smokes will get
a lung disease
so we're going to pull up a little
python code
i'm always my favorite roll up the
sleeves keep in mind
we're going to be doing this um kind of
like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set
so we're going to create a set with
curly braces this means that our set has
only unique values so you have a list
uh you have your tuples which can never
change
and then you have um in this case the
the set
so four seven you can't create a four
seven comma four it'll delete the four
out so it's only unique values and if
you use dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary
we have a value and that value is
assigned to or that
key is assigned to a value so you could
have a key value set up as a dictionary
so it's like a dictionary without the
value it's just the keys and they all
have to be unique
and if we run this we have a set of four
seven we can also
take a list a regular setup and i'm
going to go ahead and just throw in
another number in here four
and run it and you can see here if i
take my list one two three four
four and i convert it to a set
and here it is my set from list equals
set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set
three is in the set and then if you do
three in my set
that's going to be a logic function uh
and one in my set
six is not in the set and so forth if we
run this
we get three is in the set true one is
in the set false because 357 is another
one
six is in the set six is not in the set
so not in my set you can also use this
with the list
we could have just used three five seven
and it would have
the same response on there is three and
usually you do if three is in but three
in my set is still works on
just a regular list and we'll go ahead
and do a little iteration
we're going to do kind of the dice one
remember
one two three four five six and so we're
going to bring in the
iteration tool and import product as
product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a
and it's going to be a set of values
they can only have one
value for each one that's why they put
it in a set and if you remember from
range it is up to seven so this is gonna
be one
two three four five six it will not
include the seven
and the same thing for our dice b
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product of a
and b so what's a plus b
if we go ahead and run this it'll print
that out and you'll see
in this case when they say product
because it's an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two so we've now created a tuple of
all possible outcomes of the dice
where dice a is one two three one to six
and dice b
is one to six and you can see one to one
one to two one to three and so forth
you remember we had a slide on this
earlier where we talked about
the different all the different outcomes
of a dice we can play around with this a
little bit
uh we can do in dice equals two divi
dice faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space
where we have a set which is the product
of the dice faces
repeat equals indice and we'll go ahead
and just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here
and print them all out like we had
before
we can just go through for outcome and
event space outcome
and equals so the event space
is creating a sequence and as you can
see here when we print it out
it stacks them versus going through and
putting them in a nice line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print
since we have the end printing with a
comma that just means
it's just going to it's not going to hit
the return going down to the next line
and we'll go ahead and do the length
of our event space uh there'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if i get carried away with
my typing of length
we'll print it twice and it'll give me
an error so we have 36
different possible variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like
what about the multiple of 3 what if we
want to have
the probability of the multiple of 3 in
our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space
of x y equals outcome if
x plus y remainder 3 so we're going to
divide by 3 and look at the remainder
and it equals zero
then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set
not necessary because we know it's not
going to be repeating itself but just in
case we'll go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of three one plus two is three
five plus four
is nine which divided by three is three
and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length of our
f outcome so we can see what that looks
like
there we go and of course i did forget
to add the print in the middle because
we're looping through and putting an end
on the
on the setup on there so we're going to
put the print in there and if i run this
you can see
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of
3 and we can easily conv
compute the probability of this by
simply taking the length
of our favorable outcome over the length
of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there probability
last line so we just type it in we end
up with the 0.3333
chance that's roughly a third
and we want to make this look nice so
let's go ahead and put in another line
there the probability of getting the sum
which is a multiple of 3
is 0.3333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it
uh you can see we just have a huge
amount of choices
so just goes on and on down here and we
can look at
the length of the event space
and we have over 7 76
choices that's a lot of choices and if
we want to ask the question like we did
above
uh what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of 5 but
not a multiple of 3. we can go through
all of these different options and then
you can see here
d1 d2 d3 d4 d5 equals the outcome
and if you add these all together and
the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero
but the remainder is also of a division
by three is not equal to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not
we can just depend that on here and then
we can look at that
uh favorable outcome we'll go ahead and
set that and we'll just
take a look at this what's our length of
our
favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
776
and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll
a multiple of 5 when you add them
together
but not a multiple of 3. and so we're
just going to divide those two numbers
and you can see here we get
0.11625 or 11.62 percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not
really complicated math right here on
probabilities
it's just how many options do you have
and how many of those are you possibly
going to be able to
come up with with the solution you're
looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data
for which the true values are known and
so you'll see on the left we have the
predicted
and the actual and we have a negative uh
false negative positive true positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative
and you can think of this as your
predicted
model what does that mean that means if
you divided your data
and you used two-third of it to create
the model you might then test it against
an actual case for the last third to see
how well it comes out how many times was
it
true positive versus false positive you
give a false positive response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal
you don't want to give a false positive
so you might adjust your model
accordingly so you don't have a false
positive say with a covavirus test
it'd be better to have a false negative
and they go back and get retested
than to have 30 false positives where
then the test is pretty much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example
where a cancer prediction model is put
to the test for its accuracy
and precision actual result of a
person's medical report is compared
with the prediction made by the machine
learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a
false positive i mean a false negative
in other words you don't want to have it
tell you that you don't have cancer when
you do
so that would be something you'd really
be looking for in this particular domain
you don't want a false negative and this
is again
you know you've created a model you have
hundreds of people or thousands of
pieces of data that come in there's a
real famous case study where they have
the
imagery and all the measurements they
take and there's about 36 different
measurements they take and then if you
run the
a basic model you want to know just how
accurate it is how many
negative results do you have that are
either telling people they have cancer
that don't or telling people that don't
have cancer that they do
and then we can take these numbers and
we can feed them into our accuracy our
precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your total um true where you
got the right results you add them
together the true positive the two
negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate
versus what were wrong we talked about
precision
is a metric to measure how many of the
correctly predicted cases are actually
turned out to be
positive so we have a precision
on true positive again if you're talking
about
like uh covet testing with the viruses
you really want this to be a high number
you want this
true that to be the center point where
you might have the opposite if you're
dealing with
cancer where you want no false negatives
so this is your metric on here precision
is your test positive
true positive plus false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model
so test positive is the test positive
plus the
false negative on there and we'll want
to go ahead and do a
demo on the naive bayes classifier
before i get
too far into a naive bayes classifier
because we're going to pull it from the
sk
learn or the scikit
let's go ahead kind of an interesting
page here for classifiers
when you go into the sk learn kit
there's a lot of ways to do
classification and i'll just zoom up in
here so you can
see some of the titles there's
everything from the nearest neighbor
linear but we're going to be focusing on
the naive bayes
over here and this is just a sample
data set that they put together and you
can see how
some of these have a very different
output the naive bayes remember is set
up as
probably the most simplified calculator
or
set of predictions out there and so what
we've been talking about with the true
false and stuff like that where there's
a uh
and then a belief that there is a
independent assumption between the
features where the features are very
assumed to have some kind of connection
then we can go ahead and use that for
the prediction
and so that's what we're using is a
naive bayes classifier
versus many of the other classifiers
that are out there
for this we're going to use uh the
social network
ads it's a little data set on here and
let me go and just open that up the file
here we go it has user id gender age
estimated salary purchased and so we
have
you can see the user id mail 19
estimated salary 19 000 and purchased
zero so it's either going to make a
purchase or not
so look at that last one 0 1 we should
be thinking of binomials we should be
thinking of
a simple naive bayes classifier kind of
setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as
np nice to have a good visual of our
data so we'll put in our matplot library
here's our pandas our data frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data set's
going to be
we're going to read it from the social
network ads.csv
then we're going to print the head just
so you can see it again even though i
showed you it in the file
and x equals the data set i location
2 3 values and y is going to be the four
column four let me just run this it's a
little easier to go over that
you can see right here we're going to be
looking at 0 1
2 as age and estimated salary so
2 and that's what i location just means
that we're looking at the number versus
a regular location a regular location
you'd actually say
age and estimated salary and then column
4 is did they make a purchase
they purchased something so those are
the three columns we're going to be
looking at when we do this
and we've gone ahead and imported these
and imported the data so now our data
set is all set with this information in
it and we'll need to go ahead and split
the data up
so we need our from the sk learn model
selection
we can import train test split
this does a nice job we can set the
random state so it randomly picks the
data
and we're just going to take 25 percent
of it's going to go into the test
our x test and our y test and the 75
will go to x train and y train that way
once we
create our model we can then have data
to see just how accurate
or how well it has performed with our
prediction
the next step in pre-processing our data
is to go ahead and do feature scaling
now a lot of this to start to look
familiar if you've done a number of the
other
modules and setup you should start
noticing that we
bring in our data we take a look at what
we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
in this case we're going to go ahead and
scale it scale it means we're putting it
between a value
of minus one and one uh or some place in
the
middle ground there this way if you have
any huge set
you don't have this huge set up if we go
back up to here where salary
the salary is 20 000 versus
age 35. well there's a good chance with
a lot of the back end math
that 20 000 will skew the results and
the estimated salary will have a higher
impact than the
age instead of balancing them out and
letting the calculations weigh them
properly
and finally we get to actually create
our
naive bayes model
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the gaussian naive bayes
and the gaussian is is the most basic
one
that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the sk
learn kit they have a number of
different ones you can pull in there
there's a
bernoulli i've never used that one
categorical
complement and here's our gaussian so
there's a number of different options
you can look at
gaussian when you come to the naive
bayes is the most commonly used
so we're talking about the naive bayes
that's usually what people are talking
about when they
when they're pulling this in and one of
the nice things about the gaussian if
you go to their website
to sk learn the naive bayes gaussian
there's a lot of cool features one of
them is you can do partial fit on here
that means if you have a huge amount of
data you don't have to process it all to
want you
once you can batch it into the
gaussian nb model and there's many other
different things you can do with it
as far as fitting the data and how you
manipulate it
we're just doing the basics so we're
going to go ahead and create our
classifier
we're going to equal the gaussian in b
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data
and our training solution so x train y
train
and we'll go ahead and run this and it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y
predict equals the classifier.predict x
test so here we fit the data and now
we're going to go ahead and predict
and now we get to our confusion matrix
so from the sk learn matrix metrics you
can import your confusion matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you
and then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the y
test and the y predict so we have our
actual
and we have our predicted value and
you can see from here this is the chart
we looked at here's predicted so
true positive false positive false
negative
true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65
3 7 25
and in this particular prediction we had
65
or predicted the truth as far as a
purchase they're going to make a
purchase
and we guessed three wrong and then we
had
25 we predicted would not purchase and
seven of them
did so there's our our confusion matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting
you would start to hear some snoozing if
they were looking at the numbers and you
say hey here's my confusion
matrix so let's go ahead and visualize
the results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
and this is actually my machine is going
to throw an error because
this is being because of the way the
setup is
i have a newer version on here than when
they put together the demo
and we need our x set and our y set
which is our x train and y train
and then we'll create our x1 x2 and
we'll put that into a grid
and we set our xset minimum stop and our
at max stop and if you come all the way
over here we're going to step
.01 this is going to give us a nice line
uh is what that's doing and we're going
to plot the contour
plot the x limit plot the y limit and
put the scatter plot in there let's go
ahead and run this
to be honest when i'm doing these graphs
there's so many different ways to do
that
there's so many different ways to put
this code together to show you what
we're doing
it's a lot easier to pull up the graph
and then go back
up and explain it so the first thing we
want to note here when we're looking at
the data
is this is the training set and so we
have those who didn't make a purchase
we've drawn a nice area for that that's
defined by the naive bayes setup
and then we have those who did make a
purchase the green and you can see that
some of the green drops fall into the
red area and some of the red dots fall
into the green
so even our training set isn't going to
be a hundred percent
uh we couldn't do that and so we're
looking at our different
data coming down uh we can kind of
arrange our x1 x2 so we have a nice plot
going on and we're going to create the
contour that's that nice line that's
drawing down the middle on here with the
red green
that's where that's what this is doing
right here with the reshape and notice
that we had to
do the dot t if you remember from numpy
um if you did the numpy module
you end up with pairs you know x uh x1
x2
x1 x2 next row and so forth
you have to flip it so it's all one row
you have all your x1s and all your x2s
so this is what we're kind of looking
for right here on this setup
uh and then the scatter plot is of
course
your scattered data across there we're
just going through all the points that
puts these nice little dots on to
our setup on here and we have our
estimated salary and our
h and then of course the dots are did
they make a purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
x set y set equals x train y train
which seems kind of a little weird to do
this is because this is probably
originally a definition
so it was its own module that could be
called over and over again
and which is really a good way to do it
because the next thing we're going to
want to do is do the exact same
thing but we're going to visualize the
test set results
that way we can see what happened with
our test group our 25 percent
and you can see down here we have the
test set
and it if you look at the two graphs
next to each other this one obviously
has
75 percent of the data so it's going to
show a lot more
this is only 25 of the data you can see
that there's a number that are kind of
on the edge as to whether they could
guess by age and
income they're going to make a purchase
or not but that said
it still is pretty clear it's pretty
good as far as how much the estimate is
and how good it does
now graphs are really effective
for showing people what's going on but
you also need to have the numbers
and so we're going to do from sklearn
we're going to import metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification port from the y
test and the y predict
and you can see here we have precision
uh precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an f1 score and a support
and we have our precision the recall on
getting it right
and then we can do our accuracy the
macro average and the weighted average
so you can see it pulls in pretty good
as far as
how accurate it is you could say it's
going to be about 90
is going to guess correctly um that it
that they're not going to purchase
and we had an 89 chance that they are
going to purchase
um and then the other numbers as you get
down have a little bit different meaning
but it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy
and here's our micro average and the
weighted average and everything else you
might need
and if you forgot the exact definition
of accuracy
it is the true positive true negative
over all
of the different setups precision is
your true
positive overall positives true and
false
and recall is a true positive over true
positive plus
false negative and we can just real
quick flip back there
so you can see those numbers on here uh
here's our precision
here's our recall and here's our
accuracy on this
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what
happens when you have multiple inputs so
in multiple linear regression
we have well we'll start with the simple
linear regression where we had
y equals m plus x plus c and we're
trying to find the value of y
now with multiple linear regression we
have multiple variables coming in
so instead of having just x we have x1
x2 x3 and instead of having just
one slope each variable has its own
slope attached to it
as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression
you basically take your single linear
regression and you spread it out
so you have y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth
and then you add your coefficient on
there implementation of linear
regression now we get into my favorite
part
let's understand how multiple linear
regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before
we were looking at a company and just
based on its rnd
trying to figure out its profit we're
going to start looking at the
expenditure of the company we're going
to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r
d we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs
marketing costs and so on and from there
we're going to see if we can figure out
what the profit of that company is going
to be
to start our coding we're going to begin
by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression
we're going to take a look at the data
to see what we're playing with then
we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model
and then from there we'll go ahead and
solve it and just see how
valid our solution is so let's start
with importing the basic libraries
now i'm going to be doing this in
anaconda jupiter notebook a very popular
ide
i enjoy it's such a visual to look at
and so easy to use
um just any id for python will work just
fine for this
so break out your favorite python ide so
here we are in our jupiter notebook
let me go ahead and paste our first
piece of code in there and let's walk
through what libraries we're importing
first we're going to import numpy as np
and then i want you to skip one line and
look at import pandas as
pd these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np
and you have to almost have that for
your sk learn toolbox you always import
that right off the beginning
pandas although you don't have to have
it for your sklearn libraries it does
such a wonderful job of importing data
setting it up into a data frame so we
can manipulate it rather easily and it
has a lot of tools also in addition to
that so we usually like to use the
pandas when we can and i'll show you
what that looks like
the other three lines are for us to get
a visual of this data and take a look at
it
so we're going to import
matplotlibrary.pipelot as
plt and then seaborn as sns
seaborn works with the matplot library
so you have to always import matplot
library and then seaborn sits on top of
it
and we'll take a look at what that looks
like you could use any of your own
plotting libraries you want there's all
kinds of ways to look at the data
these are just very common ones and the
seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber signed
matplot library inline that is only
because i'm doing an inline ide
my interface in the anaconda jupiter
notebook
requires i put that in there or you're
not going to see the graph when it comes
up
let's go ahead and run this it's not
going to be that interesting so we're
just setting up variables
in fact it's not going to do anything
that we can see but it is importing
these different
libraries and setup the next step is
load the data set and extract
independent and dependent variables now
here in the slide you'll see companies
equals pd.read csv and it has a long
line there with the file at the end 1000
companies.csv
you're going to have to change this to
fit whatever setup you have
and the file itself you can request just
go down to the commentary below this
video
and put a note in there and simply learn
we'll try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself
so we're going to add this code in here
and we're going to see that i have
companies equals pd.reader underscore
csv
and i've changed this path to match my
computer c colon slash simply learn
slash 1000 underscore companies
companies.csv
and then below there we're going to set
the x equals to companies
under the i location and because this is
companies as a pd data set
i can use this nice notation that says
take every row
that's what the colon the first colon is
comma except for the last column that's
what the second part is where we have a
colon minus one
and we want the values set into there so
x is no longer
a data set a pandas data set but we can
easily extract the data from our pandas
data set with this notation and then
y we're going to set equal to the last
row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that
and we're going to look at the companies
dot head which lists the first five rows
of data and i'll open up the file
in just a second so you can see where
that's coming from but let's look at the
data in here
as far as the way the pandas sees it
when i hit run
you'll see it breaks it out into a nice
setup this is what pandas one of the
things pandas is really good about is it
looks just like an excel spreadsheet
you have your rows and remember when
we're programming we always start with
zero we don't start with one
so it shows the first five rows zero one
two three four and then it shows your
different columns
r and d spend administration marketing
spend
state profit it even notes that the top
are column names it was never told that
but pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows
why don't we go ahead and open this file
up in a csv so you can actually see the
raw data so
here i've opened it up as a text editor
and you can see at the top we have rnd
spend comma administration comma
marketing spin comma state comma profit
carrier's return i don't know about you
but i'd go crazy trying to read files
like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that
top part the first five row now as nice
as this format
is where i can see the data to me it
doesn't mean a whole lot
maybe you're an expert in business and
investments and you understand
what three hundred 165 nine dollars and
twenty cents
compared to the administration cost of a
hundred and thirty six thousand eight
hundred ninety seven dollars and eighty
cents so on so on
helps to create the profit of a hundred
ninety two thousand two hundred sixty
one
and eighty three cents that makes no
sense to me whatsoever
no pun intended so let's flip back here
and take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means
so at this point we're going to use a
single line of code to get a lot of
information
so we can see where we're going with
this let's go ahead and paste that into
our notebook and see what we got going
and so we have the visualization
and again we're using sns which is
pandas
as you can see we imported the map plot
library dot pi plot as plt
which then the seaborn uses and we
imported the seaborn as sns
and then that final line of code helps
us show this
in our inline coding without this it
wouldn't display and you could display
it to a file in other means and that's
the matplot library in line with the
amber sign at the beginning so here we
come down to the single line of code
seaborn is great because it actually
recognizes the panda data frame
so i can just take the companies dot
core
for coordinates and i can put that right
into the seaborn
and when we run this we get this
beautiful plot
and let's just take a look at what this
plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one
we have the columns and the rows we have
r and d
spending we have administration we have
marketing spending and profit
and if you cross index any two of these
since we're interested in profit if you
cross index profit with profit
is going to show up if you look at the
scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data
they have an exact correspondence so r d
spending is going to be the same as r d
spending and the same thing with
administration costs so right down the
middle
you get this dark row or dark um
diagonal row
that shows that this is the highest
corresponding data that's exactly the
same
and as it becomes lighter there's less
connections between the data
so we can see with profit obviously
profit is the same as profit
and next it has a very high correlation
with r d spending which we looked at
earlier
and it has a slightly less connection to
marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice
look at the data let's go ahead and dig
in and create some actual useful
linear regression models so that we can
predict values and have
a better profit now that we've taken a
look at the visualization of this data
we're going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values
so let's see what that looks like we're
going to set up our linear regression
model
in two steps the first one is we need to
prepare
some of our data so it fits correctly
and let's go ahead and paste this code
into our jupyter notebook
and what we're bringing in is we're
going to bring in the sklearn
pre-processing where we're going to
import the label encoder
and the one hot encoder to use the label
encoder we're going to create a variable
called label encoder and set it equal to
capital l
label capital e encoder this creates a
class that we can reuse
for transferring the labels back and
forth now about now you should ask what
labels are we talking about
let's go take a look at the data we
processed before and see what i'm
talking about here
if you remember when we did the
companies dot head and we printed the
top
five rows of data we have our columns
going across
we have column 0 which is r and d
spending
column 1 which is administration column
2 which is marketing spending
and column 3 is state and you'll see
under state we have new york california
florida now to do a linear regression
model it doesn't know how to process
new york it knows how to process a
number so the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to change that new
york california and florida
and we're going to change those to
numbers that's what this line of code
does here
x equals and then it has the colon comma
3
in brackets the first part the colon
comma means that we're going to look at
all the different rows so we're going to
keep them all together but the only row
we're going to edit is the third row
and in there we're going to take the
label coder and we're going to fit and
transform
the x also the third row so we're going
to take that third row we're going to
set it equal to a transformation
and that transformation basically tells
it that instead of having
a new york it has a zero or one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals
one hot inc or categorical features
equals three
and then we take the x and we go ahead
and do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation
preps our data force so it's completely
set the way we need it as just a row of
numbers
even though it's not in here let's go
ahead and print x
and just take a look what this data is
doing you'll see you have an array of
arrays
and then each array is a row of numbers
and if i go ahead and just do row 0
you'll see i have a nice organized row
of numbers that the computer now
understands
we'll go ahead and take this out there
because it doesn't mean a whole lot to
us it's just a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important
why because the computer has
automatically transformed
our header into the setup and it's
automatically transformed
all these different variables so when we
did the encoder
the encoder created two columns
and what we need to do is just have the
one because it has both the variable and
the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this
in here and we have x equals x colon
comma
one colon all this is doing is removing
that one extra
column we put in there when we did our
one hot encoder and our label encoding
let's go ahead and run that and now we
get to create our linear regression
model
and let's see what that looks like here
and we're going to do that in two steps
the first step is going to be in
splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set
and we have a testing set that's very
important otherwise we'd be very
unethical without testing it to see how
good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model
and train it and set it up let's go
ahead and paste this next piece of code
in here
and i'll go ahead and shrink it down a
size or two so it all fits on one line
so from the sklearn module selection
we're going to import train test split
and you'll see that we've created
four completely different variables we
have capital x train
capital x test smaller case y train
smaller case y test that is the standard
way that they usually reference these
when we're doing different
models you usually see that a capital x
and you see the train and the test and
the lowercase y
what this is is x is our data going in
that's our rnd spin our administration
our marketing
and then y which we're training is the
answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity so that's what we're
going to shoot for in this
tutorial the next part train test split
we take
x and we take y we've already created
those
x has the columns with the data in it
and y
has a column with profit in it and then
we're going to set the test size
equals 0.2 that basically means 20
percent
so 20 of the rows are going to be tested
we're going to put them off to the side
so since we're using a thousand lines of
data that means that
200 of those lines we're going to hold
off to the side to test for later
and then the random state equals zero
we're going to randomize
which ones it picks to hold off to the
side we'll go ahead and run this
it's not overly exciting so setting up
our variables but the next step is the
next step we actually create our linear
regression model
now that we got to the linear regression
model we get that next piece of the
puzzle
let's go ahead and put that code in
there and walk through it so here we go
we're going to paste it in there and
let's go ahead and
since this is a shorter line of code
let's zoom up there so we can get a good
look
and we have from the sklearn dot linear
underscore model we're going to import
linear regression now i don't know if
you recall from earlier when we were
doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
or we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization
and then we also looked at setting it up
with the different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to
multiple linear regression where we're
adding all those formulas together
all of that is wrapped up in this one
section so what's going on here is i'm
going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually
and then we do the regressor dot fit in
this case we do
x train and y train because we're using
the training data
x being the data in and y being profit
what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line
we've created the whole linear
regression model and we fit the data to
the linear regression model and you can
see that when i run the regressor
it gives an output linear regression it
says copy x equals true
fit intercept equals true in jobs equal
one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model
now that we've created our linear
regression model let's go ahead and use
it
and if you remember we kept a bunch of
data aside
so we're going to do a y predict
variable and we're going to put in the x
test and let's see what that looks like
scroll up a little bit
paste that in here predicting the test
set results
so here we have y predict equals
regressor dot predict
x test going in and this gives us y
predict
now because i'm in jupiter inline i can
just put the variable up there
and when i hit the run button it'll
print that array out
i could have just as easily done print
why predict
so if you're in a different ide that's
not an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict
and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side
it's going to produce 200 answers this
is what it says the profit are for those
200 predictions
but let's don't stop there let's keep
going and take a couple look we're going
to take just a short
detail here and calculating the
coefficients and the intercepts
this gives us a quick flash at what's
going on behind the line
we're going to take a short detour here
and we're going to be calculating the
coefficient
and intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us
we can simply just print regressor dot
coefficient underscore
when i run this you'll see our
coefficients here and if we can do the
regressor coefficient
we can also do the regressor intercept
and let's run that and take a look at
that this all came from the multiple
regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from
you can see the formula down here where
y equals m1 times x1
plus m2 times x2 and so on and so on
plus c
the coefficient so these variables fit
right into this formula
y equals slope 1 times column 1 variable
plus slope 2 times column 2 variable all
the way to the
m into the n and x to the n plus c the
coefficient
or in this case you have minus 8.89
to the power of 2 etc etc times the
first column and the second column and
the third column
and then our intercept is the minus one
zero three zero zero nine point
boy it gets kind of complicated when you
look at it this is why we don't do this
by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate
now i told you that was a short detour
and we're coming towards the end of our
script
as you remember from the beginning i
said if we're going to divide this
information we have to make sure it's a
valid model that this model works and
understand how good it works
so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use
to predict how good our prediction is
and let's take a look what that looks
like in code
and so we're going to use this from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import
r2 score that's the r squared value
we're looking at the
error so in the r2 score we take our y
test versus our y predict y
test is the actual values we're testing
that was the one that was given to us
that we know are true
the y predict of those 200 values is
what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage
so it's not saying it's 93 percent
correct but you do
want that in the upper 90s oh and higher
shows that this is a very valid
prediction based on the r2 score
and if r squared value of 0.91 or 9 2 as
we got on our model
remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good
model which means success yay we
successfully trained our model with
certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression
let's take an example and see how we can
apply logistic regression to
predict the number that is shown in the
image so this is
actually a live demo i will take you
into jupiter notebook
and show the code but before that let me
take you through a couple of slides to
explain
what we are trying to do so let's say
you have an eight by eight image
and there the image has a number one two
three four
and you need to train your model to
predict what this number
is so how do we do this so the first
thing
is obviously in any machine learning
process you train your model
so in this case we are using logistic
regression so
and then we provide a training set to
train the model and then we
test how accurate our model is with the
test data which means that like any
machine learning
process we split our initial data into
two parts training set and test set with
the training set we train our model and
then with the test set we test the model
then we get
good accuracy and then we use it for for
inference
right so that is typical methodology of
training testing and then deploying of
machine learning models
so let's take a look at the code and see
what we are doing so i will not go line
by line but just take you through some
of the blocks so first thing we do
is import all the libraries and then we
basically take a look at the
images and see what is the total number
of images we can
display using matplotlib some of the
images are a sample of these images
and then we split the data into training
and test as i mentioned earlier
and we can do some exploratory analysis
and then we build our model we train our
model with the training set
and then we test it with our test set
and
find out how accurate our model is using
the confusion matrix the heat map and
use heat map for visualizing this
and i will show you in the code what
exactly
is the confusion matrix and how it can
be used for
finding the accuracy in our example we
go
we get an accuracy of about 0.94 which
is pretty good or 94 percent which is
pretty good
all right so what is the confusion
matrix this is an example of a confusion
matrix
and this is used for identifying the
accuracy of
a classification model or like a
logistic regression model
so the most important part in a
confusion matrix
is that first of all this as you can see
this is a matrix and the size of the
matrix depends on how many outputs
we are expecting right so the most
important part here is that
the model will be most accurate when we
have the maximum
numbers in its diagonal like in this
case that's why it has almost 93 94
percent because
the diagonals should have the maximum
numbers
and the others other than diagonals the
cells other than the diagonal should
have
very few numbers so here that's what is
happening so there is a 2 here there are
there is a 1 here but most of them
are along the diagonal this what does
this mean
this means that the number that has been
fed is 0 and the number that has been
detected
is also zero so the predicted value and
the actual value are the same so
along the diagonals that is true which
means that
let's let's take this diagonal right if
the maximum number is here that means
that like here in this case it is 34
which means that 34 of the images that
have been fed or rather actually there
are two misclassifications in there so
36 images have been fed which have
number four
and out of which 34 have been predicted
correctly as number four
and one has been predicted as number
eight
and another one has been predicted as
number nine so these are two
misclassifications
okay so that is the meaning of saying
that the maximum number should be in the
diagonal so if you have all of them so
for an ideal
model which has let's say 100 accuracy
everything will be only in the diagonal
there will be no numbers other than zero
in all other cells so that is like a
hundred percent
accurate model okay so that's uh just of
how to use this
matrix uh how to use this uh confusion
matrix i know the name
uh is a little funny sounding confusion
matrix but
actually it is not very confusing it's
very straightforward so you are just
plotting
what has been predicted and what is the
labeled information or what is the
actual data
that's also known as the ground truth
sometimes okay these are some fancy
terms that are used so predicted label
and the actual name that's all it is
okay yeah so we are showing a little bit
more
information here so 38 have been
predicted and here you will see that
all of them have been predicted
correctly there have been 38 zeros
and the predicted value and the actual
value is is exactly the same whereas
in this case right it has there are i
think
37 plus 5 yeah 42
have been fed the images 42 images
are of digit 3 and the
accuracy is only 37 of them have been
accurately
predicted three of them have been
predicted as number seven
and two of them have been predicted as
number eight and so on and so forth okay
all right so with that let's go into
jupiter notebook and see
how the code looks so this is the code
in in jupiter notebook for logistic
regression
in this particular demo what we are
going to do is train our model
to recognize digits which are
the images which have digits from
let's say 0 to 5 or 0 to 9 and
and then we will see how well it is
trained and whether it is able to
predict these
numbers correctly or not so let's get
started so the first part
is as usual we are importing some
libraries that are required and then
the last line in this block is to load
the
digits so let's go ahead and run this
code then here we will visualize
the shape of these digits so we can see
here
if we take a look this is how the shape
is 1797
by 64. these are like eight by eight
images
so that's that's what is reflected in
this shape now
from here onwards we are basically once
again importing some of the
libraries that are required like numpy
and matplot
and we will take a look at uh some of
the sample
images that we have uh loaded so this
one for example creates a figure
and then we go ahead and take a few
sample images
to see how they look so let me run this
code and
so that it becomes easy to understand so
these are about
five images sample images that we are
looking at
0 1 2 3 4. so this is how the image is
this is how the data is
okay and based on this we will actually
train
our logistic regression model and then
we will test it and see how well
it is able to recognize so the way it
works is
the pixel information so as you can see
here this is an
8 by 8 pixel kind of a image
and the each pixel whether it is
activated
or not activated that is the information
available for each pixel now based on
the pattern
of this activation and non-activation of
the various pixels this
will be identified as a zero for example
right
similarly as you can see so overall each
of these
numbers actually has a different pattern
of the pixel activation and that's
pretty much that our
model needs to learn for which a number
what is the pattern of the activation of
the pixels right so that is what we are
going to train our
model okay so the first thing we need
to do is to split our data into training
and test data set right so whenever we
perform
any training we split the data into
training and test so that the training
data set is used to train the system
so we pass this probably multiple times
and then we test it with the test data
set and the split is
usually in the form of the and there are
various ways in which you can split this
data
it is up to the individual preferences
in our case here we are splitting in the
form of
23 and 77 so when we say
test size as 20.23
that means 23 percent of the entire data
is used for testing and the remaining 77
percent is used for training
so there is a readily available function
which is uh
called train test split so we don't have
to write any special code for the
splitting it will automatically
split the data based on the proportion
that
we give here which is test size so we
just give the test size
automatically training size will be
determined and
we pass the data that we want to split
and
the the results will be stored in x
underscore train
and y underscore train for the training
data set
and what is x underscore train these are
these are the features
right which is like the independent
variable and
why underscore train is the label right
so in this case what happens is we have
the input value which is
or the features value which is in x
underscore train and since this is the
labeled data
for each of them each of the
observations
we already have the label information
saying whether this digit is a zero or a
one or a two
so that this is what will be used for
comparison to find out whether
the the system is able to recognize it
correctly or there is an error for each
observation it will compare with this
right so this is the label so the same
way x underscore train y underscore
train is for the training data set
x underscore test y underscore test is
for the
test data set okay so let me go ahead
and execute this code
as well and then we can go and check
quickly what is the
how many entries are there and in each
of these so x underscore train
the shape is 13 83
by 64 and y underscore train has 1383
because there is
nothing like the second part is not
required here and then
x underscore test shape we see is 414 so
actually there are 414
observations in test and 1383
observations in train so that's
basically what these four lines of code
are are saying okay then we import the
logistic regression library and
which is a part of scikit learn so we we
don't have to implement the logistic
regression process itself we just call
these
the function and let me go ahead and
execute that
so that we have the logistic regression
library imported now we create an
instance of logistic regression right so
logistic regr is a is an instance of
logistic regression
and then we use that for training our
model so let me first
execute this code so these two lines so
the first line
basically creates an instance of
logistic regression model
and then the second line is where we are
passing
our data the training data set right
this is our
the the predictors and uh this is our
target
we are passing this data set to train
our model
all right so once we do this in this
case the data is not large but
by and large the training is what takes
usually a lot of time so we spend in
machine learning
activities in machine learning projects
we spend a lot of time
for the training part of it okay so here
the data set is relatively small so it
was pretty quick so all right so
now our model has been trained using the
training data set
and we want to see how accurate this is
so what we'll do is we will test it out
in probably
faces so let me first try out how well
this is
working for one image okay i will just
try it out with one image my the first
entry in my test
data set and see whether it is uh
correctly predicting or not so
and in order to test it so for training
purpose we use the
fit method there is a method called fit
which is for training the model
and once the training is done if you
want to test for a particular value new
input you use the
predict method okay so let's run the
predict method
and we pass this particular image
and we see that the shape is
or the prediction is 4. so let's try
a few more let me see for the next 10
seems to be fine so let me just go ahead
and test the entire data set
okay that's basically what we will do so
now we want to find out how accurately
this has performed so we use the score
method to find what is the percentages
of accuracy and we see here that it has
performed up to 94 percent to accurate
okay
so that's on this part now what we can
also do is
we can also see this accuracy
using what is known as a confusion
matrix so let us go ahead and
try that as well so that we can also
visualize
how well this model has done
so let me execute this piece of code
which will basically
import some of the libraries that are
required and
we we basically create a confusion
matrix and instance of
confusion matrix by running confusion
matrix and passing
these values so we have so
this confusion underscore matrix method
takes two parameters
one is the y underscore test and the
other is
the prediction so what is the y
underscore test these are the labeled
values which we already know
for the test data set and predictions
are what the system has predicted for
the
test data set okay so this is known to
us
and this is what the system has the
model has generated so we kind of create
the
confusion matrix and we will print it
and this is how the confusion matrix
looks as the name suggests it is a
matrix and
the key point out here is that the
accuracy of the model
is determined by how many numbers are
there in the diagonal the more the
numbers
in the diagonal the better the accuracy
is
okay and first of all the total sum of
all the numbers in this whole matrix is
equal to the number of observations in
the test data set
that is the first thing right so if you
add up all these numbers that will be
equal to the
number of observations in the test data
set and then
out of that the maximum number of them
should be
in the diagonal that means the accuracy
is pretty good
if the the numbers in the diagonal are
less and in all other places there are a
lot of numbers
which means the accuracy is very low the
diagonal indicates a correct prediction
that
this means that the actual value is same
as the predicted value here again
actual values same as the predictive
value and so on right so the moment
you see a number here that means the
actual value is something
and the predicted value is something
else right similarly here the actual
value is something
and the predicted value is something
else so that is
basically how we read the confusion
matrix
now how do we find the accuracy
you can actually add up the total values
in the diagonal
so it's like 38 plus 44 plus 43 and so
on
and divide that by the total number of
test observations
that will give you the percentage
accuracy using a confusion matrix
now let us visualize this confusion
matrix in a slightly
more sophisticated way using a heat map
so we will create a heat map with some
we'll add some colors as well
it's uh it's like a more visually
visually more appealing so that's the
whole idea
so if we let me run this piece of code
and this is how
the heat map looks and as you can see
here
the diagonals again are all the values
are
here most of the values so which means
reasonably this seems to be reasonably
accurate and yeah basically the accuracy
score is 94 percent this is calculated
as i mentioned
by adding all these numbers divided by
the total
test values or the total number of
observations in test data set
okay so this is the confusion matrix for
logistic regression all right so
now that we have seen the confusion
matrix
let's take a quick sample and see how
well the system has
classified and we will take a few
examples
of the data so if we see here we
we picked up randomly a few of them so
this is uh
number four which is the actual value
and also the predicted value both are
four
this is an image of zero so the
predicted value is also zero
actual value is of course zero then this
is the image of
nine so this has also been predicted
correctly
nine and actual value is nine and this
is the image of one
and again this has been predicted
correctly as
like the actual value okay so this was a
quick demo
of logistic regression how to use
logistic regression to
identify images need for confusion
matrixes
classification models have multiple
output categories
most error measures will tell us the
total
error in our model but we cannot use it
to find out individual instances of
errors
in our models so you have your input
coming in you have your classifier
it measures the error and it says oh 53
of these are correct
but we don't know which 53 percent are
correct is it 53 percent correct
on guessing on the spam is it 23
guessing on spam and
27 guessing on what's not spam
this is where the confusion matrix comes
in
so during the classification we also
have to overcome the limitations of
accuracy
accuracy can be misleading for
classification problems
if there is a significant class
imbalance
a model might predict the majority class
for all cases
and have a high accuracy score
and so you can see here we have our
email coming in and there's two spams
the classifier comes in and goes hey it
only catches one of those spams and it
misclassifies one that's not spam
so our model predicted eight out of ten
instance and will have an accuracy of 80
percent
but is it classifying correctly
a confusion matrix represents a table
layout of the different
outcomes of prediction and results of a
classification problem and helps
visualize its outcomes and so you see
here we have our
simple chart predicted and actual
the confusion matrix helps us identify
the correct predictions of a model for
different individual classes
as well as the errors so you'll see here
that the values predicted by our
classifier are along the rows
this is what we're going to guess it is
our cl our model is guessing what this
is based on its
training so we've already trained the
model to
guess whether it's spam or not spam or
whatever it is you're working on
and then the actual values of our data
set are along the columns
so this is the actual value it's
supposed to be
people who can speak english will be
classified as positives
so because they have a remember 001 do
you speak english yes no
and you could extend this that they
might have do you speak
french do you speak whatever languages
and so you might have a whole lot of
classifiers that you would look at each
one of these
people who cannot speak english will be
classified as negatives
so there'll be a zero so zero ones
the number of times our actual positive
values are equal to predicted
positive values gives us true positive
tp
the number of times our actual negative
values are equal to predictive negative
values gives us true negative tn
the number of times our model wrongly
predicts negative values as positives
gives us a false positive
fp and you'll see when you're working
with these a lot
you know memorizing that is false
positive you can easily figure out what
that is and pretty soon you're just
looking at the fp
or the tp depending on what you're
working on and the number of times our
model wrongly predicts positive values
as
negatives gives us a false negative
fp now i'm going to do a quick step
out here let's say you're working in the
medical
and we're talking about cancer
do you really want a bunch of false
negatives
you want zero under false negative so
when we look at this confusion matrix
if you have five percent false positives
and five percent false negatives it'd be
much better to even have
twenty percent false positives because
they go in and test it and
zero false negatives the same might be
true
if you're working on say a car
driving is this a safe place for the car
to go
well you really don't want any false
positives
you know yes this is safe right over the
cliff
so again when you're working on the
project or whatever it is you're working
on
this chart suddenly has huge value
we were talking about spam email how
many
important emails say from your banking
overdraft charge coming in
that you want to be a a true a false
negative
you don't want it to go in the spam
folder likewise you want to
get as much of the spam out of there but
you don't want to miss anything really
important
confusion matrix metrics are performance
measures which help us find the accuracy
of our classifier
there are four main metrics accuracy
precision recall and f1 score
the f1 score is the one i usually hear
the most and accuracy
is usually what you put on your chart uh
when you're sending in front of the
shareholders how accurate is it
people understand accuracy
f1 score is a little bit more on the
math side
and so you've got to be a little careful
when you're quoting f1 scores in the
when you're sitting there with all the
shareholders because a lot of them will
just glaze over
so confusion matrix metrics are
performance measures
which help us find the accuracy of our
classifier there are four main metrics
accuracy the accuracy is used to find
the portion of the correctly classified
values
it tells us how often our classifier is
right
it is the sum of all true values divided
by the total values
and this makes sense uh again it's one
of those things
i don't want to depends on what you're
looking for are you looking for
not to miss any spam mails are you
looking to drive down the road
and not run anybody over precision
is used to calculate the model's ability
to classify positive values correctly
it answers the question when the model
predicts a positive value
how often is it right it is the true
positive divided by the total number of
predicted positive
values again this one depends on what
project you're working on
whether this is what you're going to be
focusing on
so recall it is used to calculate the
model's ability to predict positive
values
how often does the model actually
predict the correct
positive values it is the true positives
divided by the total number of actual
positive values and then your f1 score
it is the harmonic mean of recall and
precision it is useful when you need to
take
both precision and recall into account
consider the following two confusion
matrix derived from two different
classifier
to figure out which one performs better
we can
find the confusion matrix for both of
them
and you can see we're back to does it
classify
whether they can speak english or or
non-speaker they speak some they don't
know the english language and so we put
these two uh
confusion matrixes out here we can go
ahead and do the math behind that we can
look up the accuracy that's a tpn plus
tn over the tf plus tn plus fp
plus fn and so we get an accuracy of
0.8125
and we have a precision if you do the
precision which is your
tp truth positive over t p plus
f p uh we get 0.891
and if we do the recall we'll end up
with the 0.825 that's your tp over tp
plus fn and then of course your f1 score
which is two times precision times
recall
over precision plus recall and we get
the 0.857
and if we do that um with another model
let's say we had two different models
and we're trying to see which one
we want to use for whatever reason
we might go ahead and compute the same
things we have our accuracy
our precision and our recall and our f1
score
and as we're looking at this we might
look at the accuracy because that's
really what we're interested in
is uh how many people are we able to
classify as being able to speak english
i really don't want to know
if i'm you know i i i really don't want
to know if they're non-speakers
i'd rather miss 10 people speaking
english instead of 15.
and so you can see from these charts
we'd probably go with the first model
because it does a better job
guessing who speaks english and has a
higher accuracy because in this case
that is what we're looking for so
uh with that we'll go ahead and pull up
a demo so you can see what this looks
like
in the python setup in in the actual
coding
for this we'll go into anaconda
navigator
if you're not familiar with anaconda
it's a really
good tool to use as far as doing display
in demos and for quick development
as a data scientist i just love the
package
now if you're going to do something
heavier lifting there's some limitations
with anaconda and with the setup
but in general you can do just about
anything in here with your python
and for this we'll go with jupiter
notebook jupyter lab is the same as
jupiter notebook
you'll see they now have integration
with pi charm if you work in pycharm
certainly there's a lot of other
integrations that anaconda has
and we've opened up i simply learn files
i work on
and create a new file called confusion
matrix demo
and the first thing we want to note is
the data we're working with
uh here i've opened it up in a wordpad
or notepad or whatever
you can see it's got a row of headers
comma separated and then all the data
going down below
and then i save this in the same file so
i don't have to remember what path i'm
working on
uh of course if you have your data
separated and you're working with a lot
of data you probably want to put it into
a different folder or file
depending on what you're doing and the
first thing we're going to do is go
ahead and import our tools
we're going to use the pandas that's our
data frame
if you haven't had a chance to work with
the data frame please review
panda's data frame and going to simply
learn you can pull up the pandas data
frame
tutorial on there and then we're going
to use
uh the scikit framework which is
all denoted as sklearn and i can just
pull this in you can see here's the
scikit learn.org with the stable version
that you can import into your python
and from here we're going to use the
train test split
for splitting our data we're going to do
some pre-processing
we're going to do use the logistic
regression model
that's our actual machine learning model
we're using
and then what this quote this particular
setup is about is we're going to do the
accuracy score
the confusion matrix and the classifier
report
so let me go ahead and run that and
bring all that information in
and just like we open the file we need
to go ahead and load our data in here
so we're going to go ahead and do our
pandas read csv
and then just because we're in jupyter
notebook we can just put data to read
the data in here
a lot of times we'll actually let me
just do this i prefer to do the
just the head of the date or the top
part
and you can see we have age sex i'm not
sure what cp stands for
test bps cholesterol so a lot of
different
measurements if you were in this domain
you want to know what all these
different
measurements mean i don't want to focus
on that
too much because when we're talking
about data science a lot of times you
have no idea what the data means
if you've ever looked up the breast
cancer measurement is just a bunch of
measurements and numbers
unless you're a doctor you have no idea
what those measurements mean
but if it's your specialty and your
domain you better know them so we're
going to go ahead and create y
and it's going to we're going to set it
equal to the target
so here's our target value here and
there's either 1 or 0.
so we have a classifier if you're
dealing with 1 0
true false what do you have you have a
classifier
and then our x is going to be
everything except for the target
so we're going to go ahead and drop the
target axis equals 1.
remember that's columns versus the index
or rows
axis equals zero would would give you an
error but you would
drop like row two and then we'll go
ahead and just print that out so you can
see what we're looking at
and here we have y
data x data and you can see from the x
data we have the x head
and we can go ahead and just do print
the y head data and run that
so this is all loading the data that
we've done so far
if there's a confusion in there go back
and rewind the tape and review it
and then we need to go ahead and split
our data into
our x train x test y train
y test and then keep in mind you always
want to split the data
before we do the scalar and the reason
is
is that you want the scalar on the
training data
to be set on the training data data or
fit to it
but not on the test data think of this
as being out in the field
you're not it could actually alter your
results
so it's always important to do make sure
whatever you do to the training data
or whatever fit you're doing is always
done on the training
not on the test and then we want to go
ahead and
scale the data now we are working with
a linear regression model i'll mention
this here in a minute when we get to the
actual model
uh so some sometimes you don't need to
scale it when you're working with linear
regression models it's not going to
change your result as much as say a
neural network where it has a huge
impact
uh but we're going to go ahead and take
here's our x train x test y train y test
we create our scalar we go ahead and
scale uh the scale is going to fit the x
train and then we're going to go ahead
and take our x train and transform it
and then we also need to take our x test
and transform it based on the scale
on here so that our x is now between
that nice uh minus one to one
and so this is all uh our pre
data setup and hopefully
uh all of that looks fairly familiar to
you if you've done a number of our other
classes and you're
up to the setup on here
and then we want to go ahead and do is
create our model and we're going to use
the
logistic regression model and from the
logistic regression model
we're going to go ahead and fit our x
train and y train and then we'll run our
predicted value on here
let's go ahead and run that and so now
we are we actually have like our x test
and our prediction so if you remember
from
our matrix we're looking for the actual
versus the prediction and how those
compare
and if i take us back up here you're
going to notice that we imported the
accuracy
score the confusion matrix and the
classification report
and there's of course our logistic
regression the model we're using for
this
and i did mention is going to talk a
little bit about scalar and the
regression model
the scalar on a lot of your regression
models your basic mass
standard regression models and i'd have
to look it up for the logistic
regression model
when you're using a standard regression
model you don't need to scale the data
it's already just built in by the way
the model works
in most cases uh but if you're in a
neural network and
there's a lot of other different setups
then you really want to take this
and fit that on there and so
we can go in and do the accuracy and
this is if you remember correctly we
were looking at the accuracy
with the english speaking so this is
saying our accuracy
as to whether this person is i believe
this is the heart
data set um
it's going to be accurate about 85
percent of the time as far as whether
it's going to predict
the person's going to have a heart
condition
or the one as it comes up with the 0 1
on there
which would mean at this point that you
have an 85 percent being correct on
telling someone they're extremely high
risk for a heart attack kind of thing
and so we want to go ahead and create
our confusion matrix
and let me just do that
of course the software does everything
for us so we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see right here um here's our
25
prediction correct predictions right
here
and if you remember from our slide i'll
just bring this over says a nice visual
we have our true positive
false positive so we had 25 which were
true
that it said hey this person is going to
be high risk at heart
and we had four that were still high
risk that has said we're false
so out of these 25 people or out of
these 29 people and that makes sense
because you have 0.85
out of 29 people it was correct on 25 of
them
and so here's our accuracy score we were
just looking at that our accuracy
is your true positive and your true
negative over all of them
so how true is it there is our accuracy
coming up here
0.85 and then we have our nice matrix
generated from that
and you can see right here is a similar
matrix we had going for the
from the slide and this starts to this
should start asking questions at this
point um
so if you're in a board meeting or
you're working with this you really want
to start looking at
this data here and saying well is this
good enough is uh
this number of people and hopefully
you'd have a much larger data set
it might is my confusion matrix showing
for the
true positive and false positive is that
acceptable for what we're doing and of
course if you're going to put together
whatever data you're putting out you
might want to separate the
true negative false positive false
negative true positive
and you can simply do that by doing the
confusion matrix
and then of course the ravel part lets
you set that up so you can just split
that right up into a nice tuple
and the final thing we want to show you
here in
the coding on this part
is the confusion matrix metrics
and so we can come in here and just use
the matrix equals classification report
the y test and the predict and then
we're going to take that classification
report
and go ahead and print that out and you
can see here it does a nice job
giving you your accuracy your micro
average
your weighted average you have your
precision
your recall your f1 score and your
support
all in one window so you can start
looking at this data and saying oh
okay our precision's at point eight
three
uh point eight seven for getting a a
positive
and point eight three for the negative
side for a zero
and we start talking about whether this
is a valid information or not to use
and when we're looking at a heart attack
prediction we're only looking at
one aspect what's the chances of this
person having a heart attack or not
you might have something where we went
back to the languages
maybe you also want to know whether they
speak english or
hindi uh or french and you can see right
here that we can now
take our confusion matrix and just
expand it as big as we need to depending
on how many different classifiers we're
working on
decision tree important terms before we
dive in further
we need to look at some basic terms we
need to have
some definitions to go with our decision
tree in the different parts we're going
to be using we'll start with
entropy entropy is a measure of
randomness or unpredictability in the
data set
for example we have a group of animals
in this picture there's four different
kinds of animals and this data set
is considered to have a high entropy you
really can't pick out what kind of
animal it is based on looking at just
the four animals
as a big clump of entities so as we
start splitting it into subgroups we
come up with our
second definition which is information
gain
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy
after the data set is split so in this
case based on the color yellow we've
split
one group of animals on one side as true
and those who aren't yellow
as false as we continue down the yellow
side we split based on the height
true or false equals 10 and on the other
side height is less than 10
true or false and as you see as we split
it the entropy continues to be less and
less and less and so our information
gain is simply
the entropy e1 from the top and how it's
changed to e2 on the bottom and we'll
look at the
deeper math although you really don't
need to know a huge amount of math when
you actually do the programming in
python because they'll do it for you but
we'll look on the actual math of how
they compute entropy finally we went on
the different parts of our tree
and they call the leaf node leaf node
carries the classification or the
decision
so it's the final end at the bottom the
decision node
has two or more branches this is where
we're breaking the group up into
different parts
and finally you have the root node the
topmost decision node is known as the
root node how does a decision tree work
wonder what kind of animals i'll get in
the jungle
today maybe you're the hunter with the
gun or if you're more into photography
you're a photographer with a camera so
let's look at this group of animals and
let's try to classify
different types of animals based on
their features using a decision tree so
the problem statement
is to classify the different types of
animals based on their features using a
decision tree the data set
is looking quite messy and the entropy
is high in this case
so let's look at a training set or a
training data set
and we're looking at color we're looking
at height and then we have our different
animals we have our elephants our
giraffes our monkeys and our tigers
and they're of different colors and
shapes let's see what that looks like
and how do we split the data we have to
frame the conditions
that split the data in such a way that
the information gain
is the highest note gain is the measure
of decrease in entropy
after splitting so the formula for
entropy is the sum
that's what this symbol looks like that
looks like kind of like a
e funky e of k where i equals 1 to k
k would represent the number of animals
the different animals in there
where value or p value of i
would be the percentage of that animal
times the log
base two of the same the percentage of
that animal
let's try to calculate the entropy for
the current data set and take a look at
what that looks like and don't be afraid
of the math you don't really have to
memorize this math
just be aware that it's there and this
is what's going on in the background
and so we have three giraffes two tigers
one monkey
two elephants a total of eight animals
gathered and if we plug that into the
formula
we get an entropy that equals three over
eight
so we have three giraffes a total of
eight times the log
usually they use base two on the log so
log base two
of three over eight plus in this case
it's yellow fence
two over eight two elephants over total
of eight times log base two
two over eight plus one monkey over
total of eight
log base two one over eight and plus two
over eight of the tigers
log base two over eight and if we plug
that into our computer our calculator i
obviously can't do logs in my head
we get an entropy equal to 0.571
the program will actually calculate the
entropy of the data set
similarly after every split to calculate
the gain
now we're not going to go through each
set one at a time to see what those
numbers are we just want you to be aware
that this is a formula or the
mathematics behind it
gain can be calculated by finding the
difference of the subsequent entropy
values
after a split now we'll try to choose a
condition that gives us the highest
gain we will do that by splitting the
data using each condition and checking
that the gain we get out of them the
condition that gives us the highest gain
will be used to make the first split
can you guess what that first split will
be just by looking at this image
as a human is probably pretty easy to
split it let's see if you're right
if you guessed the color yellow you're
correct
let's say the condition that gives us
the maximum gain is yellow so we will
split the data based on the color yellow
if it's true that group of animals goes
to the left if it's false
it goes to the right the entropy after
the splitting has to
decreased considerably however we still
need some splitting of both the branches
to attain an entropy value equal to zero
so we decide to split both the nodes
using height as the condition
since every branch now contains single
label type we can say that entropy in
this case has reached the least
value and here you see we have the
giraffes the tigers the monkey and the
elephants
all separated into their own groups this
tree can now predict all the classes of
animals present in the data set with a
hundred percent accuracy that was easy
use case loan repayment prediction let's
get into my favorite part and open up
some python
and see what the programming code in the
scripting looks like in here
we're going to want to do a prediction
and we start with this individual here
who's requesting to find out how good
his customers are going to be
whether they're going to repay their
loan or not for his bank and from that
we want to generate a problem statement
to predict if a customer will repay loan
amount
or not and then we're going to be using
the decision tree algorithm in python
let's see what that looks like and let's
dive into the code
in our first few steps of implementation
we're going to start by
importing the necessary packages that we
need from python and we're going to load
up our data
and take a look at what the data looks
like so the first thing i need is i need
something to edit my python and run it
in so let's flip on over
and here i'm using the anaconda jupiter
notebook
now you can use any python ide you like
to run it in but i find the jupiter
notebooks really nice for doing things
on the fly
and let's go ahead and just paste that
code in the beginning and before we
start
let's talk a little bit about what we're
bringing in and then we're going to do a
couple things in here we have to make a
couple changes as we go through this
first part of the import
the first thing we bring in is numpy as
np
that's very standard when we're dealing
with mathematics especially with uh very
complicated
machine learning tools you almost always
see the numpy come in for your num
your number it's called number python it
has your mathematics in there in this
case
we actually could take it out but
generally you'll need it for most of
your different things you work with
and then we're going to use pandas as pd
that's also a standard the
pandas is a data frame setup and you can
liken this to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks
like an excel spreadsheet so as we come
back to this when you see
np or pd those are very standard uses
you'll know that that's the pandas
and i'll show you a little bit more when
we explore the data in just a minute
then we're going to need to split the
data so i'm going to bring in our train
test and split and this is coming from
the sk learn
package cross validation in just a
minute we're going to change that and
we'll go over that too
and then there's also the sk.tree import
decision tree classifier that's the
actual tool we're using remember i told
you don't be afraid of the mathematics
it's going to be done for you
well the decision tree classifier has
all that mathematics in there for you so
you don't have to figure it back out
again
and then we have sklearn.metrics for
accuracy score
we need to score our our setup that's
the whole reason we're splitting it
between the training and testing data
and finally we still need the sklearn
import tree and that's just the basic
tree function is needed for the decision
tree classifier
and finally we're going to load our data
down here and i'm going to run this and
we're going to get two things on here
one we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like
so the first thing we had is we have an
error why is this error here well it's
looking at this it says
i need to read a file and when this was
written
the person who wrote it this is their
path where they stored the file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full
file name and you'll see it's on my c
drive and this is very lengthy
setup on here where i stored the
data2.csv
file don't worry too much about the full
path because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated
by simplylearn if you want a copy of
that you can comment down below
and request it here in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to
full file name so let's go ahead and run
it now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding understanding these
different warnings and these different
errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a
opportunity to understand what's going
on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation
is depreciated so it's a warning on it's
being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation
and if you research this and go to the
sklearn site you'll find out that you
can actually just swap it right in there
with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning what they've done
is they've had two different developers
develop it in two different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one
that's all that is and very easy and
quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the
data underscore2.csv let's talk a little
bit more about that and see what that
looks like both as a text file
because it's a comma separated variable
file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got
one two three four five columns and each
column has data in it and let me flip
this over because we're also going to
look at this uh
in an actual spreadsheet so you can see
what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as
excel and zoomed in and you can see
we've got our columns
and our rows of data a little easier to
read in here we have a result
yes yes no we have initial payment last
payment credit score
house number if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then 1 000 lines of data
now as a programmer if you're looking at
a small amount of data i usually start
by pulling it up in different sources so
i can see what i'm working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it'll just be
too too large so you need to either
bring in a small amount that you can
look at it like we're doing right now
or we can start looking at it through
the python code so let's go ahead and
move on
and take the next couple steps to
explore the data using python
let's go ahead and see what it looks
like in python to print the length and
the shape of the data
so let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this you'll see that it's
a thousand
long and that's what we expected there's
a thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the
column head this is one of the nice
things when we did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row zero
so it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines
it also tells me there's five columns so
we were looking at the data we had five
columns of data
and then let's take one more step to
explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape
let's go ahead and use the pandas
module for head another beautiful thing
in the data set that we can utilize
so let's put that on our sheet here and
we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there
and then we went ahead and gave a label
for our print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that let's just take a closer
look at that let me zoom in here
there we go pandas do such a wonderful
job
of making this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it
when you put it as the head it prints
the first five lines of the data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two
three four instead of one two three four
five that's a standard
scripting and programming set as you
wanna start with the zero position
and that is what the data head does it
pulls the first five rows of data
puts in a nice format that you can look
at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet
or open office cal or trying to look at
a
word doc where it's all scrunched
together and hard to read you can now
get a nice open view of what you're
working with
we're working with a shape of a thousand
long five wide so we have five columns
and we do the full data head you can
actually see what this data looks like
the initial payment
last payment credit scores house number
so let's take this now that we've
explored the data and let's start
digging into the decision tree
so in our next step we're going to
train and build our data tree and to do
that
we need to first separate the data out
we're going to separate into two groups
so that we have something to actually
train the data with and
then we have some data on the side to
test it to see how good our model is
remember with any of the machine
learning you always want to have some
kind of test set
to weigh it against so you know how good
your model is when you distribute it
let's go ahead and break this code down
and look at it in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at source and target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in
and the data that we're actually trying
to guess what the answer is going to be
and so to separate it we can simply put
in
x equals the balance of the data.values
the
first brackets means that we're going to
select
all the lines in the database so it's
all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero
zero is a yes or no and that's whether
the loan went default or not
so we want to start with one if we go
back up here that's the initial payment
and it goes all the way through the
house number well if we want to look at
one through five we can do the same
thing for y which is the answers
and we're going to set that just equal
to the zero row
so it's just the zero row and then it's
all rows going in there so now we've
divided this
into two different data sets one of them
with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test
your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules
this does it all for us and you can see
they set the test size equal to 0.3
so that's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there
and then finally we get to actually
build our decision tree
and they've called it here clf
underscore entropy
that's the actual decision tree or
decision tree classifier
and in here they've added a couple
variables which we'll explore in just a
minute
and then finally we need to fit the data
to that
so we take our clf entropy that we
created and we fit the x
train and since we know the answers for
x trait or the y train
we go ahead and put those in and let's
go ahead and run this and what most of
these
sklearn modules do is when you set up
the variable
in this case we set the clf entropy
called decision tree classifier it
automatically prints out what's in that
decision tree
there's a lot of variables you can play
within here and it's quite beyond the
scope
of this tutorial to go through all of
these and how they work
but we're working on entropy that's one
of the options we've added that it's
completely a random state of 100 so 100
percent
and we have a max depth of three now the
max depth if you remember above when we
were doing the different graphs of
animals
means it's only going to go down three
layers before it stops
and then we have minimal samples of
leaves as five so it's going to have at
least
five leaves at the end so i'll have at
least three splits i'll have no more
than three layers
and at least five end leaves with the
final
result at the bottom now that we've
created
our decision tree classifier not only
created it but trained it
let's go ahead and apply it and see what
that looks like so let's go ahead and
make a prediction
and see what that looks like we're going
to paste our predict code in here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our variable clf
entropy that we created and then you'll
see dot predict
and it's very common in the sk learn
modules
that their different tools have the
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use in
actual commercial use and
distributed it this would be the new
loans you're putting in here to guess
whether the person is going to be uh pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our sample is
how good of our tree
does at predicting the loan payments and
finally
since anaconda jupiter notebook is it
works as a command line for python we
can simply put the y
predict e in to print it i could just as
easily have put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out
we'll go ahead and do that it doesn't
matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly
300 in here remember it's 30 percent of
a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our
test went in there and this is what our
y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data
and try to figure out just how good a
model we have so here we go since
sklearn does all the heavy lifting for
you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is
and let's go ahead and go through that
and see what that means and what that
looks like let's go ahead and paste this
in and let me zoom in a little bit there
we go
so you have a nice full picture and
we'll see here we're just going to do a
print accuracy is
and then we do the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see
where that's coming from that's coming
from here down here from sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score and you could
probably run a script make your own
script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
did we get right
and so we put in our y test that's the
one we ran the predict on
and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got
and we're just going to multiply that by
a hundred because this is just going to
give us an answer as a decimal
and we want to see it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.6667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit
we can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that
we now have accuracy set up on here and
so we have created a model that uses the
decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not
the accuracy of the model is about 94.6
the bank can now use this model to
decide whether it should approve the
loan request from a particular customer
or not
and so this information is really
powerful we may not be able to as
individuals understand all these numbers
because they have thousands of numbers
that come in but you can see that this
is a smart decision for the bank to use
a tool like this
to help them to predict how good their
profit's going to be
off of the loan balances and how many
are going to default or not
how does a random forest work as a whole
so to begin
our random forest classifier
let's say we already have built three
trees
and we're gonna start with the first
tree that looks like this just like we
did in the example this tree looks at
the diameter if it's greater than or
equal to three
it's true otherwise it's false so one
side goes to the smaller diameter one
side goes to larger
diameter and if the color is orange
it's going to go to the right true we're
using oranges now instead of lemons
and if it's red it's going to go to the
left false we build a second tree very
similar but split differently instead of
the first one being split by a diameter
this one when they created it if you
look at that first bowl it has a lot of
red objects
so it says is the color red because
that's going to bring our entropy down
the fastest and so of course if it's
true it goes to the left
if it's false it goes to the right and
then it looks at the shape
false are true and so on and so on and
tree three is a diameter equal to one
and it came up with this because there's
a lot of cherries in this bowl
so that would be the biggest split on
there is is the diameter equal to one
that's going to drop the entropy the
quickest
and as you can see it splits it into
true if it goes false and they've added
another category
does it grow in the summer and if it's
false it goes off to the left if it's
true
it goes off to the right let's go ahead
and bring these three trees you can see
them all in one image
so this would be three completely
different trees categorizing a fruit
and let's take a fruit now let's try
this and this fruit if you look at it
we've blackened it out
you can't see the color on it so it's
missing data remember one of the things
we talked about earlier
is that a random forest works really
good if you're missing data if you're
missing pieces
so this fruit has an image but maybe the
person had a black and white
camera when they took the picture and
we're going to take a look at this
and it's going to have they put the
color in there so ignore the color down
there
but the diameter equals 3 we find out it
grows in the summer equals yes
and the shape is a circle and if you go
to the right you can look at what one of
the decision trees did
this is the third one is the diameter
greater than equal to 3
is the color orange well it doesn't
really know on this one but
if you look at the value it's a true and
it goes to the right tree
two classifies it as cherries is the
color equal
red is the shape of circle true it is a
circle
so this would look at it and say oh
that's a cherry and then we go to the
other classifier and it says is the
diameter equal one
well that's false does it grow in the
summer true
so it goes down and looks at as oranges
so how does this random forest work the
first one says it's an orange the second
one said it was a cherry
and the third one says it's an orange
and you can guess
if you have two oranges and one says
it's a cherry when you add that all
together
the majority of the vote says orange so
the answer is it's classified as an
orange even though we didn't know the
color and we're missing data on it
i don't know about you but i'm getting
tired of fruit so let's switch
and i did promise you we'd start looking
at a case example
and get into some python coding today
we're going to use the case
the iris flower analysis this is the
exciting part as we roll up our sleeves
and actually look at some python coding
before we start the python coding we
need to go ahead and create a problem
statement
wonder what species of iris do these
flowers belong to
let's try to predict the species of the
flowers using machine learning in
python let's see how it can be done so
here we begin to go ahead and
implement our python code and you'll
find that the first half of our
implementation is all about
organizing and exploring the data coming
in let's go ahead and take
this first step which is loading the
different modules into python and let's
go ahead and put that in our favorite
editor whatever your favorite editor is
in this case i'm going to be using the
anaconda jupiter notebook which is one
of my favorites
certainly there's notepad plus plus and
eclipse and dozens of others or just
even
using the python terminal window any of
those will work just fine to go ahead
and explore
this python coding so here we go let's
go ahead and flip over to our jupyter
notebook
and i've already opened up a new page
for python 3 code and i'm just going to
paste this right in there
and let's take a look and see what we're
bringing into our python
the first thing we're going to do is
from the sklearn.datasets
import load iris now this isn't the
actual data this is just the module
that allows us to bring in the data the
load iris
and the iris is so popular it's been
around since 1936
when ronald fisher published a paper on
it and they're measuring
the different parts of the flower and
based on those measurements predicting
what kind of flower it is and then if
we're going to do a random forest
classifier
we need to go ahead and import a random
forest classifier from the sk learn
module
so sklearn dot ensemble import random
forest classifier
and then we want to bring in two more
modules and these are
probably the most commonly used modules
in python and data science
with any of the other modules that we
bring in
and one is going to be pandas we're
going to import pandas as pd
pd is a common term used for pandas and
pandas is basically
creates a data format for us where
when you create a pandas data frame it
looks like
an excel spreadsheet and you'll see that
in a minute when we start digging deeper
into the code
panda is just wonderful because it plays
nice with all the other modules in there
and then we have numpy which is our
numbers python and the numbers python
allows us to do different mathematical
sets on here
we'll see right off the bat we're going
to take our np
and we're going to go ahead and seed the
randomness with it with 0. so
np.random.seed is seating that is 0.
this code doesn't actually show anything
we're going to go ahead and run it
because i need to make sure i have all
those loaded
and then let's take a look at the next
module on here the next six slides
including this one are all about
exploring the data remember i told you
half of this is about
looking at the data and getting it all
set so let's go ahead and take
this code right here the script and
let's get that over into our jupiter
notebook
and here we go we've gone ahead and run
the
imports and i'm going to paste the code
down here
and let's take a look and see what's
going on the first thing we're doing is
we're actually loading
the iris data and if you remember up
here we loaded the module that tells it
how to get the iris data
now we're actually assigning that data
to the variable iris
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the df to define
data frame and that's going to equal pd
and if you remember that's pandas as pd
so that's our pandas and panda data
frame and then we're looking at iris
data and columns equals iris feature
names
and we're going to do the df head and
let's run this you can understand what's
going on here
the first thing you want to notice is
that our df has created
what looks like an excel spreadsheet and
in this excel spreadsheet we have set
the columns
so up on the top you can see the four
different columns
and then we have the data iris.data down
below it's a little confusing without
knowing where this data is coming from
so let's look at
the bigger picture and i'm going to go
print i'm just going to change this for
a moment
and we're going to print all of iris and
see what that looks like
so when i print all of iris i get this
long list of information
and you can scroll through here and see
all the different titles on there
what's important to notice is that first
off there's a brackets at the beginning
so this is a python dictionary and in a
python dictionary
you'll have a key or a label
and this label pulls up whatever
information comes after it
so feature names which we actually used
over here under columns
is equal to an array of sepal length
sepal width
petal length petal width these are the
different names they have for the four
different columns
and if you scroll down far enough you'll
also see data down here oh
goodness it came up right towards the
top and data is equal to the different
data we're looking at
now there's a lot of other things in
here like target we're going to be
pulling that up in a minute
and there's also the names the target
names which is further down
and we'll show you that also in a minute
let's go ahead and set that back
to the head and this is one of the neat
features
of pandas and panda data frames
is when you do df.head or the
pandadataframe.head
it'll print the first five lines of the
dataset in there along with the headers
if you have it in this case we have the
column header set to iris features
and in here you'll see that we have zero
one two
three four in python most arrays always
start at zero
so when you look at the first five it's
going to be zero one two three four not
one two three four five
so now we've got our iris data imported
into a data frame
let's take a look at the next piece of
code in here and so in this section here
of the code we're gonna take a look at
the target
and let's go ahead and get this into our
notebook this piece of code so we can
discuss it a little bit more in detail
so here we are in our jupiter notebook
i'm going to put the code in here
and before i run it i want to look at a
couple things going on
so we have df species
and this is interesting because right
here you'll see where i have df species
in brackets which is uh the key code for
creating another column
and here we have iris.target now these
are both in the
pandas setup on here so in pandas we can
do either one
i could have just as easily done iris
and then in brackets
target depending on what i'm working on
both are
acceptable let's go ahead and run this
code and see how this changes
and what we've done is we've added the
target from the iris data set
as another column on the end
now what species is this is what we're
trying to predict
so we have our data which tells us the
answer for all these different pieces
and then we've added a column with the
answer that way when we do
our final setup we'll have the ability
to program our neural network to look
for these
this different data and know what a
setosa is or
a vera color which we'll see in just a
minute or virginica those are the three
that are in there
and now we're going to add one more
column i know
we're organizing all this data over and
over again it's kind of fun
there's a lot of ways to organize it
what's nice about putting everything
onto
one data frame is i can then do
a printout and it shows me exactly what
i'm looking at and i'll show you that
where you where that's different where
you can alter that and do it slightly
differently
but let's go ahead and put this into our
script up to debt now
and here we go we're going to put that
down here
and we're going to run that and let's
talk a little bit about what we're doing
now we're exploring data and
one of the challenges is knowing how
good your model is
did your model work and to do this we
need to split the data and we split it
into two different
parts they usually call it the training
and the testing and so in here
we're going to go ahead and put that in
our database so you can see it clearly
and we've set it df remember you can put
brackets this is creating another column
is train so we're going to use part of
it for training and this equals
np remember that stands for
numpy.random.uniform so we're generating
a random number
between 0 and 1 and we're going to do it
for each
of the rows that's where the length df
comes from so each row gets a generated
number and if it's
less than 0.75 it's true and if it's
greater than
0.75 it's false this means we're going
to take
75 of the data roughly because there's a
randomness involved
and we're going to use that to train it
and then the other 25
we're going to hold off to the side and
use that to test it later on so let's
flip back on over and see what the next
step
is so now that we've labeled our
database for which is training and which
is testing
let's go ahead and sort that into two
different variables
train and test and let's take this code
and let's bring it into our project
and here we go let's paste it on down
here and before i run this
let's just take a quick look at what's
going on here is we have
up above we created remember there's our
def dot head which prints the first five
rows and we've added a column
is train at the end and so we're going
to take that we're going to create
two variables we're going to create two
new data frames one's called
train one's called test 75 percent in
train 25
and test and then to sort that out
we're going to do that by doing df our
main original data frame with the iris
data in it
and if df is trained equals true
that's going to go in the train and if
df is train equals false it goes in the
test
and so when i run this we're going to
print out the number in each one
let's see what that looks like and
you'll see that it puts 118 in the
training module
and it puts 32 in the testing module
which lets us know that there was 150
lines of data in here so if you went and
looked at the original data you could
see that there's 150 lines
and that's roughly 75 and 1 and 25
for us to test our model on afterward so
let's jump back to our code and see
where this goes
in the next two steps we want to do one
more thing with our data
and that's make it readable to humans i
don't know about you but i hate looking
at
zeros and ones so let's start with the
features and let's go ahead and take
those
and make those readable to humans and
let's put that in our code
let's see here we go paste it in and
you'll see here we've done
a couple very basic things we know that
the columns in our data frame again this
is a panda thing
the df columns and we know the first
four of them
zero one two three that'd be the first
four are going to be the features or the
titles of those columns and so when i
run this
you'll see down here that it creates an
index sepa length
sepa width pedal length and pedal width
and this should be familiar because if
you look up here here's our column
titles going across
and here's the first four one thing i
want you to notice here
is that when you're in a command line
whether it's jupyter notebook
or you're running command line in the
terminal window
if you just put the name of it it'll
print it out this is the same as doing
print features
and the shorthand is you just put
features in here if you're actually
writing a code and saving the script and
running it by remote
you really need to put the print in
there but for this when i run it you'll
see it gives me the same thing
but for this we want to go ahead and
we'll just leave it as features because
it doesn't really matter
and this is one of the fun thing about
jupiter notebooks is i'm just building
the code as we go
and then we need to go ahead and create
the labels for the other part so let's
take a look and see what that
for our final step in prepping our data
before we actually start running the
training and the testing is we're going
to go ahead
and convert the species on here into
something the computer understands
so let's put this code into our script
and see where that takes us
all right here we go we set y equal to
pd.factorize
train species of zero
so let's break this down just a little
bit we have our pandas
right here pd factorize what's
factorized doing i'm going to come back
to that in just a second
let's look at what train species is and
why we're looking at
the group zero on there and let's go up
here
and here is our species
remember this and we created this whole
column here for species and then it has
setosa setosa setosa setosa and if you
scroll down enough you'd also see
virginica and veracolor we need to
convert that into something the computer
understands zeros and ones
so the trained species of zero
because this is in the format of a of an
array of arrays
so you have to have the zero on the end
and then species is just that column
factorize goes in there looks at the
fact
that there's only three of them so when
i run this you'll see that y
generates an array that's equal to in
this case it's the training set
and it's zeros ones and twos
representing the three different kinds
of flowers we have
so now we have something the computer
understands and we have a nice table
that we can read and understand and now
finally
we get to actually start doing the
predicting so here we go
we have two lines of code oh my goodness
that was a lot of work to get to two
lines of code
but there is a lot in these two lines of
code so let's take a look
and see what's going on here and put
this into our
full script that we're running and let's
paste this in here
and let's take a look and see what this
is we have we're creating a variable clf
and we're going to set this equal to the
random forest classifier
and we're passing two variables in here
and there's a lot of variables you can
play with
as far as these two are concerned
they're very standard in
jobs all that does is to prioritize it
not something to really worry about
usually when you're doing this on your
own computer you do in jobs equals two
if you're working in a larger or big
data and you need to prioritize it
differently this is what that
number does is it changes your
priorities and how it's going to run
across the system and things like that
and then the random state is just how it
starts 0 is fine for here
but let's go ahead and run this
we also have clf.fit train features
comma y and before we run it let's talk
about this a little bit more
clf dot fit so we're fitting
we're training it we are actually
creating our
random forest classifier right here this
is a code that does everything and we're
going to take our training set
remember we kept our test off to the
side and we're going to take our
training set
with the features and then we're going
to go ahead and put that in and here's
our target
the y so the y is 0 1 and 2
that we just created and the features is
the actual
data going in that we put into the
training set
let's go ahead and run that and this is
kind of an interesting thing because
it printed out the random force
classifier
and everything around it and so when
you're running this in your
terminal window on a script like this
this automatically treats us like just
like when we were up here
and i typed in y and printed out y
instead of print y
this does the same thing it treats this
as a variable and prints it out
but if you're actually running your code
that wouldn't be the case
and what is printed out is it shows us
all the different
variables we can change and if we go
down here you can actually see in jobs
equals two you can see the random state
equals zero those are the two that we
sent in there
you would really have to dig deep to
find out all these
different meanings of all these
different settings on here some of them
are self-explanatory if you kind of
think about it a little bit like max
features is auto
so all the features that we're putting
in there is just going to automatically
take all four of them
whatever we send it it'll take some of
them might have so many features
because you're processing words there
might be like 1.4 million features in
there because you're doing legal
documents and that's how many different
words are in there
at that point you probably want to limit
the maximum features that you're going
to process
and leaf nodes that's the end nodes
remember we have the fruit and we're
talking about the leaf nodes like i said
there's a lot in this
we're looking at a lot of stuff here so
you might have in this case there's
probably only think three leaf nodes
maybe four
you might have thousands of leaf nodes
at which point you do need to put a cap
on that and say okay it can only go so
far and then we're going to use all of
our resources on processing this
and that really is what most of these
are about is
limiting the process and making sure we
don't uh overwhelm a system
and there's some other settings in here
again we're not going to go over all of
them
warm start equals false warm start is if
you're programming it one piece at a
time
externally since we're not we're not
going to have like we're not going to
continually to train this particular
learning tree
and again like i said there's a lot of
things in here that you'll want to look
up more detail from the sk
learn and if you're digging in deep and
running a major project on here for
today though
all we need to do is fit or train our
features and our target y
so now we have our training model what's
next
if we're going to create a model
we now need to test it remember we set
aside
the test feature test group 25
of the data so let's go ahead and take
this code and let's put it into
our script and see what that looks like
okay here we go
and we're going to run this
and it's going to come out with a bunch
of zeros ones and twos
which represents the three type of
flowers the setosa the virginica and the
versacolor
and what we're putting into our predict
is the test features
and i always kind of like to know what
it is i am looking at
so real quick we're going to do test
features and remember features is an
array
of sepal length simple width pedal
length pedal width
so when we put it in this way it
actually loads all these different
columns that we loaded into features
so if we did just features let me just
do features in here so you can see what
features looks like
this is just playing with the with
pandas data frames
you'll see that it's an index so when
you put an index in like this
into test features into test
it then takes those columns and creates
a panda data frames from those columns
and in this case we're going to go ahead
and put those into our predict
so we're going to put each one of these
lines of data
the 5.0 3.4 1.5 0.2
and we're going to put those in and
we're going to predict what our
new forest classifier is going to come
up with
and this is what it predicts it predicts
0 0 0 1
2 1 1 2 2 2 and and
again this is the flower type setosa
virginica and versacolor
so now that we've taken our test
features
let's explore that let's see exactly
what that data means to us
so the first thing we can do with our
predicts is we can actually generate
a different prediction model when i say
different we're going to view it
differently
it's not that the data itself is
different so let's take this next piece
of code and put it into our script
so we're pasting it in here and you'll
see that we're doing uh
predict and we've added underscore proba
for probability
so there's our clf.predict probability
so we're running it
just like we ran it up here but this
time with this we're going to get a
slightly different result
and we're only going to look at the
first 10. so you'll see down here
instead of looking at all of them
which was what 27 you'll see right down
here
that this generates a much larger field
on the probability
and let's take a look and see what that
looks like and what that means
so when we do the predict underscore
prabha
for probability it generates three
numbers so we had three leaf nodes
at the end and if you remember from all
the theory we did
this is the predictors the first one is
predicting
a 1 for setosa it predicts a
0 for virginica and it predicts a 0 for
versa color and so on and so on and so
on and let's um you know what i'm going
to change this just a little bit
let's look at 10 to 20
just because we can and we start to get
a little different of data and you'll
see right down here
it gets to this one this line right here
and this line has 0
0.5 0.5 and so if we're going to vote
and we have two equal votes it's going
to go with the first one
so it says setosa gets zero votes
virginica gets .5 votes
versus color gets 0.5 votes but let's
just go with the
virginica since these two are equal and
so on and so on down the list
you can see how they vary on here so now
we've looked at both how to do a basic
predict of the features
and we've looked at the predict
probability let's see what's next on
here
so now we want to go ahead and start
mapping names for the plants
we want to attach names so that it makes
a little more sense for us
and this we're going to do in these next
two steps we're going to start
by setting up our predictions
and mapping them to the name so let's
see what that looks like
and let's go ahead and paste that code
in here and run it
and this goes along with the next piece
of code so we'll skip through this
quickly and then come back to a little
bit
so here's iris dot target names
and uh if you remember correctly this
was the
the names that we've been talking about
this whole time the setosa virginica
versus color and then we're going to
go ahead and do the prediction again
we've run we could have just set a
variable equal to this instead of
re-running it each time but we're going
to run it again clf dot predict test
features remember that
returns the zeros the ones and the twos
and then we're going to set that equal
to
predictions so this time we're actually
putting it in a variable
and when i run this it distributes
it it comes out as an array and the
array is setosa satosa satosa
satosa setosa we're only looking at the
first five we could actually do
let's do the first 25 just so we can see
a little bit more on there
and you'll see that it starts mapping it
to all the different flower types the
versacolor and the virginica in there
and let's see how this goes with the
next one
so let's take a look at the top part of
our species in here
and we'll take this code and put it in
our script
and let's put that down here and paste
it there we go and we'll go ahead and
run
it and let's talk about both these
sections of code here
and how they go together the first one
is our predictions and i went ahead and
did uh predictions through 25 let's just
do five
and so we have setosa satoshi satosa
satoshi that's what we're predicting
from our
test model and then we come down here we
look at test
species i remember i could have just
done test.species.head
and you'll see it says setosa satosa
setosa setosa
and they match so the first one is what
our forest is doing and the second one
is what the actual data is now is we
need to combine these so that we can
understand what that means we need to
know how good our forest is how good it
is at predicting the features
so that's where we come up to the next
step which is lots of fun
we're going to use a single line of code
to combine our predictions and our
actuals
so we have a nice chart to look at and
let's go ahead and put that in our
script in our jupyter notebook here
let's see let's go ahead and paste that
in and then i'm gonna
because i'm on the jupiter notebook i
can do a control minus so you can see
the whole line there
there we go resize it and let's take a
look and see what's going on here
we're going to create in pandas remember
pd stands for pandas
and we're doing a cross tab this
function takes two sets of data
and creates a chart out of them so when
i run it you'll get a nice chart down
here
and we have the predicted species
so across the top you'll see the setosa
versus color virginica
and the actual species setosa versacolor
virginica
and so the way to read this chart and
let's go ahead and take a look on how to
read this chart here
when you read this chart you have setosa
where they meet
you have versus color where they meet
and you have virginica where they meet
and they're meeting where the actual and
the predicted agree
so this is the number of accurate
predictions so in this case it equals
30.
if you had 13 plus 5 plus 12 you get 30.
and then we notice here
where it says virginica but it was
supposed to be versa color this is
inaccurate
so now we have two two inaccurate
predictions
and 30 accurate predictions so we'll say
that the model accuracy
is 93 that's just 30 divided by 32
and if we multiply it by a hundred we
can say that it
is 93 accurate so we have a 93
accuracy with our model i did want to
add one more quick thing in here on our
scripting
before we wrap it up so let's flip back
on over to my script
in here we're going to take this line of
code from up above
i don't know if you remember it but
predix equals the iris.target underscore
names
so we're going to map it to the names
and we're going to run the prediction
and we read it on test features
but you know we're not just testing it
we want to actually deploy it
so at this point i would go ahead and
change this
and this is an array of arrays this is
really important when you're running
these to know that
so you need the double brackets and i
could actually create
data maybe let's just do two flowers so
maybe i'm processing more data coming in
and we'll put two flowers in here and
then
i actually want to see what the answer
are is so let's go ahead and
type in preds and print that out and
when i run this
you'll see that i've now predicted two
flowers that maybe i measured in my
front yard as
versacolor and versacolor
not surprising since they put the same
data in for each one
this would be the actual end product
going out to be used on data that you
don't know the answer for
so that's going to conclude our
scripting part of this today we're going
to cover
the k nearest neighbors let's refer to
as k n
n and k n is really a fundamental place
to start in the machine learning
it's the basis of a lot of other things
and just the logic behind it is easy to
understand and incorporated
in other forms of machine learning so
today what's in it for you
why do we need k n n what is k n
how do we choose the factor k when do we
use
k knn how does knn algorithm work
and then we'll dive in to my favorite
part the use case
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set
as far as testing out models and
learning how to use the different models
in machine learning
by now we all know machine learning
models make predictions by learning from
the past data available
so we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know
and then we use that to create a
predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there watching the black cat cross their
path
no dear you can differentiate between a
cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws
how sharp are their claws and we can
evaluate the length of the ears
and we can usually sort out cats from
dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now
unless they live a place where there's
not many cats or dogs so if we look at
the sharpness of the claws the length of
the ears
and we can see that the cat has smaller
ears
and sharper claws than the other animals
its features are more like cats
it must be a cat sharp claws length of
ears and goes in the cat group
because knn is based on feature
similarity we can do classification
using knn classifier
so we have our input value the picture
of the black cat it goes into our
trained model
and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so
what is knn what is the k n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest
supervised machine learning algorithms
mostly used for classification
so we want to know is this a dog or is
not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified
knn stores all available cases and
classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
we gone from cats and dogs right into
wine another favorite of mine k n stores
all available cases
and classifies new cases based on a
similarity measure
and here you see we have a measurement
of sulfur dioxide
versus the chloride level and then the
different wines they've tested and where
they fall on that graph based on how
much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and k n
is a perimeter that refers to the number
of nearest neighbors to include in the
majority of the voting process
and so if we add a new glass of wine
there red or white
we want to know what the neighbors are
in this case we're going to put
k equals 5. we'll talk about k in just a
minute a data point is classified by the
majority of votes from its five
nearest neighbors here the unknown point
would be classified as red
since four out of five neighbors are red
so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it
how do we choose a factor k k n
algorithm is based on feature similarity
choosing the right value of k is a
process called
parameter tuning and is important for
better accuracy
so at k equals three we can classify we
have a question mark in the middle
as either a as a square or not is it a
square or is it
in this case a triangle and so if we set
k equals to three we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors
we're going to say this is a square and
if we put k equals to 7 we classify as
a triangle depending on what the other
data is around and you can see as the k
changes depending on where that point is
that drastically changes your answer
and we jump here we go how do we choose
the factor of k
you'll find this in all machine learning
choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k
did i set it right my values in whatever
machine learning tool you're looking at
so that you don't have a huge bias
in one direction or the other and in
terms of k n
n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on
it's just two noises it's it's right
next to a couple things and it's going
to pick
those things and you might get a skewed
answer and if your k is too
big then it's going to take forever to
process
so you're going to run into processing
issues and resource issues
so what we do the most common use and
there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n
so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it
in most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using
like this case squares and triangles if
it's even you want to make your
k value odd that helps it select better
so
in other words you're not going to have
a balance between two different factors
that are equal so usually take the
square root of n
and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it
and that's where you get the k value
from that is the most common use and
it's pretty solid
it works very well when do we use k n n
we can use k n when data is labeled so
you need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats
data is noise free and so you can see
here
when we have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 hello kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and
that would cause an issue data set is
small so we're usually working with
smaller data sets where
you might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean
doesn't have a lot of noise because k n
is a lazy learner i.e it doesn't learn a
discriminative function from the
training set
so it's very lazy so if you have very
complicated data and you have a large
amount of it you're not going to use the
knn
but it's really great to get a place to
start even with large data
you can sort out a small sample and get
an idea of what that looks like using
the knn
and also just using for smaller data
sets k n works really good
how does a k n algorithm work consider a
data set having two variables
height in centimeters and weight in
kilograms
and each point is classified as normal
or underweight
so we see right here we have two
variables you know true false they're
either normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn
so if we have new data coming in this
says 57 kilograms
and 177 centimeters is that going to be
normal or underweight
to find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by
distance d equals the square root of
x minus a squared plus y minus b squared
and you can remember that from the two
edges of a triangle we're computing the
third edge since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand
clearly so we have our unknown point and
we placed it there in red
and we have our other points where the
data is scattered around the distance
d1 is the square root of 170 minus 167
squared plus 57 minus 51 squared
which is about 6.7 and distance
2 is about 13. and distance 3 is about
13.4
similarly we will calculate the
euclidean distance of unknown data point
from
all the points in the data set and
because we're dealing with small amount
of data that's not that hard to do it's
actually pretty quick for a computer and
it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance
hence we have calculated the euclidean
distance of unknown data point from all
the points as shown where x1
and y1 equal 57 and 170
whose class we have to classify so now
we're looking at that we're saying well
here's the euclidean
distance who's going to be their closest
neighbors now let's calculate the
nearest neighbor at k equals three
and we can see the three closest
neighbors puts them at
normal and that's pretty self-evident
when you look at this graph it's pretty
easy to say okay what we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight
so majority of neighbors are pointing
towards normal hence as per k
n algorithm the class of 57 170 should
be normal
so recap of knn positive integer k
is specified along with a new sample we
select the k
entries in our database which are
closest to the new sample
we find the most common classification
of these entries this is the
classification we give to the new sample
so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got
so let's take a look and see what that
looks like in a use case
in python so let's dive into the predict
diabetes use case
so use case predict diabetes the
objective
predict whether a person will be
diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were
or were not diagnosed with diabetes and
let's go ahead and open that file and
just take a look at that data
and this is in a simple spreadsheet
format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have
columns a through i that's what one two
three four
five six seven eight eight columns
with a particular attribute and then the
ninth column which is the outcome is
whether they have diabetes
as a data scientist the first thing you
should be looking at is insulin well you
know if someone has insulin
they have diabetes because that's why
they're taking it and that could cause
issue in some of the machine learning
packages
but for a very basic setup this works
fine for
doing the k n and the next thing you
notice is it didn't take very much to
open it up
i can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this
into my ram on my computer i can look at
it
i can manipulate it and it's not going
to really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss
what ide i'm using certainly can use any
particular editor for python but i like
to use for doing uh
very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos
with the jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the anaconda
navigator which is the new release out
there which is really nice
you can see under home i can choose my
application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments
i can create a unique environment for
each one which is nice
and there's even a little button there
where i can install different packages
so if i click on that button and open
the terminal i can then use a simple pip
install to install different packages
i'm working with let's go ahead and go
back under home and we're going to
launch our notebook
and i've already you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up
a browser window in this case i'm going
to it's going to open up chrome because
that's my default that i use
and since the script is pre-done you'll
see i have a number of windows open up
at the top the one we're working in
and since we're working on the k n
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not let's go and put that
title in there
and i'm also going to go up here and
click on cell
actually we want to go ahead and first
insert a cell below and then i'm going
to go back up
to the top cell and i'm going to change
the cell type to markdown
that means this is not going to run as
python it's a markdown language
so if i run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice
remind us what we're working on and by
now you should be familiar with doing
all of our imports
we're going to import the pandas as pd
import
numpy is np pandas is the pandas data
frame and numpy is a number array
very powerful tools to use in here so we
have our imports
so we've brought in our pandas our numpy
our two general python
tools and then you can see over here we
have our trained test split
by now you should be familiar with
splitting the data we want to split part
of it for training our thing and then
training our particular model and then
we want to go ahead and test the
remaining data to see how good it is
pre-processing a standard scalar
preprocessor
so we don't have a bias of really large
numbers remember in the data we had like
number of pregnancies isn't going to get
very large where the amount of insulin
they take can get up to 256 so 256
versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so
they're all uniform between minus one
and one and then the actual tool
this is the k neighbors classifier we're
going to use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test
all about testing our model how good is
it we just put down test on there and we
have our confusion matrix
our f1 score and our accuracy so we have
our two general
python modules we're importing and then
we have our six
modules specific from the sk learn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this
so these are actually imported there we
go and then move on to the next step
and so in this set we're going to go
ahead and load the database we're going
to use pandas remember pandas is pd
and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing
so here's our data set equals pd.read
csv
that's a pandas command and the diabetes
folder i just put in the same folder
where my
ipython script is if you put in a
different folder you need the full
length on there we can also do a quick
length of
the data set that is a simple python
command len for length
we might even let's go ahead and print
that we'll go print and if you do it on
its own line
link that data set the jupyter notebook
it'll automatically print it
but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there if you put a bunch of
these in a row
you know the data set 1 head data set 2
head it only prints out the last one
so i use always like to keep the print
statement in there but because
most projects only use one data frame
panda's data frame
doing it this way doesn't really matter
the other way works just fine
and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew
and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines
so we have zero through four and just a
quick look at the data you can see it
matches what we looked at before we have
pregnancy glucose blood pressure all the
way to
age and then the outcome on the end and
we're going to do a couple things in
this next step
we're going to create a list of columns
where we can't have zero
there's no such thing as zero skin
thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead
so not a really good factor if they
don't if they have a zero in there
because they didn't have the data
and we'll take a look at that because
we're going to start replacing that
information
with a couple of different things and
let's see what that looks like
so first we create a nice list as you
can see we have the values talked about
glucose blood pressure skin thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on
a very common thing to do and then for
this particular setup we certainly could
use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead
and do it as a data set column equals
dataset column.replace this is this is
still
pandas you can do a direct there's also
one that's that you look for your nan
a lot of different options in here but
the nan in numpy nan is what that stands
for
is none it doesn't exist so the first
thing we're doing here
is we're replacing the zero with a numpy
none there's no data there that's what
that says that's what this is saying
right here
so put the zero in and we're going to
place zeros with
no data so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead hope
they just didn't get the data the next
thing we want to do is we're going to
create the mean
which is the integer from the data set
from the column
dot mean where we skip n a's we can do
that
that is a pandas command there the skip
n a so we're going to figure out the
mean of that data set
and then we're going to take that data
set column and we're going to replace
all the npn with the means
why did we do that we could have
actually just taken this step and gone
right down here and just replaced zero
and skip anything where
except you could actually there's a way
to skip zeros and then just replace all
the zeros but in this case we want to go
ahead and do it this way so you could
see that we're switching this to a
non-existent value then we're going to
create the mean
well this is the average person so
if we don't know what it is if they did
not get the data and the data is missing
one of the tricks is you replace it with
the average what is the most common
data for that this way you can still use
the rest of those values to do your
computation
and it kind of just brings that
particular value of those missing values
out of the equation let's go ahead and
take this and we'll go ahead and run it
doesn't actually do anything so we're
still preparing our data
if you want to see what that looks like
we don't have anything in the first few
lines just not going to show up but we
certainly could look at a row
let's do that let's go into our data set
with printed data set
and let's pick in this case let's just
do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels
going down and we thankfully don't see
anything in here that looks like
missing data at least on the ones it
shows you can see i skipped a bunch in
the middle
that's what it does if you have too many
lines in jupiter notebook he'll skip a
few and
go on to the next in a data set let me
go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing
data that way we have something to train
it with and something to test it on
and you're going to notice we did a
little something here with the pandas
database code
there we go my drawing tool we've added
in this right here off the data set
and what this says is that the first one
in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set
we want to look at the eye location and
it is all rows that's what that says so
we're going to keep all the rows but
we're only looking at
0 column 0 to 8. remember column 9
here it is right up here we put it in
here is outcome well that's not part of
the training data that's part of the
answer
yes column 9 but it's listed as 8 number
8
so 0 to eight is nine columns so uh
eight is the value and when you see it
in
here zero this is actually zero to seven
it doesn't include the last one and then
we go down here to y which is our answer
and we want just the last one just
column eight
and you can do it this way with this
particular notation and then if you
remember we imported the
train test split that's part of the sk
learn
right there and we simply put in our x
and our y
we're gonna do random state equals zero
you don't have to necessarily seat it
that's a seed number i think the default
is one when you see it i have to look
that up
and then the test size test size is 0.2
that simply means we're going to take 20
of the data and put it aside so that we
can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data
but that is a lot of this is prepping
this data once you prep it the actual
lines of code are quick and easy
and we're almost there but the actual
writing of our knn we need to go ahead
and do a scale the data
if you remember correctly we're fitting
the data in a standard scalar which
means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303
in one column and the next column is one
to six
we're going to set that all so that all
the data is between minus one
and one that's what that standard scalar
does keeps it standardized
and we only want to fit the scalar with
the training set
but we want to make sure the testing set
is the x test going in
is also transformed so it's processing
it the same
so here we go with our standard scalar
we're going to call it sc underscore x
for the scalar
and we're going to import the standard
scalar into this variable and then
our x train equals sc underscore x dot
fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x
train variable and then our x test we're
also going to transform it
so we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x
test isn't part of that training it
isn't part of that of training the
transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to run this
and if you look at this we've now gone
through these
steps all three of them we've taken care
of replacing our zeros
for key columns that shouldn't be zero
and we replace that with the means of
those columns
that way that they fit right in with our
data models we've come down here we
split the data
so now we have our test data and our
training data and then we've taken and
we scaled the data
so all of our data going in no no we
don't tr we don't train the
y part the y train and y test that never
has to be trained it's only the data
going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data
in the model so we do all that data prep
and you can see down here we're only
going to have a couple lines of code
where we're actually building our model
and training it
that's one of the cool things about
python and how far we've come it's such
an exciting time to be in machine
learning because there's so many
automated tools
let's see before we do this let's do a
quick length of
and let's do y we want let's just do
length of y
and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root
let's do y train there we go it's
actually supposed to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do
math square root length of y test and
when i run that we get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use
12 is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote
don't want to have an even number of
neighbors voting so we want to do
something odd
and let's just take one away we'll make
it 11. let me delete this out of here
this one the reasons i love jupiter
notebook is you can flip around and do
all kinds of things on the fly
so we'll go ahead and put in our
classifier we're creating our classifier
now and it's going to be the k
neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11. remember we did 12 minus 1
for 11. we have an odd number of
neighbors p equals 2
because we're looking for is it are the
diabetic or not
and we're using the euclidean metric
there are other
means of measuring the distance you
could do like square square means values
all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well
it's important to evaluate the model
let's use the confusion matrix to do
that
and we're going to use the confusion
matrix wonderful tool
and then we'll jump into the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most
commonly used quoted number when you go
into a meeting or something like that
so let's go ahead and paste that in
there and we'll set the cm
equal to confusion matrix why test y
predict
so those are the two values we're going
to put in there and let me go ahead and
run that and print it out
and the way you interpret this is you
have the y
predicted which would be your title up
here you could do
let's just do p r e d predicted across
the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to to write in here
actual that means that
this column here down the middle that's
the important column and it means that
our prediction
said 94 and prediction in the actual
agreed on 94
and 32. this number here
the 13 and the 15 those are what was
wrong
so you could have like three different
if you're looking at this across three
different variables instead of just two
you'd end up with the third row down
here and that column going down the
middle
so in the first case we have the the and
i believe the
zero is in 94 people who don't have
diabetes
the prediction said that 13 of those
people did have diabetes and were at
high risk
and the 32 that had diabetes it had
correct
but our prediction said another 15
out of that 15 it classified as
incorrect
so you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix
then we're going to go ahead and print
the f1 score let me just run that
and you see we get a .69 in our f1 score
the f1 takes into account
both sides of the balance of false
positives
where if we go ahead and just do the
accuracy account
and that's what most people think of is
it looks at just
how many we got right out of how many we
got wrong so a lot of people when you're
data scientist
and you're talking to other data
scientists they're going to ask you what
the f1 score the f score is
if you're talking to the general public
or the
decision makers in the business they're
going to ask what the accuracy is and
the accuracy is always better than
the f1 score but the f1 score is more
telling it lets us know that there's
more false positives than we would like
on here but 82 percent
not too bad for a quick flash look at
people's different
statistics and running an sk learn and
running the knn
the k nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using knn
which can predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not
or at the very least whether they should
go get a checkup and have their
glucose checked regularly or not the
print accuracy score we got the 0.818
was pretty close to what we got and we
can pretty much round that off and just
say we have an
accuracy of 80 percent tells us it is a
pretty fair fit in the model
so far so clear but a question should be
coming up
we have our sample data set but instead
of looking like this
what if it looked like this where we
have two sets of data
but one of them occurs in the middle of
another set you can see here where we
have the blue and the yellow
and then blue again on the other side of
our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyperplane so when you
see data like
this it's necessary to move away from a
1d view of the data
to a two-dimensional view of the data
and for the transformation we use what's
called a
kernel function the kernel function will
take the 1d
input and transfer it to a
two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1d when transferred to a two-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets
what if we make it even more complicated
how do we perform an svm for this type
of data set
here you can see we have a two
dimensional data set where the data is
in the middle
surrounded by the green data on the
outside in this case we're going to
segregate the two classes we have our
sample data set
and if you draw a line through it's
obviously not an optimal hyperplane in
there so to do that
we need to transfer the 2d to a 3d array
and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a
hyperplane right through it and easily
split the data before we start looking
at a programming example and dive into
the script
let's look at the advantage of the
support vector machine we'll start with
high dimensional
input space or sometimes referred to as
the curse of dimensionality we looked at
earlier one dimension two dimension
three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for
the svm automatically does that in high
dimensional space
one of the high dimensional space one
high dimensional space that we work on
is sparse document vectors
this is where we tokenize the words and
document so we can run our machine
learning algorithms over them i've seen
ones get as high as 2.4 million
different tokens that's a lot of vectors
to look at
and finally we have regularization
parameter the regulation parameter or
lambda
is a parameter that helps figure out
whether we're going to have a bias or
overfitting of the data whether it's
going to be overfitted to a very
specific instance or is going to be
biased to a high or low value
with the svm it naturally avoids the
overfitting and bias problems that we
see in many other algorithms
these three advantages of the support
vector machine make it a very powerful
tool to add to your repertoire
of machine learning tools now we did
promise you a used case study we're
actually going to dive into some python
programming and so we're going to go
into a problem statement and start off
with the zoo
so in the zoo example we have family
members going to the zoo
we have the young child going dead is
that a group of crocodiles or alligators
well that's hard to differentiate
and zoos are a great place to start
looking at science and understanding how
things work
especially as a young child and so we
can see the parents sitting here
thinking well what is the difference
between a crocodile and an alligator
well one crocodiles are larger in size
alligators are smaller in size snout
width the crocodiles have a narrow snout
and alligators have a wider snout
and of course in the modern day and age
the father is sitting here thinking how
can i turn this into a lesson for my son
and he goes let a support vector machine
segregate the two groups i don't know if
my dad ever told me that but that would
be funny now in this example
we're not going to use actual
measurements and data we're just using
that for imagery and that's very common
in a lot of machine learning algorithms
and setting them up but let's roll up
our sleeves and we'll talk about that
more in just a moment
as we break into our python script so
here we arrive
in our actual coding and i'm going to
move this into
a python editor in just a moment but
let's talk a little bit about what we're
going to cover
first we're going to cover in the code
the setup how to actually create our svm
and you're going to find that there's
only two lines of code that actually
create it and the rest of it is done
so quick and fast that it's all here in
the first page
and we'll show you what that looks like
as far as our data because we're going
to create some data i talked about
creating data just a minute ago and so
we'll get into the creating data here
and you'll see this nice correction of
our two blobs and we'll go through that
in just
a second and then the second part is
we're going to take this and we're going
to
bump it up a notch we're going to show
you what it looks like behind the scenes
but let's start with actually creating
our setup i like to use the
anaconda jupiter notebook because it's
very easy to use but you can use any of
your favorite python editors
or setups and go in there but let's go
ahead and switch over there and see what
that looks like
so here we are in the anaconda python
notebook or anaconda jupiter notebook
with python we're using
python 3. i believe this is 3.5 but it
should be work
in any of your 3x versions and you'd
have to look at the sklearn and make
sure if you're using
a 2x version an earlier version let's go
and put our code in there
and one of the things i like about the
jupiter notebook is i go up to view
and i'm going to go ahead and toggle the
line numbers on to make it a little bit
easier
to talk about and we can even increase
the size because this is edited
in this case i'm using google chrome
explorer and that's how it opens up for
the editor
although anyone any like i said any
editor will work now the first step is
going to be our imports
and we're going to import four different
parts the first two i want you to look
at are line one and line two
are numpy as np and matplot
matplotlibrary.pipelot as
plt now these are very standardized
imports when you're doing work the first
one is the numbers python
we need that because part of the
platform we're using uses that for the
numpy array
and i'll talk about that in a minute so
you can understand why we want to use a
numpy array versus the standard python
array
and normally it's pretty standard setup
to use np
for numpy the map plot library is how
we're going to view our data
so this has uh you do need the np for
the sk learn module but the map plot
library is purely for our use for
visualization
and so you really don't need that for
the svm but we're going to put it there
so you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like
that's really important at the end when
you finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at
and then finally we're gonna i'm gonna
jump one ahead to
line number four that's the
sklearn.datasets.samplesgenerator
import make blobs and i told you that we
were going to make up data
and this is a tool that's in the sk
learning to make up data i personally
don't want to go to the zoo
get in trouble for jumping over the
fence and probably get eaten by the
crocodiles or alligators as i work on
measuring their snouts and width and
length instead we're just going to make
up some data
and that's what that make blobs is it's
a wonderful tool if you're
ready to test your your setup and you're
not sure about what data you're going to
put in there you can create this blob
and it makes it real easy to use
and finally we have our actual svm the
sklearn
import svm on line three so that covers
all our
imports we're going to create remember i
use the make blobs to create data
and we're going to create a capital x
and a lowercase y
equals make blobs in samples equals 40.
so we're going to make 40 lines of data
it's going to have two centers with a
random state equals 20. so which
each each group is going to have 20
different pieces of data in it
and the way that looks is that we'll
have under x
an x y plane so i have two numbers under
x
and y will be 0 1 that's the two
different centers
so we have yes or no in this case
alligator or crocodile
that's what that represents and then i
told you that the actual
sk learner the svm is in two lines of
code
and we see it right here with clf equals
svm
dot svc kernel equals linear and i set
sql to one although in this example
since we are not
regularizing the data because we want to
be very clear and easy to see
i went ahead you can set it to a
thousand a lot of times when you're not
doing that but for this thing
linear because it's a very simple linear
example we only have the two dimensions
and it'll be a nice linear hyperplane
it'll be a nice linear line
instead of a full plane so we're not
dealing with a huge amount of data
and then all we have to do is do clf dot
fit
x comma y and that's it clf has been
created
and then we're going to go ahead and
display it and i'm going to talk about
this display here in just a second
but let me go ahead and run this code
and this is what we've done is we've
created
two blobs you'll see the blue on the
side and then kind of an
orangish on the other side that's our
two sets of data they represent one
represents crocodiles and one represents
alligators and then we have our
measurements in this case we have like
the
width and length of the snout and i did
say i was going to come up here and talk
just a little bit about our plot
and you'll see plt that's what we
imported we're going to do a scatter
plot
that means we're just putting dots on
there and then look at this notation i
have the capital x
and then in brackets i have a colon
comma 0. that's from
numpy if you did that in a regular array
you'll get an error in a python array
you have to have that in a numpy array
it turns out that our make blobs returns
a numpy array and this notation is great
because what it means is
the first part is the colon means we're
going to do all the rows that's all the
data in our blob we created under
capital x
and then the second part has a comma
zero we're only going to take the first
value and then if you notice we do the
same thing but we're going to take
the second value remember we always
start with zero and then one
so we have column zero and column one
and you can look at this
as our xy plots the first one is the x
plot and the second one is the y
plot so the first one is on the bottom 0
2
4 6 8 and 10 and then the second one
x of the one is the 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 going
up the left hand side
s equals 30 is just the size of the dot
so we can see them and said little tiny
dots
and then the c map equals plt.cm.paired
and you'll also see the c equals y
that's the color
we're using two colors zero one and
that's why we get the nice blue
and the two different colors for the
alligator and the crocodile now you can
see here that we did this the actual uh
fit was done in two lines of code
a lot of times there'll be a third line
where we regularize the data we set it
between like minus one and one and we
reshape it but for this it's not
necessary
and it's also kind of nice because you
can actually see what's going on
and then if we wanted to we wanted to
actually run a prediction let's take a
look and see what that looks
like and to predict some new data and
we'll show this again
as we get towards the end of digging in
deep you can simply assign your new data
in this case i'm giving it a width and
length 3
4 and a width and length 5 6 and note
that i put the data
as a set of brackets and then i have the
brackets inside
and the reason i do that is because when
we're looking at data
it's designed to process a large amount
of data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time
and so in this case i'm processing two
lines and then i'm just going to print
and you'll see
clf dot predict new data so the clf
and the dot predict part is going to
give us an answer and let's see what
that looks like
and you'll see 0 one so predicted the
first one the three four is going to be
on
the one side and the five six is going
to be on the other side so one came out
as an alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation
for the setup but really we want to dug
in and see what's going on behind the
scenes
and let's see what that looks like so
the next step is to dig in deep
and find out what's going on behind the
scenes and also put that in a nice
pretty graph
we're going to spend more work on this
and we did actually generating the
original model
and you'll see here that we go through a
few steps and i'll move this over to our
editor in just a second
we come in we create our original data
it's exactly identical to the first part
and i'll explain
why we redid that and show you how not
to redo that
and then we're going to go in there and
add in those lines
we're going to see what those lines look
like and how to set those up
and finally we're going to plot all that
on here and show it and you'll get a
nice graph
with the what we saw earlier when we
were going through the theory behind
this
where it shows the support vectors and
the hyperplane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dashed lines and
the solid line which is the hyperplane
let's get that into our jupiter notebook
before i scroll down to a new line
i want you to notice line 13 has plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here
and i'm going to paste that code in and
you'll see that the plot show has moved
down below
let's scroll up a little bit and if you
look at the top here of our new section
one two three and four is the same code
we had before
and let's go back up here and take a
look at that we're gonna fit the values
on our svm and then we're going to plot
scatter it
and then we're going to do a plot show
so you should be asking why are we
redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot
so once i've done this plot show i have
to reload that data
now we could do this simply by removing
it up here re-running it
and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code
now in this it doesn't matter too much
and you'll see the plot show was down
here and then removed
right there on line five i'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there
because we don't want to blank out
our screen we want to move on to the
next setup so we can go ahead and just
skip the first four lines because we did
that before
and let's take a look at the ax equals
plt.gca
now right now we're actually spending a
lot of time just graphing that's all
we're doing here
okay so this is how we display a nice
graph with our
results in our data ax is a very
standard node used variable when you
talk about plt
and it's just setting it to that axis
the last axis in the plt
it can get very confusing if you're
working with many different layers of
data on the same graph
and this makes it very easy to reference
the ax so this
reference is looking at the plt that we
created and we already mapped out our
two blobs on
and then we want to know the limits so
we want to know how big the graph is
we can find out the x limit and the y
limit simply with the
get x limit and get y limit commands
which is part of our metplot
library and then we're going to create a
grid and you'll see down here we have
we've set the variable xx equal to
np.line space
x limit 0 x limit one comma thirty and
we've done the same thing for the y
space and then we're gonna go in here
and we create a
mesh grid and this is a numpy command so
we're back to
our numbers python let's go through what
these numpy commands mean
with the line space in the mesh grid
we've taken x
x small x x equals np line space
and we have our x limit 0 and our x
limit 1
and we're going to create 30 points on
it and we're going to do the same thing
for the y
axis now this has nothing to do with our
evaluation
it's all we're doing is we're creating a
grid
of data and so we're creating a set of
points between 0
and the x limit we're creating 30 points
and the same thing with the y
and then the mesh grid loops those all
together so it forms a nice grit
so if we were going to do this say
between the limit 0 and 10 and do 10
points
we would have a 0 0 1 1 0 1
0 2 0 3 0 4 to 10 and so on you can just
imagine a point
at each corner one of those boxes and
the mesh grid combines them all so we
take the yy and the xx we created and
creates the full grid
and we've set that grid into the yy
coordinates and the xx coordinates
now remember we're working with numbi
and python we like to separate those we
like to have instead of it being
x comma 1 you know x comma y
and then x 2 comma y 2 and this in the
next set of data it would be
a column of x's and a column of y's and
that's what we have here is we have a
column of y's and we put it as a capital
y y
and a column of x's capital x x with all
those different points being listed
and finally we get down to the numpy v
stack
just as we created those in the mesh
grid we're now going to put them all
into
one array x y array now that we've
created the stack of data points
we're going to do something interesting
here we're going to create a value
z and the z equals the clf
that's our that's our support vector
machine we created
and we've already trained and we have a
dot decision
function we're going to put the x y in
there so here we have all this data
we're going to put that x
y in there that data and we're going to
reshape it and you'll see that we have
the xx dot
shape in here this literally takes the
xx
resets it up connected to the y and the
z
value lets us know whether it is the
left hand side it's going to generate
three different values the z
value does and it'll tell us whether
that data is
a support vector to the left the
hyperplane in the middle
or the support vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points
and those points have been reshaped so
they're right on a line on those three
different lines
so we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas
and we've reshaped it and we've just
taken 30 points in each direction
if you do the math you have 30 times 30
so that's 900 points of data and we
separated between the three lines and
reshaped it to fit those three lines
we can then go back to our map plot
library we've created the ax
and we're going to create a contour and
you'll see here we have contour
capital xx capital yy these have been
reshaped to fit those lines
z is the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there
and we can set the colors equals k and i
told you we had three different labels
but we have
three levels of data the alphas just
makes it kind of see through so it's
only 0.5 of the value in there so when
we graph it the data will show up from
behind it wherever the lines go
and finally the line styles this is
where we set the
two support vectors to be dash dash
lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does
and then finally we take our ax dot
scatter
we're going to go ahead and plot the
support vectors but we've programmed it
in there so that they look nice like the
dash dash line and the dashed line
on that grid and you can see here when
we do the clf
dot support vectors we are looking at
column 0
and column 1 and then again we have the
s equals 100 so we're going to make them
larger and the line width equals 1
face colors equals none let's take a
look and see what that looks like when
we show it
and you can see we get down to our end
result it creates
a really nice graph we have our two
support vectors and dashed lines
and they have the near data so you can
see those two points or in this case the
four points where those lines
nicely cleave the data and then you have
your hyperplane down the middle
which is as far from the two different
points as possible creating the maximum
distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout
and we've easily separated the two
groups of crocodile and alligator
congratulations you've done it we've
made it of course these are pretend
data for our crocodiles and alligators
but this hands-on example will help you
to encounter
any support vector machine projects in
the future and you can see how easy they
are to set up
and look at in depth regularization in
machine learning so
our agenda on this one is fitting the
data
understanding linear regression bias and
variance what is overfitting
what is underfitting and those are like
the biggest things right now in data
science is overfitting and under fitting
what does that mean and what is
regularization
and then we'll do a quick hands-on demo
to take a look at this
so fitting the data let's start with
fitting the data
and we talk about what is data fitting
it's a process of plotting
a series of data points and drawing the
best fit line
to understand the relationship between
the variables and this is what we called
data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph
we're going to go in a little deeper on
there so we might have
in this case just to two dimensions we
have an efficiency of the car
and we have the distance traveled in 1
000 kilometers
and so what is data fitting well it's a
linear relationship
and a linear relationship very
specifically
linear means line the line used to
represent
the relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points
and the variables have linear
relationship
linear regression so let's start with
how linear regression works a linear
regression
finds a line that best fits the data
point and gives a relationship between
the two variables
and so you can see here we have the
efficiency of the car
versus the distance traveled and you can
see this nice straight line drawn
through there
and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line that now becomes
a plane
it gets a little more complicated with
multiple variables but they all come
down to
this linear kind of drawing a line
through your data and finding
what fits the the data the best
and so we can consider an example uh
let's say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream
and we're looking at how warm it is
outside which would hopefully draw
a lot of people into the ice cream store
and suppose we have two lines we're
going to draw
l1 and l2 and we're going to kind of
guess which one we think is the best fit
and which claim to describe the
relationship between the variables
and so first we find the square of the
distance between the line l1
and each data point and add them all and
find the mean
distance and i want you to think about
that when we
square something if it's a negative or
positive number it no longer matters
because a minus
2 squared is 4 2 squared is 4. so we're
removing
what side of the line is on and we're
just looking for the error
in this case the mean distance of each
of the little dotted lines you see here
this way of calculating the square of
the distance adding them and then taking
the mean is called
mean square error or loss function
and we talk about loss how far off are
we that's what we're really talking
about what did we miss
and we have a positive distance and a
negative distance and of course when we
square it it is neither
it just becomes a positive error
and so we take the mean square error and
a lot of times you'll see it referred to
as
mse if i look in the code and i'm going
through my python code and i see mse
i know that's a mean squared error and
we take all the dotted lines and we
calculate
this error we add them all together and
then we average it
or find the means and in this case
they ran a demo on this and it was uh
1127.27
for our l1 line now we find the loss
function for
line l2 in a similar fashion and we get
the mean square error
to be 6397
and it's computed the same way so maybe
you put this line just way outside the
data range and this is the error you get
by analyzing our results we find that
the loss function
or the mean square error is less for l1
than l2 hence l1 is the best
fit line this process
describes a lot of machine learning
processes it was we're going to keep
guessing and get as close as we can
to find the right answer we have to have
some way to invite
to calculate this and figure out which
one's the best
and the mean square error is one of the
better fits to doing for doing this and
most commonly used
we really want to talk about bias and
variance
very important terms to know in machine
learning
and with linear regression
so bias bias occurs when an algorithm
has limited flexibility to learn from
data
variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific
sets of data let's start with
bias and variance you can see here we
have the two different
setups bias you can think is very
generalized where variance is very
specific
and so we talk about bias such models
pay very little attention to the
training data and over
simplify the model therefore the
validation error or prediction error
and training error follow similar trends
and uh with bias if you over simplify it
so much
you're going to miss your local
uh if if you have like a really good fit
you're going to miss it
you're you're going to just kind of
guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to be
with variance a model with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not
generalize therefore the validation
error or prediction error are far apart
from
each other such models always lead to a
high
error on training and test data as a
bias does
where variants such models usually
perform very well on training data but
have
high error rates on test data and i want
you to think about this
when we're talking about a bias uh the
error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of getting
an average
we're not really fitting it close with
variance we're fitting it so close
that the test data does really good it's
going to
nail it every time if you're doing
categorical testing that's a car that's
a truck that's a bicycle
but with variants suddenly a
truck has to have certain features and
it might have to be red
because you had so many red pictures so
if it has if it's an 18 wheeler it has
to be red
if it's blue then it has to be a bicycle
that's the kind of variance we're
talking about where it picks up on
something
and it cannot get the right answer
unless it gets a very specific
data and we see that so that as you're
testing it your models
and you programmed it you got to look
for how i trained it what is coming out
and if it's not if it's not looking good
on either bias or if it's not looking
good on the training
or on the test data then your
bias then you're biasing your data if it
really looks good
on the training data then that's going
to be your variance
you've over fitted the data and those
are very important things to know when
you
are building your models in regression
of any kind or any kind of setup for
predicting
so in dark games if all the data found a
particular pointer this can be
considered as a biased throw
and the player aims for the particular
score
for variance if all the darts fall on
different pointers and no two darts fall
on the same pointer
then this can be considered as a varied
throw and the player aims for various
scores
again the bias sums everything up in one
point kind of averages it together where
the variance really looks for the
individual
predictions coming out
so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details
along with the noise and the data tries
to fit each data point
on the curve you can see that
if you plug in your coordinates you're
just going to get the whatever
is fitted every point on the data stream
there's no average there's no
two points that might have that you know
why might have two different answers
because
if the wind blows a certain way in the
efficiency of your car maybe you have a
headwind
so your car might alter how efficient it
is as it goes and so there's going to be
this variance on here
and this says no you can't have any
variance with you know the this is it's
going to be exactly this it can't be any
you can't be the same speed or the same
car and have a slightly different
efficiency so
as the model has very less flexibility
it fails to predict
new data points and thus the model
rejects every new data point
during the prediction uh so you'll get
like a really high error on here
and so uh reasons for overfitting data
used for training is not
cleaned and contains noise garbage
values in it you can spend so much time
cleaning your data and it's so important
it's so important that if you have if
you have some kind of
something wrong with the data coming in
it needs to be addressed whether it's a
source of the data
maybe they use in medical different
measuring tools
so you now have to adjust for data that
came in from hospital a versus hospital
b
or even off of machine a and machine b
that's testing something
and those those numbers are coming in
wrong
the model has a high variance again wind
is a good example
i was talking about that with the car
you may have a hundred tests but
because the wind's blowing it's all over
the place
size of training data used is not enough
so a small
amount of data is going to also cause
this problem you only have a few points
and you try to plot everything
the model is too complex this comes up a
lot
we put too many pieces together and how
they interact can't even be tracked
and so you have to go back back break it
up and find out actually what correlates
and what doesn't
so what is under fitting a scenario
where machine learning models can either
learn
the relationship between the data points
nor predict
or classify a new data point and you can
see here we have
our efficiency of our car and our line
drawn and it's just going to be way off
for both the training and the predicting
data
as the model doesn't fully learn the
patterns
it accepts every new data point during
the prediction
so instead of looking for a general
pattern we just kind of accept
everything
data used for training is not cleaned
and contains
noise garbage and values again under
fitting and overfitting
same issue you got to clean your data
the model has a high bias we've seen
this
in all kinds of things from
[Music]
uh the mod the most common is the
driving cars
to facial identification or whatever it
is
the model itself when they build it
might have a bias towards one thing
and this would be an underfitted model
would have that bias because it's
averaged it out
so if you have five people from india
and 10 people from africa
and 20 people from the u.s you created a
bias
because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work with
size of training data used is not enough
that goes with the size i was just
talking about so we have a model with a
high bias we have size of training data
used it's not enough
the model is too simple
again this is one straight line through
all the data when
it needs as a slight shift to it for
other reasons
so what is a good fit a linear curve
that best fits the data is neither
overfitting or under fitting models but
is just
right and of course we have the nice
examples here where we have overfitting
lines going up and down every point is
trying to be include
gluted underfitting the line really is
off
from where the data is and then a good
fit is got to get rid of that minimize
that
error coming through regularization is
taking the guesswork out
you're looking at this graph and you're
going oh which one is that really over
fit or is that under fit
that's pretty hard to tell so we talk
about regularization
regularization techniques are used to
calibrate
the linear regression models and to
minimize the adjusted loss function
and prevent overfitting or under fitting
so what that means in this case we're
going to go ahead and take a look at a
couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the ridge regularization
and the lasso regularization
and these models are just like just like
we did the
mlp the multi-layered positron in the sk
learn
module you could bring in the ridge
module and you can bring in the lasso
module
so when we talk about um
ridge regression it modifies the
overfitted or underfitted models by
adding the penalty equivalent to the sum
of the squares of the magnitude of the
coefficients
and so we have a cost function equals
loss equals
lambda times the sum of w squared or the
absolute value of w depending on how
you're doing it
now remember we talked about error
whether we either square it or we
absolute value it
because that removes a plus or minus
sign on there and there's reasons to do
it either way but it is more common to
square the value
and then we have our in this case the
lambda is going to be the penalty for
the errors we've thrown in a greek
character for you just to confuse
everybody
and w is the slope of the curve of the
line
so uh we're going to look at this and
we're going to draw a line this is going
to be like a linear regression model so
if you had in sk learned you could
import just a standard linear regression
model it would plot this line across
whatever data we're working on
and we look at this of course we're just
extrapolating this i know they use some
specific data
but you don't want to get into the
actual domain and so
for a linear regression line let's
consider two points that are on the line
and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equals zero
considering the two points on the line
we'll go ahead and do lambda equals one
we'll set our w is going to be 1.4
then the cost function equals 0 plus 1
times 1.4 squared which equals 1.96
so really don't get caught up too much
in the math on this
other than understanding um that this is
something that's very easy for a
computer to calculate
and if you ever see the loss plus the
plus the
lambda times w the sum of w squared
and then let's say we have a ridge
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it
and we do the calculations on the data
and for the ridge regression let's
assume a loss equals 0.3 squared plus
0.2 squared equals 0.13 so when they put
all the calculations through
of the two points we end up with the
0.0.62
so we've now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model
and the ridge regression model plots a
little differently than the standard
linear regression model
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
ridge
regression line fits the model more
accurately than the linear regression
line
and i find this true on a lot of data i
work with i'll end up using either the
ridge regression model or the lasso
mars regression model for fitting
especially dealing with a lot of like
stock markets daily setup
they come out slightly better you get a
slightly better
fit and so we have our lasso we just
talked about lasso coming in here
and the cost function equals instead of
doing
a squared we're just going to do the
absolute value and so
if you remember this is where ridge
regression changes where's my ridge
regression model
we're squaring the value here
and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here
and so the loss of this of the squared
individuals
and here is our lambda
symbol again penalty for errors and w
equals the slope of the curve
and comparing the two models with all
the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line
and this is like i said i use these two
models a lot
uh the ridge and this is important this
is
this is kind of the meat of the matter
how do you know which one to use
some of it is you just do it a bunch of
times and then you figure it out
ridge regularization is useful when we
have many variables with relatively
smaller data samples the model does not
encourage convergence towards zero but
is likely to make them closer to zero
and prevent
overfitting the lasso regularization
model
is preferred when we are fitting a
linear model with fewer variables
so in the la in the iris thing we had
four or five variables as we measured
the different leaf pieces
you might be doing the measurements on
the cancer project
which has 36 different variables
so as we get down to the iris with four
variables
lasso lar will probably work pretty good
where you might
use the ridge regularization with more
model with if you have something
significantly larger and it encourages
the coefficients of the variables to go
towards zero
because of the shape of the constraint
which is an absolute
value and with any of this we want to go
ahead
and do a demo and lasso and ridge
regression so let's take a look and see
what that looks like in our code
and bring up our jupiter notebook we'll
start with our imports
pandas is pd import numpy is np import
matplot library as plt
sklearn we're going to import our data
sets it's kind of more generic
we usually just import one data set
instead of all of them but you know
quick and dirty when you're putting some
of these together we have our sklearn
model selection we're going to import
our train test split for splitting our
data up
and then we'll bring in our linear
regression model
and we'll go ahead and run these just to
load them up and then load our data set
we're just talking about that
you could just have imported the load
boston and
boston data set in there instead of
loading all the data sets
um and then once we've loaded our data
set
we want to go ahead and take a look at
that data and
see what we got here let me just go
ahead and pop that down there
and go and run it
and so we've gone ahead and taken our uh
boston
uh data we're gonna look we put it into
our pandas data frame
um the boston data set and then the
boston
columns we want to see what's going on
with them we have our target
we have the house price etc
and so our x equals boston
eye location now remember in pandas
the new updates to pandas they want eye
location
if you're going to pull data we used to
be able to leave this off
but it does something different it
creates a slice versus a direct
setup so make sure using that eye
location and the i the output so this is
all just
bringing our data together and we can
see here if we do
we print the boston panda's head
we can see here all of our different
aspects we're looking for
and if you're following the x and the y
the x
is everything except for the last column
where y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column
and then y is all the rows but
just the last column so y is our house
price
and the x is the crimson industry
chas knox and all these other different
statistics they've collected for house
sales in boston
there we go oops control
so we'll go ahead and split our data x
train and our x
test y train y test equals the train
test split
which we imported and we have our boston
you could have easily used the x and y
on here as opposed to boston
eye location and we'll create our test
size we're going to take 25 percent of
the data and put it in as a test
and then we'll go ahead and run this
i need an extra drink there so we have
our training test
and then of course the print the train
data shape
i love doing this kind of thing whenever
i'm working with this data
print out the shape make sure everything
looks correct
so that we have 127 by 13 and 127 by one
379 by 13 they should match
and if they're if the the data sets are
not quite
matching then you know something's wrong
and you're going to get all those errors
i don't know how many times i've gone
through here and it's dropped a row on
one of them and not on the other or
something weird has happened when i'm
cleaning the data
this is pretty straightforward and
simple because the data comes in a nice
pre-package is all clean for you
so let's go ahead and apply apply the
multiple
linear regression model
and we'll call this lreg l reg
linear regression and we're going to go
ahead and fit that linear regression
model to
x train and y train then we'll generate
the prediction on the test set
so here's our l reg y predict
with our x test going into the
prediction
and let's calculate that mean square
error mse
i told you you'll see mse used a lot um
people use it in variables and things
like that it's pretty common and we get
our mean squared error equals
this is just the basic formula we've
already been talking about what's the
difference squared
and then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run this
and you can see when we get through the
end of this we have our mean square
error on test
we have our total and then we have each
column coming down
and at this point unless you really know
the data you're working with it's not
going to mean a whole lot
so if it's in your domain you might be
know what you're looking at when you
see these kinds of numbers coming up uh
but if it's not it's just a bunch of
numbers and that's okay
at least that's okay for this demo uh
and then we're gonna go ahead and plot
these so we can see what's going on
and this is always kind of fun it's
always nice to have a nice visual of
what you're looking at
and you can see here um when we plot the
coefficient scores on here
and we the guys in the back did a great
job putting some pretty colors together
making it look nice
and setting up the columns you can see
here uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient
when i look at a table like this i look
for what has very little
different coefficients they're not using
a huge change in what has huge
changes and that flags you for all kinds
of things as you're working with the
data
but it depends so much on the domain
you're working with
these are great things though as just a
quick look to see what's going on with
your data and what you're looking for
and of course once we look at this now
our motive is to reduce the coefficient
score
so now we want to take these and
bring them down as much as we can and
for that we're going to work with the
ridge regression on here
so let's start by going we're going to
import our ridge model
the red regression from the sklearn
library or the scikit
and we're going to go ahead and train
the model so here's our ridge
r equals alpha equals 1. and i mentioned
that earlier
when i work with the ridge model you'll
see alpha equals 1. if you set alpha
equal to
0 that's a standard linear regression
model so you have alpha equals 1
2 3 4 and you usually use 1 2 or 3 4 and
a standard integer on there
and we'll go ahead and fit the ridge
model on there with our x train and our
y train data
generate a prediction for that for our x
test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error
just like we did before this should all
look familiar
and we'll go ahead and print that out
and we'll look at the ridge coefficients
for our data and see what that looks
like
now if i jump up and down between these
two
you'll get a headache you'll still see
the knox value
let's just look at the knocks because
that was the biggest value it's a minus
nine here
and if we go back up here the knox value
is a minus 18.
so right off the bat i'm seeing a huge
change
um in the biggest coefficient there
so if we're going to do that nice setup
we want to go ahead and just print it
and see what that looks like
there we go and we've uh set up our plot
subplots and again the team put together
some nice colors so it makes it look
good
we're doing an x bar based on the
columns
and our l regress coefficients color
equals color
x spine bottom and so forth uh so just
put together a nice little graph
and you're starting to see uh one this
when you compare this if you put on the
same graph as this one up here
this is up here minus 18. this is at
minus nine
and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above
the same thing with these values here
they might look the same but they're
actually all
almost half the value on here
and then finally you can do the same
thing for the lasso regression
this would all look very similar as far
as what we worked on before
and i'm just going to print that on here
and run it
and again let's go up to knox
look where nox is it's all the way down
to zero
and if we look at our next biggest
coefficient it's minus 0.8
and really here's our 22.73
let me go up here
16.7
and we go up here and we look at the
same number uh 16.69
and so we look at this uh if i was
running this
and doing a working on a project with
this
i would look at these numbers i start
with the 16.69
come down here and compare it to 16.78
69 is better than 7 8. so from the very
beginning we might
start looking at this first model for
over all
predicting but there's other factors
involved
we might know that the knocked value is
central and the other ones aren't quite
as good
and so we might start looking at just
certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have
a certain meaning to us and so forth and
so you look at all those different
items in there again but the bottom
dollar is our first model
did better than our other two models our
mean square error on the test set
continues to come down on this
dimensionality reduction dimensionality
reduction
refers to the technique that reduces the
number of input variables in a data set
and so you can see on the table on the
right shows the orders
made at an automobile parts retailer
the retailer sells different automobile
parts from different companies
and you can see we have company bpex
isomax
and they have the item the tire the axle
an order id
a price number and a quantity in order
to predict the future cells
we find out that using correlation
analysis
that we just need three attributes
therefore we have reduced the number of
attributes
from five to three and clearly we don't
really care about the part number
i don't think the part number would have
an effect on how many tires are bought
and even the store who's buying them
probably does not have an effect on that
in this case that's what they've
actually done is remove those
and we just have the item the tire the
price and the quantity
one of the things you should be taking
away from this is in the scheme of
things
we are in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data
and we're pre-processing the data what
can we do to clean it up
why dimensionality reduction well number
one less dimensions for a given data set
means less computation or training time
that can be really important if you're
trying a number of different models
uh and you're re-running them over and
over again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data
that can start taking days to go through
all those different models
so this is huge this is probably the
hugest part as far as reducing
our data set redundancy is removed after
removing similar entries from the data
set
again pre-processing some of our models
like a neural network if you put in two
of the same data
it might give them a higher weight than
they would if it was just once you want
to get rid of that redundancy
it also increases the processing time if
you have multiple
data coming in space required to store
the data is reduced
so if we're committing this into a big
data
pool we might not send the company that
bought it
why would we want to store two whole
extra columns when we added into that
pool of data
makes the data easy for plotting in 2d
and 3d plots
this is my favorite part very important
you're in your shareholder meeting
you want to be able to give them a
really good clear
and simplified version you want to
reduce it down to something people can
take in
it helps to find out the most
significant features and skip the rest
which also comes in in post scribing
leads to better human interpretation
that kind of goes with number four what
makes data easy for plotting
you have a better interpretation when
we're looking at it principle component
analysis
so what is it a principal component
analysis is a technique for reducing the
dimensionality of data sets
increasing interpretability but at the
same time
minimizing information loss so we take
some very complex data set with lots of
variables
we run it through the pca we reduce the
variables we end up with a reduced
variable setup
this is very confusing to look at
because
if you look at the end result we have
the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from
so if we come up here we look at this we
say okay this is you know one angle
we get the back of a lot of heads not
many faces
so we'll do it from here we might get
the one person up front smiling
a lot of the people in the class are
missing so we have a huge amount off to
the right of blank space
maybe from up here again we have the
back of someone's head
and it turns out that the best angle to
click the picture from
might be this bottom left angle you look
at it you say hey that makes sense it's
a good
configuration of all the people in the
picture now when we're talking about
data it's not you really can't do it by
what you think is going to be the best
we need to have some kind of
mathematical
formula so it's consistent and so it
makes sense in the back end
one of the projects i worked on many
years ago
has something similar to the iris if
you've ever done the iris data sets
probably one of the
most common ones out there where they
have the flower
and they're measuring the stamen in the
petals and they have width and they have
length of the petal
instead of putting through the width and
the length of the petal
we could just as easily do the
width to length ratio we can divide the
width by the length and you get a single
number where you had two
that's the kind of idea that's going on
into this in pre-processing and looking
at what we can do to bring the data down
the very simplified example on my iris
pedal example when we look at the
similarity
in pca we find the best picture or
projection of the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there
we can see these data points based on in
this case just two variables now keep in
mind
we're usually talking about 36 40
variables
almost all of your business models
usually have about 26 to 27 different
variables they're looking at same thing
with like a bank loan model we're
talking 26 to 36 different variables
they're looking at that are going in
so we want to do is we want to find the
best view in this case we're just
looking at the x y
we look down at it and we have our
second
idea pc2 and again we're looking at the
x i this
x y this time from a different direction
here for our e's we can consider that we
get
two principal components namely pc1 and
pc2
comparing both the principal components
we find the data points are sufficiently
spaced in
pc1 so if you look at what we got here
we have
pc1 you can see along the line how the
data points are spaced versus the
spacing in pc2
and that's what they're coming up with
what is going to give us the best look
for these data points when we combine
them and we're looking at them from just
a single angle
whereas in pc2 they are less spaced
which makes the observation and further
calculations much
more difficult therefore we accept the
pc1 and not the pc2 as the data points
are more spaced
now obviously the back end calculations
are a little bit more
complicated when we get into the math of
how they decide
what is more valuable this gives you an
idea though that when we're talking
about this we're talking about the
perspective
which would help in understanding how
pca analysis works
we want to go ahead and do is dive into
the important terminologies under
pca and important terminologies are
views
the perspective through which data
points are observed
and so you'll hear that if someone's
talking about a pca presentation
and they're not taking the time to
reduce it to something that the
average person shareholders can
understand you might hear them refer to
it as the different views what view are
we taking
dimension number of columns in a data
set are called the dimensions of that
data set
and we talked about you'll hear features
dimensions
i was talking about features there's
usually when you're running a business
you're talking 25 26 27 different
features
minimal and then you have the principal
component new variables that are
constructed as
linear combinations or mixtures of the
initial variables
principal component is very important
it's a combination
if you remember my flower example it
would be the
width over the length of the petal as
opposed to putting both width and length
in you just put in
the ratio instead which is a single
number versus two separate numbers
projections the perpendicular distance
between the principal component
and the data points and that goes to
that line
we had earlier it's that right angle
line of where those point
how those points fall onto the line
important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of attributes
that just makes common sense you're not
going to do
10 principal properties with only three
features
you're trying to reduce them so it's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw
weird code out there and just randomly
do stuff with instead of really thinking
it through
principle components are orthogonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line
when we when we do pc1 we're looking at
how those
points fall on to that line same thing
with pc2
we want to make sure that pc1 does not
equal pc2 we don't want to have the same
two principal points
when we do two points the priority of
principal components
decreases as their numbers increase
this is important to understand if
you're going to
create uh one principle
component everything is summarized into
that one component
as we go to two components the priority
how much it holds value decreases as we
go down so if you have five different
points
each one of those points is going to
have less value than just the one point
which has everything summarized in it
how pca works i said there was more in
the back end we talked about the math
this is what we're talking about is how
does it actually work
so now we have understanding that you're
looking at a perspective
uh now we want to see how that math side
works pca performs the following
operations in order to evaluate
the principal components for a given
data set
first we start with the standardization
then we have a covariance matrix
computation
and we use that to generate our i gene
vectors and i gene
values which is the feature vector
and if you remember the i gene vector is
like a translation
for moving the data from x
equals one to x equals two or whatever
we're altering it and the igen value is
the final value that we generate
when we talk about standardization the
main aim of this step is to standardize
the range of the attributes so that each
one of them
lie within similar boundaries this
process involves removal of the mean
from the variable
values and scaling the data with respect
to the standard deviation
and you can see here we have z equals
the variable values minus the mean
over the standard deviation the
covariance matrix
computation covariance matrix is used to
express the correlation between any
two or more attributes in
multi-dimensional data set
the covariance matrix has the entries as
the variance and the covariance of the
tribute values
the variance is denoted by var and the
covariance is denoted by
cove on the right we can see the
covariance matrix for two attributes and
their values
when we do a hands-on and look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like
for now you can just notice that this is
a matrix that we're generating with the
variance and then the covariance of x to
y
on the right side we can see the
covariance table for more than two
attributes in a multi-dimensional data
set
this is what i was talking about we
usually are looking at not just one
feature
two features we're usually looking at 25
30 features going on and so if we do
a setup like this we should see all
those different features as the
different variables
covariance matrix tells us how the two
or more variables are related
positive covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is directly
proportional to the other variable
negative covariance indicate that the
value of one variable is
inversely proportional to the other
variable that is always important to
note whenever we're doing any of these
matrixes that we're going to be looking
at that positive and negative whether
it's inverted or not
and then we have the i gene values and
the i gene vectors
i gene values and hygiene vectors are
the mathematical value
that are extracted from the covariance
table
they are responsible for the generation
of a new set of variables from the old
set of variables
which further lead to the construction
of the principal components
igen vectors do not change directions
after linear transformation
igine values are the scalars or the
magnitude of the
gene vectors and again this is just
chain transforming that data so we're
going to change
uh the vector b to the b
prime as denoted on the chart and so
we have like multiple variables how do
we calculate that new variable
and then we have feature vectors feature
vectors is simply
a matrix that has hygiene vectors of the
components that we decide to keep as the
columns
here we decide whether we must keep or
discard the less significant principal
components that we have generated in the
above steps
this becomes really important as we
start
looking at the back end of this and
we'll do this in the
demo but one of the more important steps
to understand
and so we have the pca example consider
matrix x within rows or observations and
k
columns or variables now for this matrix
we would construct a variable space with
as many dimensions
as the variable but for our simplicity
let's consider this three dimensions for
now
now each observation row of the matrix x
is placed in the k-dimensional variable
space such that the rows in the data
table
form a swarm of points in this space
now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the plot
the first principal component is a line
that best accounts for the shape of the
point swarm
it represents the maximal variance
direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1
this value is known as a score
usually only one principal component is
insufficient to model the systematic
variation for a data set
thus a second principal axis is created
the second principle component is
oriented such that it reflects the
second
largest source of variation in the data
while being orthogonal to pc1 pc2
also passes through the average point
let's go
ahead and pull this up and just see what
that means
inside our python scripting
i'm going to use the anaconda navigator
and i will be in python 3.6
for this example i believe there's even
like a 3.9 out
i tend to stay in 3.6 because a lot of
the models i use
especially with the neural networks are
stable in 3 6.
and then we open up our jupiter i'm in
chrome
and we go ahead and create a new python
3.
and for ease of use our team in the back
was nice enough to put this together for
me
and we'll go and start with the
libraries the first thing i like to do
whenever i'm looking at
any new setup well you know what let's
do let's do the libraries first
we're going to do our basic libraries
which is matplot library
the plt from the matplot library pandas
our data frame pd numpy our numbers
array np
seaborn for graphing sns that goes with
the
plot that actually sits on matplot
library so the seaborn sits on there
and then we have our amber sign because
we're in jupiter notebook matplot
library in line
the newer version actually doesn't
require that but i put it in there
either
anyway just because i'm so used to it
and then we want to go ahead and take a
look at the
data and in this case we're going to
pull
in certainly you can have lots of fun
with different data but we're going to
use the cancer data set
and one of the reasons the cancer data
set is it has like 36 35 different
features
so it's kind of fun to use that as our
base for this
and we'll go ahead and run this and look
at our keys
and the first thing we notice in our
keys for the cancer data set
is we have our data we have our target
our frame target names description
feature names and file name
so what we're looking for in all this is
well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on here
i'm not going to spend a huge amount of
time on the description
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain
we want to focus on our pca setup uh
what's important is you start looking at
what the different attributes are what
they mean
um if you were in the medical field
you'd want to note all these different
things whether what they're measuring
where it's coming from
you can actually see the actual
different measurements they're taking
no missing attributes
we page all the way to the bottom and
you're going to have your data
in this case our target and if you dig
deep enough to the target
let's actually do this let's go ahead
and print
target names
real quick here i always like to just
take a look and see what's on the other
end of this
target names
run that yeah
so the target name is is it malignant or
is it b9
so in other words is this uh dangerous
growth or is it something we don't have
to worry about that's the bottom line
with the cancer in this case
and then we can go ahead and load our
data and
you know let me go up a just a notch
here for easy of reading
it's hard to get that just right that's
all you have to do
so let's go ahead and look at our data
uh our we're going to use our pandas
and we're going to go ahead and do our
data frame it's going to equal cancer
data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we
already loaded the
the names up of our of the features in
there what is going to come out of this
let me just see if we can get to that
it's at the top of target names
that's just this list of names here in
the setup
and we can go ahead and run this code
and it'll print the head and you can see
here we have the mean radius the mean
texture
mean perimeter i don't know about you
this is a wonderful
data set if you're playing with it
because like many of the data that
most of the data that comes in half the
time we don't even know what we're
looking at
uh we're just handed a bunch of stuff as
a data scientist going what the heck is
this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there we have no idea what
these feature means or where they come
from
we want to just look at the data and
figure that out
and now we actually are getting into the
pca side of it
as we've noticed before is difficult to
visualize high dimensional data
we can use pca to find the first two
principal components
and visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space
with a single scatter plot before we do
this we need to go ahead and scale our
data
now i haven't run this to see if you
really have to scale the data on this
but as just a general
run time i almost do that as the first
step of any
modeling even if it's pre-modeling as
we're doing here
in neural networks that is so important
with pca visualization
it's already going to scale it when we
do the means and deviation inside the
pca
but just in case it's always good to
scale it
and then we're going to take our pca
with the scikit
learn uses very similar process to other
pre-processing functions that come with
scikit-learn
we instantiate a pca object find the
principal components using the fit
method
then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction
by calling transform we can also specify
how many components we want to keep when
creating the pca object
and so the code for this
oops getting a little bit ahead let me
go and run this code
uh so the code for this is
from sklearn decomposition import pca
pca equals pca in components equals two
and that's really important to note that
because we're only going to want to look
at two components
i would never go over four components
especially if you're going to demo this
with somebody else
if you're showing this to the
shareholders the whole idea is to reduce
it to something people can see
and then the pca fit we're going to is
going to take the
scaled data that we generated up here
and then you can see we've created our
pca model with in components equals 2.
now whenever i use a new tool
i like to go in there and actually see
what i'm using so let's go to the scikit
webpage for the pca
and you can see in here here's our call
statement it describes what all the
different uh
setups you have on there probably the
biggest one to look at would be
well the biggest one is your components
how many components do you want
which you have to put in there pretty
much and then you also might look at the
svd solver it's on auto right now but
you can override that and do different
things with it
it does a pretty good job as it is
and if we go down all the way down to
there we go to our methods if you notice
we have fit
we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not
used for prediction it's used to look at
the data again we're in the describe
setup
we're fitting the data we're taking a
look at it we've already looked at
our minimum maximum we've already looked
at what's in each quarter
we've done a full description of the
data this is part of describing
the data that's the biggest thing i take
away when i come
zooming in here and of course i have
examples of it down here if you forget
and the biggest one of course is the
number of components
and then i mean the rest you can play
with
the actual solver whether you're doing a
full or randomize there's different
things
it does pretty good on the auto
and now we can transform this data to
its first two
principal components
and so we have our xpca
we're going to set that equal to pca
transform
scaled data so there we go there's our
first transformation
and let's just go ahead and print the
scaled data shape
and the xpca data shape
and the reason we want to do this is
just to show us
what's going on here we've taken 30
features
i think i said 36 or something like that
but it's 30
and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from
we still have 569 data sets
i mean data rows data sets we still have
569 rows of data
but instead of computing 30 features
we're now only doing our model on
two features
so let's go ahead and plot these and
take a look and see what's going on
and
we're just going to use our plt figure
we'll set the figure size on here
here's our scatter plot xpca
x underscore pca of 1
these are two different perceptions
we're using
and then you'll see right here c for
color
cancer equals target and so remember we
have
zero we have one and if i remember
correctly
zero was malignant one was b9
uh so everything in the zero column is
going to be one color and the other
color is going to be
one and then we're going to use the
plasma map just kind of telling you what
color it is
add some labels first principle
component second principal component
and we'll go ahead and run this and you
can see here
instead of having a chart one of those
heat maps with 30 different
columns in it we can look at this and
say hey
this one actually did a pretty good job
of separating the data
and a couple things when i'm looking at
this that i notice
is first we have a very clear area
where it's clumped together where it's
going to be
benign and we have a huge area it's
still clumped together more spread out
where it's going to be
malignant or i think i had that
backwards and then in the middle
because we're dealing with something in
this particular case
cancer we would try to separate i would
be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out
in other words there's an area where
everything overlaps and we're not going
to have a clear result on it
uh just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently versus going in
and saying just cutting into the can
into the cancer so the body absorbs it
and it dissipates
versus uh actively going in there
removing it
testing it going through chemo and all
the different things
that's a big difference you know as far
as what's going to happen here
and that middle line where the overlap
is going to be huge
that's domain specific going back to the
data
we can see here clearly by using these
two components we can easily separate
these two classes so the next step is
what does that mean
interpreting the components
unfortunately with this great power of
dimensionality reduction
comes the cost of not being able to
easily understand what these components
represent
i don't know what principle component
one looks work represents or second
principle
the components correspond to
combinations of original features
the components themselves are stored as
an attribute of the filtered pca
object and so we talk look at that we
can go ahead and do uh look at the pca
components
this is in our model we built we've
trained it we can run that
and you can see here's the actual
components uh it's
the two components have each have their
own array
and within the array you can see the
what the scores are using
and these actually give weight to what
features
are doing what so in this
numpy matrix array each row represents a
principal component and each column
relates back to the original features
what's really neat about this
is we can now go in reverse
and drop this onto a heat map and start
seeing uh what this means and so let me
go ahead and just
put this down i've already got it down
here
uh we'll go ahead and put this in here
we're going to use our
df comp data frame and we do our pca
components
and i want you to notice how easy this
is
we're going to set our columns equal to
cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy and we're
dumping it into a data frame what's neat
about a data frame
is when we get to seaborn it will pull
that data frame apart
and and set it up for us we want
and so we're just going to do the cn the
seaborn heat map
of our data frame composition and we'll
use the plasma coloring
and it creates a nice little color graph
here
you can see we have the mean radius and
all the different features along the
bottom
on the right we have a scale so we can
see we have the dark colors all the way
to
the really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look at
so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features
and the principal component itself
so you know very powerful map to look at
and then you can go in here
and we might notice that the mean radius
look how on the bottom of the map it is
um
on some of this so you have some
interesting
correlations here that change the
variations on that and what means what
this is more when you get to a post
scribe you can also use this to try to
guess as
what these things mean and what you want
to change to get a better result
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more today we have a really
interesting topic for you
in this video we'll be analyzing the
upcoming united states presidential
election using twitter sentiment
analysis in python
in the course of this session we will
understand in brief about the upcoming
election
the candidates fighting the 2020 u.s
election and throw light on the result
of the 2016 u.s election
we look at the election forecast by some
of the popular news agencies
as well as poll analysis websites such
as 538
before we begin i want to make it clear
that this video is solely for learning
purposes
we at simply learn do not lean towards
any party in the united states or are
biased towards any candidate
the analysis is based on what people
have tweeted and we will understand the
mood and sentiment of the public
the main objective of this video is to
help you understand how to extract
tweets from twitter handles using python
libraries
store it in a csv file and perform
textual analysis
the results obtained are purely based on
the data that we have collected
let's begin
the battle for the 2020 u.s presidential
election has begun with the 59th united
states presidential election scheduled
to be held on the 3rd of november 2020
this will decide who will be in the
white house for the next four years
all 435 seats in the united states house
of representatives
35 of seats in the united states senate
and office of the president of the
united states will be contested
both the republican party and the
democratic party have nominated their
respective president and vice
presidential candidates
the incumbent president donald trump is
the republican nominee
while the 47th vice president of the
united states joe biden is the
democratic party's nominee
the current vice president mike pence is
the republican party's vice presidential
nominee
and is running for a second term in
office
senator kamala harris of california was
chosen by joe biden as his running mate
on 11th of august 2020.
now let's see the results of the last
u.s presidential election in 2016.
the republican ticket of businessman
donald trump and indiana governor mike
pence
had defeated the democratic ticket of
former secretary of state hillary
clinton and u.s senator from virginia
tim kaine donald trump received
a total of 304 electoral votes while
hillary clinton got 227 electoral votes
a significant number of central states
in the united states were swept
by the republican party it was
surprising to see that donald trump
getting nearly 46.4 popular vote
as compared to hillary clinton who got
48.5
votes donald trump's victory came after
crucial wins
in the battleground streets of florida
ohio iowa
north carolina and pennsylvania
will donald trump be re-elected to the
white house or are we going to see a new
president and
vice president of the united states is
the big question
let's see what our pollsters have to say
and what has been their forecast for the
upcoming election
according to 538 donald trump has not
gained
ground since the final debate on 22nd of
october
at this moment joe biden is favored to
win the election
and he leads in both national and state
pools
the economist is analyzing polling
economic and demographic data to predict
the u.s elections
their model thinks joe biden is very
likely to beat donald trump in the
electoral college
as per their forecast joe biden has 96
percent chance of winning the electoral
college
and this 99 percent chance of biden
winning the most votes
the democrats have 75 chance of
controlling the senate
while the republicans have around 25
percent
the democrats are highly likely to keep
their majority in the house of
representatives
now according to the guardian joe biden
is leading donald trump
in the national polls for the
presidential election but to keep in
mind
this does not guarantee the democratic
candidate joe biden's victory
hillary clinton also had a clear lead
over donald trump in the polls for
almost the entire
2016 campaign she ended up losing the
electoral college
now the bbc forecast tells that biden is
leading national presidential polls
with 51 percent he has hovered around 50
in recent months and has had a 10-point
lead on occasions
so clearly joe biden is set to be the
next u.s president
let's wait and watch what happens on the
3rd of november
the voters of america will decide on 3rd
of november whether donald trump remains
in the white house for another four
years
let's perform a twitter sentiment
analysis to understand the sentiments of
people tweeting about donald trump and
joe biden
by tagging them in their tweets we have
our code implemented already
i'll run through each line of code and
explain our analysis in detail
the objective is to check the polarity
of each tweet to figure out if it's
positive
negative or neutral we'll compare the
tweets of donald trump and joe biden
to see who people are favoring the most
finally
we learn to create a word cloud i have
already extracted the tweets and stored
them in two separate csv files
it takes some time to fetch 10 000
tweets hence it won't be possible for me
to show it to you live
if you want to know how we extracted the
tweets for donald trump and joe biden
then please put your email ids in the
comments section of the video
we'll share the code file and the source
file with you now you would need to
install the tweepy library
fetch the twitter keys and access tokens
and then authenticate the twitter api
i've extracted 5000 tweets each for
donald trump and joe biden
converted into a data frame and stored
it in a csv file
so let me open and show you both the
files so here is my data set for donald
trump on the top you can see
trump underscore data 5000 which means
there are
5000 tweets here the first column
has the number of tweets it starts from
zero and
goes all the way to 4919
the next column is the text column which
has the content of the tweet
you can see they have tagged
at the rate real donald trump there are
links as well
there are special characters like
emoticons
and the third column is the user
which means it's the user name who had
put that tweet
similarly i have another data for
biden you can see these are
for joe biden and here you can see the
content they have tagged kamala harris
also
similarly we have the username now let
me take you straight to my jupyter
notebook
where i have implemented the code okay
so first and foremost let's import all
the required libraries
so we have the numpy library for
numerical computation
then we have the pandas library for data
manipulation
next we are importing two libraries
matplotlib
and c bond for data visualization
then we have text blob and word cloud
to get the sentiment and to build the
word cloud
and finally we are importing the plotly
library for creating graphs
let me run this cell in the current cell
we'll import the data sets using read
underscore csv function
present in the pandas library so i have
passed in my
location where the data file is so i
placed it on my desktop
and the index underscore
col parameter or column parameter refers
to the columns to be used as the row
labels of the data frame
here 0 indicates that the first column
will be used
as row labels let me run it
ok now we have imported both the data
files
let me go ahead and print the shape of
one of the data frames so i'll write
print
let's say we'll check the shape of biden
data frame so i'll write
print by then dot shape
i'll hit shift enter you can see there
are
5000 rows and there are two columns one
is the text column and the next column
is the user column
now let me go ahead and print
the head of the datasets so the head
function will
return the first five rows i'll write
trump dot
head you can see
these are the first five rows from the
trump
data frame and similarly if you want to
check for
biden i can write biden dot head
you can see it here now you can also use
the info method so let me
show you that you can write drum dot
info
and this is the result so it tells there
are 5000 entries from 0 to
4999 there are two columns
these are the number of rows
and similarly you have the data types
okay moving ahead in the next cell i am
displaying the
200th tweet present in the trump data
frame
so i have my data frame name mentioned
then i have
my text column and inside one more
square bracket i have put 200 which
means i want to see what's there
in the 200th row if i hit enter
so you can see this was the tweet fake
[ __ ]
fake president next
let me show you the tweet number 1000
for
biden so i'll write biden
and inside square brackets i'll give the
text column
and the number is 1000
if i hit shift enter so this is the
tweet
now the text blob function
is used in natural language processing
the sentiment property returns a named
tuple in the form of
sentiment in brackets polarity
and subjectivity let's check the
sentiment
of the 200th tweet made for donald trump
if i hit shift enter you can see this
was the polarity
now minus 0.399 means
the polarity was negative and you can
see the subjectivity is around
0.933 similarly
let's check for biden's tweet number
1000
so i'll write text
blob which is my function name and
inside brackets i'll give biden
then pass in my column name that is text
and i'll give the row number which is
1000
and then i'll give the
parameter or the attribute sentiment
if i hit shift enter you can see the
polarity and the subjectivity
now moving ahead here
i have defined a function that will add
another column called polarity
to our two data frames trump and biden
let me run this okay
in the next cell i have used the apply
function that will return the polarity
based on the tweets
you can see we have the apply function
this might take some time to run it okay
we are done now
let me now display the top five rows of
the data frame
so what i'll do is i'll click on this
cell
go to insert and i'll hit
insert cell below let's do one more
okay now here i'll display the head of
the data frame once again so that you
can see the polarity column added you
can see it here
so for donald trump we have the polarity
you can see the tweet and the polarity
now 0.0
which means these are neutral minus is
negative and anything that's in positive
value
indicates it's a positive tweet or it
has positive polarity
similarly let's see for biden
i'll write biden.head
okay so here you can see the polarity
for biden
now this point five means it's a
positive tweet
okay now i want to create another column
called expression
where we will classify the tweets as
positive negative or neutral
based on the polarity value so i have
used the np dot where function
and the condition we have here is if
polarity is greater than 0
it's a positive tweet else if it is less
than 0
it's a negative to it and if the
polarity is equal to 0
it means it's a neutral tweet let me run
this
ok so here you can see we have the
column
called expression and it has classified
the polarity
based on negative neutral
as well as positive
similarly let's do the same for biden
data frame as well
okay
before moving ahead if you want to get
access to the source code and the data
sets we have used in this demo
then please put your email address in
the chat section we'll send it to you
via mail
also please subscribe to simply launch
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn
in the next cell of code we have another
function
that will basically help us creating a
bar plot based on the expression column
from both the data frames so this is my
user defined function name and it has
two
parameters reviews and title
you can see we have
grouped the expression column and found
out the count using the count function
then we have created or converted it
into a list
similarly below you can see here
we have defined the color for the bars
using rgb values now let me run it
okay so we have successfully created our
user defined function
now let me go ahead and call the
function and pass in my two parameters
reviews and title
so here we have the function name
and under reviews we have the data frame
name
trump and the title we have given is
analysis for trump
let me run this okay
so you can see we have a horizontal bar
plot
on the top you can see the title of the
plot which is analysis for trump
and as per the tweets it has classified
as positive
neutral or negative if i hover over you
can see
there were 2 831 neutral tweets
1211 positive tweets and similarly there
were
958 negative tweets for donald trump
now let me call that
function once again so i'll write exp
underscore
graph which is my function name
then i'll pass in my parameters this
time i'll take biden
and the title i'll put is analysis
for biden
if i run it okay you can see the
plot for biden now if i hover over
there were 1290 positive tweets
for biden and 747 negative tweets
okay let's
scroll down now let me check
the number of rows that have polarity
equal to 0
the number of rows that have polarity
less than 0 and greater than 0 for both
the data frames
using the dot shape attribute
so first we have for trump
now equal to equal to 0 means we are
checking the total number of
neutral tweets you can see the result
now let's check for biden we have the
result
below let me run it
okay
now we'll drop those columns
that have a polarity equal to zero from
both the data frames and display the
shape
you can see we have the condition
mentioned
and we have also used the drop function
so all the neutral tweets will be
deleted and i am printing the
shape of the data frame
there you go so out of the 5000 tweet it
has deleted all the neutral tweets or
dropped all the neutral treats and this
is the final result
in the current cell we have defined
another function
called balanced underscore data now this
will help us get an equal number of rows
and columns and delete a specified
number of rows
let me run it all right
now i'll call that function to delete
169 rows from the trump's data frame
and 37 rows from biden's data frame
this will help us subset the data frames
you can see we have now
2000 tweets from each of the data frames
up next we will create some
visualizations to analyze the textual
data
so first i'm using the c bond library
and creating
a distribution plot for donald trump
if i hit shift enter you can see
this is the distribution plot thus there
are bars at the back and there's a trend
line
okay similarly let me now create a box
plot
so this is a box plot here you can see
there are some outliers
now let me add a few cells
below so that i can show that plot for
biden
so i'll write sns dot
i'll use the function dist plot
and under this plot i'll give
biden underscore subset
and i'll pass in my column that is
polarity let me run it
so this is the distribution plot for joe
biden
and now
let me also create the box plot so i'll
use the c bond library and the box plot
function
i'll pass in my data frame which is
biden underscore
subset and i'll give my
column name that is polarity i'll run it
so here you can see the box plot for joe
biden
let me tell you how you can create a
cross table using the group by function
so before coming to this cell of code
let me insert
cell above okay
now using group by function you can
create a cross table
so i'll use the trump underscore
subset data frame
and then i'll give my group by function
and inside group by function i'll give
my expression column
and i'll count the number of expressions
if i run this you can see this is a
cross table
similarly you can do it for joe biden as
well
i'll just replace the names i'll write
biden and the rest is
the same you can see
this is the cross table for biden
underscore subset
now moving ahead
let's find the polarity percentage for
negative and positive tweets
to do this i have defined a function
called
pole underscore percent and we have two
parameters declared
subset and total
let me run this ok
now here i am calling the above defined
function and printing the polarity
percentage for biden and trump
and i have mentioned my two parameters
subset
and the total number so these are the
values
moving ahead
now let's create a bar graph that will
show the negative and positive polarity
percentage for donald trump
and joe biden
let me hit shift enter you can see
we have a really good bar
graph now if i hover the mouse cursor
you can see donald trump had 27.825
percent of positive tweets and
22.17 negative similarly joe biden had
31.6 positive tweets and
18.4 negative tweets
now we want to find the public sentiment
based on trump and biden tweets
let me run this two cells first
okay now for donald trump
the total positive polarity is a
combination of trump's
total positive percentage and biden's
negative percentage
similarly for joe biden the total
positive polarity is a combination of
guidance
total positive percentage and trump's
negative percentage let me run this
you can see the result here next
let's plot a horizontal bar graph to
visualize the public sentiment
we have our x and y labels defined
we also have set our bar colors with the
help of
rgb values and we have the title as well
now if i go up you can see this is the
public sentiment
so 26.88 is the percentage that is in
favor of
joe biden and for donald trump you have
23.11
now coming down
now in the next cell of code we have a
user defined function that will
basically
plot a table which has the most positive
tweets for donald trump and joe biden
the condition we are checking is that
the polarity should be
equal to one so if it's close to one or
equal to one which means
the tweet has positive polarity
let me run it
okay now let me go ahead and call the
function now let me scroll over to the
top
you can see these are the top five
positive tweets for donald trump and
here you can see the top five positive
tweets for joe biden
likewise let's check the polarity for
most negative tweets
here the condition will be the polarity
should be
equal to minus 1 which means it's highly
negative
let me run it okay
now let's go ahead and call the function
negative tweets so i'll write neg
underscore tweets
and then inside bracket i'll give my
parameters
which is trump underscore subset
and then i'll give my title as
negative tweets
for donald trump
okay now let's copy this
we'll also check for joe biden so i'll
just replace this with
biden and let's say
negative to it for joe biden
let's run it okay if i go on top
here you can see the top negative tweets
for donald trump
and similarly we have the top five
negative tweets for
joe biden
all right finally
let's see how to create a word cloud now
word cloud is a method to show
which words are most frequently
occurring among the given text
i have defined a function called word
cloud you can see here
and it has two parameters data and title
inside the built-in function or the word
cloud function
we have mentioned the max font size
the maximum words scale value there's
also
background color which is white okay
let's run it now this will create
a word cloud so let me go ahead and
call the word cloud function and pass in
the arguments
so i'll write word cloud which is my
user defined function
and i'll give my parameters trump
underscore
subset comma i'll give my title as
word cloud
for donald trump
let's see donald trump tweet replies
okay similarly
let's do it for joe biden
write word cloud biden underscore
subset and then i'll give the title
as word
cloud for
joe biden to it
replies okay let me run it
there you go you can see we have a nice
word cloud so on the top you can see the
title which says word cloud for donald
trump
tweet replies so here you can see
some of the words like real donald trump
then there's
precedent love right
all these similarly if i scroll down you
can see the word cloud for joe biden
tweet replies you can see
there's the handle joe biden falls there
are some
other words like due taxes belief
even will it's fact
and you can see kamala had his name here
okay
now that brings us to the end of this
demo on twitter sentiment analysis using
text data
you learned how to classify tweets and
find the polarity
we also looked at how to create
interesting visualizations
with this data and understood the mood
of the public
finally you saw how to create a word
cloud that had
the most frequently occurring words in
the tweets
welcome to this video on machine
learning roadmap 2021
ai and machine learning have been the
top burst words in 2020.
machine learning can be an interesting
career move for programmers developers
and other professionals looking for a
shift in their career
over the last few years machine learning
and artificial intelligence together
have become a crucial component in many
of the world's most popular business
applications
as we approach 2021 it's a good time for
us to take a look at the machine
learning roadmap for 2021.
in this video we will discuss the basics
of machine learning and the companies
actively hiring for machine learning
roles
you will understand the skills required
to become a machine learning expert in
2021
the salary of a machine learning
engineer and how simply learn can help
you get certified in machine learning
now let's look at what machine learning
is
machine learning is an application of
artificial intelligence that allows
systems to learn from vast volumes of
data
it enables you to process analyze and
train machines using data and create
models to solve
business problems machine learning has
the potential to learn from structured
semi-structured and unstructured data
there are various supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
algorithms used to build machine
learning models
some of the most popular machine
learning algorithms are linear
regression
logistic regression support vector
machines k nearest neighbors
k-means clustering knife base and others
now some of the top companies hiring for
machine learning roles are microsoft
spotify google cell ericsson
oracle and walmart there are numerous
product based
service based as well as startup
companies that are hiring for machine
learning positions
now learning machine learning can
position an individual for a variety of
exciting careers in a growing number of
industries
with machine learning becoming more
widely accepted and adapted technology
let's look at the important skills you
need to know to become a machine
learning expert in 2021
first we have programming machine
learning mostly depends on algorithms
which means
one should possess sound knowledge of
different programming languages such as
python and r
you should have knowledge of basic
programming concepts and understand data
structures
this will help you write better and
efficient codes you should also know
about
searching sorting and optimization
algorithms the second skill you need to
know is
mathematics and statistics statistics is
the backbone of data analytics
you should have knowledge of various
measures such as mean median variance
etc
distributions such as uniform normal
binomial poison etc
and analysis methods such as anova
manova
t-test chi-square test hypothesis
testing and others
now this is required for building and
validating models from observed data
a basic understanding of high school
mathematics will help you understand how
machine learning algorithms work
the topics include probability linear
algebra and calculus
the third skill you need to know is
database and sql
very often machine learning tasks are
carried out using data stored in the
form of tables
that are present in database servers so
it's important to know about databases
and sql
good understanding of relational
databases and nosql databases such as
mysql
postgresql oracle database microsoft sql
server is vital to store manipulate
retrieve and handle structured data now
we have data wrangling
now there's a lot of pre-processing of
data that is needed before you start
building your machine learning model
collecting the data cleaning it
identifying the problems
asking the right questions and
formatting the data are crucial steps in
machine learning
you should have knowledge of libraries
and packages such as numpy
pandas plier deep flyer and idea to
perform data wrangling
next we have data visualization while
working on any machine learning problem
it's important to understand the data
well data visualization and exploratory
data analysis skills are very important
to show the hidden trends and insights
in a visual form
using various charts and graphs this
will help you find out unseen patterns
in the data
you need to have experience with
matplotlib c-bond plotly and ggplot
libraries
it would be an advantage to know bi
tools such as tableau and power bi
finally the most important skill is
machine learning itself
you need to learn different machine
learning techniques and algorithms that
are widely used to solve business
problems
then implement the algorithms using
python and r libraries
such as scikit-learn tensorflow garrett
and mlr
having knowledge of natural language
processing computer vision and time
series analysis would be a really good
advantage
to gain more experience in solving real
world problems you need to work on small
projects using variety of data sets
data science and machine learning
challenges such as those on github and
kegel
are a great way to get exposed to
different kinds of problems and their
nuances
now talking about the salary of a
machine learning engineer
according to glassdoor in the united
states a machine learning engineer can
earn around
114 thousand dollars per annum while in
india
you can earn nearly 7 lakh 73 000 rupees
per annum
this salary may vary based on your
experience the industry you are applying
for and the company policy
now moving on to the final section let
me tell you how simply learn can help
you start your career in machine
learning
so let me take you to our website first
okay so i am on the chrome browser
let me search for simplylearn.com
and here under what you want to learn
let me type
machine learning it will show me the
relevant courses that simply learn
offers
in the machine learning category so you
can see here
there are multiple courses first let me
open the
first link
and let's open the second link as well
so so this is the postgraduate program
in ai and machine learning
which is in collaboration with purdue
university and ibm
if i scroll down
you can see the key features of this
course so we'll get purdue alumni
association membership
industry recognized ibm certificates
enrollment to simply launch job assist
there's 25 plus hands-on projects on
gpu-enabled labs you have
450 plus hours of applied learning
capstone projects in three domains
and much more
and here you can see on the right this
is the certificate that you will get
after completing this program
and you will also get certificates
recognized by ibm
and another key feature of this course
is you can enroll to simply learn job
assist program so you will get im jobs
crew membership for six months
resume assistance and career monitoring
as interview preparation and career
affairs
if i scroll further here you can see the
learning path
and you will learn about python for data
science
this machine learning deep learning with
tensorflow and keras that's advanced
deep learning and computer vision
you will also learn about natural
language processing that is nlp and
speech recognition
we have reinforcement learning and you
also have the opportunity to select a
few electives so we have
ibm watson for chat bots machine
learning with r there's git and github
training
and two others here you can see
the skills that will be covered so you
will learn about statistics which is a
core component of machine learning
we learn about python supervised
learning there's dance computer vision
tensorflow there's reinforcement
learning speech recognition you will
also learn about numpy pandas and other
libraries
and here you can see these are some of
the tools that will be covered in this
course
if i scroll further now this is the
important section you can see the
industry projects that you will get to
work on
so this is on twitter there's one on
zumato
one on uber and mercedes benz as well
now they are our course advisors so
please go ahead and enroll to this
postgraduate program in ai machine
learning if you want to kick start your
career in
machine learning now the next course we
have is machine learning certification
course
if i scroll down you can see the details
of this course
so you will gain expertise with 25 plus
hands-on exercises
you will get to work on four real-life
industry-based projects with integrated
labs
there will be dedicated mentoring
sessions from industry experts
44 hours of instructor led training with
certification
here on the right you can see the skills
that will be covered
so we learn about time series modeling
linear and logistic regression
you will also learn about support vector
machines games clustering knife base
decision trees
random forest and you learn the concepts
of
bagging and boosting and deep learning
fundamentals as well
here you can see the course content
and if i scroll further now these are
the projects that you'll get to work on
and finally you'll receive this
certificate once you complete the course
thank you all for watching this full
course video tutorial on machine
learning with python
i hope you liked it if you have any
questions then please put them in the
comments section
our team will help you solve your
queries thanks again stay tuned for more
from simply loan
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here